[музика]
spech
spe
[музика]
Why
spe Oh ye
[музика]
but you like The Sounds of
ja Do you like The ss of ja
[музика]
южи южи южи
Good Yes
[музика]
ж
[оплески]
[музика]
What like
Jazz
[музика]
likeic
music
music jaz music
Yeah
[музика]
дорогі друзі Буквально за кілька хвилин
ми почнемо наш форум Хочу звернути вашу
увагу поки є така
можливість Ось я тут Всім привіт добрий
вечір доброго дня добрий вечір доброго
дня в процесі форуму У вас будуть
виникати питання в процесі доповідей ви
будете слухати спікерів і я більш ніж
переконаний що питань буде досить багато
Саме тут ви можете їх складати ось тут і
в третій завершальній частині третій
панелі Ви потримате
отримаєте повні досконалі відповіді на
свої питання також хочу сказати
що радий вітати сьогодні тут присутніх
представників не тільки Одеської
Миколаївської Херсонської а також
Кіровоградської і Полтавської
областей я сподівався що на якусь
область будуть
облиськи і мені дивно що Одеса мовчала
Одеса зазвичай не не така скромна
давайте ще раз представники
Одеської в більшості
[оплески]
Херсонської
Миколаївської ви розумієте між херсоном
і миколаєм завжди було оце от змагальні
моменти
Кіровоградської
в мене таке враження що Кіровоградська
область так розсмокталася серед інших
областей і просить сусідівплескати за
свою
область Полтавська
[оплески]
область Сергій Рафаїлович А це точно
відбувається в Одесі Я перепрошую
губернатора не
бачив друзі одним словом питання будуть
виникати це місце де їх можна складати
отримати врешті-решт відповідь
переконаний що тема сьогоднішнього
форуму надзвичайно важлива для кожного з
тут присутніх тому що не дивлячись на
ваші посади Не дивлячись на всю
відповідальність яку ви несете на роботі
в першу чергу найбільша відповідальність
у кожного з вас і в мене також це
відповідальність перед дитиною перед
дітьми і здорова нація здорові діти - це
основа основ тому я сподіваюся що другий
регіональний форум який проходить в
гостинному місті Одеса буде корисним і
по дозволить провести
злагоджену комунікацію між Центральною
владою а також владою на місцях всім
гарного настрою Сподіваюся за кілька
хвилин ми
почнем ну а поки що давайте ще раз
Оплески всім
присутнім чудовий день берег моря Одеса
що ще може бути
[оплески]
краще
[музика]
[оплески]
Jazz
[музика]
music
Шановні колеги журналісти при всій
повазі до вас час у нас трошки обмежений
тому Дякую за фото-віідеосесію і ми
почнемо з вашого
дозволу
шановні пані па та панове радий вітати
вас в гостиному місті Одеса на березі
Чорного моря сподіваюся у вас сьогодні
гарний настрій сподіваюся у вас є
бажання дізнатися про те що як на мене є
однією з найважливіших реформ
найважливішого з того що ми зробили за
30 років Це
реформа системи шкільного харчування і
це другий форум який відбувається у нас
І думаю що ні для кого не секрет що це
надзвичайно важливо це здоров'я наших
дітей це здоров'я нашої нації це
майбутнє України коротко розповім про те
як буде відбуватися регламент форуму -
це вступна частина потім дві дискусійних
панелі потім
вас очікує напевне можна назвати це
кулінарне шоу тому що прямо на сцені
буде приготовано обід для дітей сьогодні
куштувати його будете ви і оцінювати на
собі наскільки це якісно наскільки це
смачно наскільки це
різноманітно так що голодний сьогодні
ніхто не
залишиться і це надзвичайно приємно
погодьтеся 700 людей сім страв за 45
хвилин то варто буде подивитися і
спробувати але ж попри те не будемо
втрачати часу і перейдемо зразу до
справи ініціатором реформи виступила
перша леді України Олена Зеленська На
жаль сьогодні вона не змогла бути
присутньою тут Але у нас є її
відеозвернення тому шановні пані та
панове увага на екран Вітаю розпочався
новий навчальний рік для дітей це старт
здобуття нових знань а для нас і з вами
не менш важливий період почалася
найбільш активна фаза реформи шкільного
харчування її
імплементація до впровадження нових норм
залишається 3 по місяці я як і ви
схвильована але водночас упевнена в нас
та змінах які ми несемо
ці кілька місяців ми маємо використати
якомога ефективніше адже розпочинається
вдосконалення системи контролю триває
активна модернізація харчоблоків та
популяризація культури здорового
харчування у
суспільстві для того щоб спростити
процес комунікації між ключовими
учасниками у серпні ми запустили серію
регіональних форумів реформи шкільного
харчування і другий з них сьогодні у
вашому місті
Одесі головна мета донести єдине бачення
реформи розповісти про її основні
складові та розподіл завдань і
обов'язків між міністерствами та
органами місцевої
влади Я впевнена що такі зустрічі - це
дієвий майданчик для обговорення
спільних проблем ви зможете почути
детальну інформацію з питань які вас
хвилюють та сподіваюсь отримати на них
відповіді реформа шкільного харчування
стане для вас більш
зрозумілою не забувайте що головна мета-
донести інформацію до шкіл та розпочати
ще активніші роботи все це заради
молодого покоління
українців Я вважаю що на наші плечі
покладено дуже важливе завдання Давайте
зробимо Це разом плідно відповідально та
переконливо
для цього У нас є
все окремо хочу подякувати Одеській Ода
Дякую за те що приймаєте наш форум у
себе та допомагаєте його
Організувати а також дякую національній
асоціації громадського харчування і
міністерству освіти і науки за
координацію підготовки та
проведення а також Дякую усім спікерам
за участь бажаю вам результативної
роботи вірю в нас і Наші
сили шановні пані та панове до вам
вітального слова Я запрошую міністра
освіти і науки України Сергія
[оплески]
шкарлета Доброго дня шановні колеги
Шановні освітяни Сергій рфарилович
Геннадій Леонідович Мої колеги по
Кабміну знаєте перший форум в Бучі
показав що це правильно важливо
необхідно об'єднувати зусилля говорити
але ми сьогодні в славетному місті Одеса
на минулому тижні була 227 річниця з дня
народження цього шанованого прекрасного
міста Я вас вітаю всіх за це з цим
великим
святом є мій колега Міністр охорони
здоров'я Віктор лішко який на вбучі Ну
трошки підтролів мене бо виступ міністра
освіти Завжди такий трошки довгий ми ж
освітяни маємо одну пару відстояти за
трибуною правда він руханку якусь показу
Віктор килович думайте нову бо трошки
затримує вашого часу але
ж сьогодні на регіональному форумі
зновутаки піднімається велике важливе
питання за ініціативою патронатом першої
леді Ми розпочали велику важливу справу
реформу шкільного харчування і це не про
не тільки про їжу це не скажімо про меню
це про майбутнє майбутнє наших дітей про
наші з вами майбутн звички звички
здорового безпечного харчування що в
цілому дасть певний поштох нам після
цього формувати нашу здорову українську
націю є два моменти з одного боку
результати якісь сьогодні вже є вони
дійсно вражаючі І саме головне що ці
результати є зусиллям всіх органів
виконавчої
влади місцевого
самоврядування Міністерство освіти і
науки Міністерство охорони здоров'я
дежав
держпротспоживспілки але і менеджерів
керівників закладів освіти кухарів
батьків і сьогодні оце оцей агломерат це
зусилля дає нам певні
результати
реформа шкільного харчування
відбувається до відповідно до
Національної стратегії розбудови
безпечного здорового середовища яка
схвалена указом Президента України яка
відбувається під патронатом президента
України і першої Леді і наша мета
основне в освіті що є якість доступність
і безпечність саме на цих трьох основних
акцентах тримається взагалі вся освіта
що ж Нам вдалося впродовж останніх років
два роки акти впровадження цієї реформи
дали нам можливість суттєво поліпшити
матеріальну технічну базу і ще в березні
2020 року Міністерство освіти і науки
зробило аналіз і анкетування опитування
більше ніж 45ся респондентів і виділило
400 млн грвень на ремонт для
придбання обладнання їдалень і
харчоблоків найбільше таких проектів
було здійснено в Житомирській області
Вінницькій Волинській Київській полта
всьй і результати субвенції спроможна
школа для кращих результатів були саме в
цих областях найбільше спрямовані на
реформу харчоблоків на сьогодні є 1809
закладів в яких вже повністю оновлені
харчоблоки і за рахунок цих коштів
субвенції спроможна школа вдалося
зробити декілька основних акцентів перше
оновлено повністю застаріле обладнання
проведено часткові та повні ремонти
харчоблоків встановлено або
відремонтовано системи вентиляції та
вентиляційні зонти відремонтовано
електромережі підвищено якість питної
води завдяки встановленню спеціальних
промислових фільтрів я дякую органам
місцевого самоврядування керівникам
обласних державних адміністрацій адже
майже 100 млн грвень було виділено з
місцевих бюджетів на впровадження цієї
реформи це вражаючі Суми І вони дають
свої
результати на сьогодні в нас з 400 млн
виділених державою використано 3 75 млн
що становить
93,8% освоєння цих коштів але ще тільки
Вересень і я сподіваюсь що до кінця року
ми в повному обсязі засвоїмо ці
кошти Тернопільська Кіровоградська
область повністю в повному обсязі
освоїли ці кошти Я дуже дякую
губернаторам за те що активно і
продуктивно підійшли до цього
питання ті найбільш актуальні важливі
проблеми які сьогодні нами розглядаються
перше модернізація
блоків ми можемо багато говорити про
безпечність про користь певної їжі але
якщо не бути наприклад що смажити рибу
набагато ее некорисніше ніж пекти її
запікати або
пі піддавати іншій термообротці аніж
смаження якщо немає спеціального
обладнання немає конвектоматів Немає ТХ
тих специфічних засобів для її
приготування основним елементом є
організація роз'яснювальної роботи дуже
багато було на початку реформи дуже
багато було запитань як як ми зможемо
яким чином це можна зробити перейти на
те меню обговорювали меню того самого
Євгена Клопотенко я в серпні місяці був
в Одесі хочу сказати що все можливо
зусиллями якісними зусиллями голови Ода
мерів міст директорів шкіл керівників
департаментів освіти і науки це все
вдається
менеджмент а також дуже багато можна
говорити про наприклад якість харчування
адже коли сам суб'єкт який готує цю їжу
не підготовлений То про яку якість можна
говорити а адже ми говоримо про
підвищення фахової спроможності всіх
причетних до організації
цього цього процесу і особливо по
кухарям 11 серпня на засіданні Кабінету
Міністрів нас підтримали і ми видали
Постанову про використання залишків
коштів виключно на реформу шкільного
харчування цеце це додаткові кошти які
можуть бути спрямовані в цей процес і
таким самим це рішення буде сприяти тому
самому безпечному якісному здоровому
освітньому середовищі яке Ми плануємо і
намагаємось створити в нашій державі на
2021 рік в цілому виділено 1 мільрд
субвенцій спроможна школа і кошти якої
також можна спрямовувати на реалізацію
реформи шкільного
харчування на сго
дні в нас погоджено 110 проектів по по
субвенції спроможна школа І це не
враховуючи ті проекти які реалізовуються
самостійно на місцях за що я дякую
головам Ода мерам міст керівникам
департаментів освіти і науки це важлива
реформа і вона має бути
продовжена паралельно з
держпродспоживслужбилава
лерівна Дякую вам завжди за ту підтримку
яку ми разом всі йдемо мон МОЗ деж
споживслужба на ми не контролюючі органи
наразі ми органи роз'яснення допомоги
впровадження цих стандартів і це дуже
важливо що ж Нам вдалося разом з
держпродспоживслужбою на підставі
певного аудиту не перевірки не ревізії а
саме аудиту ми виявили слабкі місця у
матеріально-технічному забезпеченні в
менеджменті в організації в тому числі
постачання питної води наприклад
Миколаївська область репортаж СН всі
пам'ятають розгромний розказували про
дійсно вражаючі речі і батьки були
обурені цим всім але на сьогодні ми
використовуємо в реформі шкільного
харчування в поданні їжі це е фасована
вода промислового виробництва це вже є
маленька перемога кіровоградщина активно
використовує фільтрування води Львівщина
експериментує з переходом до кейтереного
обслуговування так само і в місті
Маріуполь таке саме відбувається в
Одеській області зокрема де ми з вами
находимося в гостинній нашій перлині
перлині нашого краю в 2020 році Одеська
область виділила 26 млн грн і для
реформи шкільного харчування по по
середній освіті з місцевих бюджетів ще 5
млн це великі кошти і Ми дякуємо вам
Сергі Рафаїлович генадійвич Дякую вам за
ту підтримку яка дійсно ійде в цій
галузі закуплено для 101 закладу
загальної середньої освіти 2100 одиниць
обладнання для харчоблоків це велика
перемога і Виявляється що можна це
зробити якщо ми хочемо то ми можемо за
рахунок субвенції спроможна школа в нас
відремонтовано обсяг субвенцій становить
6,5 млн і видатки місцевих бюджетів
майже мільйон це теж є великі Кошти які
вкладені в розвиток освіти в Одесі
активно впроваджується кейтеринг 83
заклади середньої освіти є кейтерингове
обслуговування що теж показує що можливо
організація шкільного харчування ми
дійсно перебували і опробовували меню
безглютенове меню впроваджено Я говорив
і з головою обласної адміністрації і з
профільним заступником з керівником
Департаменту освіти і науки безглютенове
дуже важливе харчування та його треба
його небагато треба але це все про
доступність і якість і воно в Одесі дуже
гарно Сьогодні впроваджено Миколаївська
область
виділено майже 12 млн з місцевих
бюджетів майже 4 мльни закуплено 1139
одиниць технологічного обладнання для
24х закладів освіти у 85 закладах
організовано кейтерингове харчування з
використанням рецептур Євгена клопатенко
але меню клопатенко - це не є Догма на
сьогодні я знаю ми були в декільках
декількох школах є прекрасні фахівці
кухарі які самостійно розробляють згідно
санітарного регламенту і стандарту
зовсім іншу рецептуру але але показують
родзиночку саме смакових властивостей
саме міста Одеса південного нашого
регіону і це теж є один з способів
показати що сьогодні можливо не тільки
треба прив'язуватись під меню треба
прив'язуватись під норми під нормативи
але при цьому зберігати свою
особливість 454 заклади організовано
самостійне харчування дітей у власних
їдальнях це теж є показник по
Миколаївській області
перехід на систему хасп 170 закладів
загальної середньої освіти по
Миколаївській області переведено на
систему хасп це теж є про безпеку про
здоров'я про майбутнє наше гарячим
харчуванням охоплено Миколаївській
області 80 000 учнів Херсонська область
виділено 11 млн з місцевих бюджетів
більше ніж 2 мльни 111 закладів
загальної середньої освіти охоплено цією
реформою на даний час заплановані
завершуються роботи ще у 20 блоках у
чотирьох закладах освіти здійснюються
повноформатні ремонти одночасно
створенням
е і впровадженням реформи 111 закладів
працюють за меню Євгена клапотенко 376
закладів Миколаївського Херсонської
області працюють за власним меню з
дотриманням всіх норм санітарних і
регламентів Полтавська область майже 14
млн виділено з місцевих бюджетів 2,6 млн
Дякуємо голо голові обласної
адміністрації авііту бачу директора
Департаменту теж активно яка в цій в
цьому матеріалі знаходиться і постійно
підтримується цей процес 730 одиниць
закуплено 62 заклади вже повністю
охоплені 200 закладів працюють за меню
Клопотенко 533 заклади мають власна
власну розробку з дотриманням всіх
санітарних регламентів Полтавська
область чемпіон
423 заклади переведено на систему хасп
це Дякуємо вам це велика дійсно велика
робота велика копітка а Але така
виважена і робота яка дає ті результати
які сьогодні є по Кей по кейтерингу сім
шкіл по на аутсорсі у нас 10 шкіл по
системі
хасп я вже сказав 421 заклад
Кіровоградська область майже 10 млн
виділено коштів з місцевих бюджетів 2,5
млн 725 одиниць технологічного
обладнання закуплено для 48ми закладів
загальної середньої освіти в рамках
проекту спроможної школи закінчуються
ремонти по чотирьох закла на сьогодні і
придбано обладнання там майже на 1, млн
грвень 429 закладів охоплено цією
реформою зроблені ремонти впроваджуються
всі стандарти безпечного та здорового
освітнього середовища в частині
харчування мені дуже сподобався досвід
міста Маріуполь там де запроваджено
великий проект фабрика кухня який
повністю забезпечує організацію
шкільного харчування до цілого до цілого
кластеру закладів освіти і це дає
можливість суттєво економити кошти
місцевих бюджетів не погіршуючи при
цьому
якість на сьогодні Враховуючи те що саме
головним аспектом є те що ми маємо
постійно робити моніторинг і роз'ясненя
ситуації те що відбувається в нас
сьогодні формується об'єктивний
інформаційний портал який під робочою
назвою знаємо за ініціативи першої леді
Олени зеленської за підтримки
швейцарсько-українського проекту десай
міжнародної організації unicef в Україні
дуже активно запроваджується
інформаційно-роз'яснювальна
робота активно в співпраці з
держпродспоживспілкою в нас було
здійснення здійснено аудит майже 22 000
закладів що дало свої результати
і на підставі цього зробили перш за все
ми зробили роз'яснення і рекомендації
стосовно запровадження системи шкільного
харчування в нас надано інформацію поста
159 закладам загальної середньої освіти
майже 18 областей України які харчоблоки
яких не відповідали але які стали базою
щодо опрацювання нових стандартів і
нових рекомендацій щодо подальшого
нашогопровадження реформи
е більшість недоліків на сьогодні вже
усунуті і це теж наша спільна перемога
до якої ми все всі маємо прагнути дійсно
є проблеми з старими приміщеннями дійсно
є ще багато великих і таких серйозних
проблем але Я абсолютно впевнений що ми
всі поступово їх
подолаємо на сьогодні саме головне не
зупинятись на впровадженні цієї реформи
і Міністерство освіти і науки на
сьогодні Мінфіну в бюджетному запиті
подало ще одну специфічну субвенцію на
1, мльрди гривень щодо цільового
формування реформи шкільного харчування
і до харчоблоків і до ремонту і до
наповнення тому Ми сподіваємось що це
буде все прийнято і нам буде трошки
легше фінансово хочу подякувати всім
освіттянам керівникам органів місцевого
самоврядування головам обласних
адміністрацій директорам департаментів
освіти і науки і особливо освітянам
менеджерам директорам шкіл які не
зупиняються на досягнутому і активно
впроваджують реформу Дякую вам
дякую зрозуміло що в реформу системи
харчування шкільного харчування
покладені основні засади такі як корисна
їжа і здоровий спосіб життя Ну а все що
стосується здоров'я це звичайно До
профільного міністра я задоволенням його
запрошую до мікрофона Міністр охорони
здоров'я України Віктор
[оплески]
Ляшко Вітаю всіх і Бажаю всім міцного
здоров'я коли ми
перебуваємо період пандемії
коронавірусної хвороби коли скрізь всі
говорять виключно про інфекційні хвороби
коли говорять розглядають як боротися з
інфекційною хворобою як боротися з цим
таким викликом який є в світі
ковід-19 досить часто і багато хто
забуває про інші епідемії які існують і
одна із них це епідемія неінфекційних
захворювань і вона епідемія неінфекцій
захворювань вона не з'являється просто
так ми знаємо чіткі фактори які їх
викликають Якщо коротко це наші шкідливі
звички це нездорове
харчування низька фізична рухова
активність тому я дякую в першу чергу
першій леді олені Зеленський яка в цей
тяжкий період боротьби з
коронавірусом зумів нас всіх об'єднати і
дати нам ключовий такий поштовх рухатись
вперед в боротьбі із
іншими хворобами які значно впливають на
здоров'я українців на тривалість
життя робота Міністерства охорони
здоров'я спільно
з нашими партнерами по уряду із
центральними органами виконавчої влади
направлена була на зміну
нормативно-правової бази за 2020 21-
роки ми її змінили І сьогодні ми можемо
з впевненістю сказати що все що треба
було Від міністерства охорони здоров'я
для того щоб запровадити здорове
харчування в наших школах зроблено тепер
потрібна командна робота об'єднати е
центральну владу з органами місцевого
самоврядування з директорами шкіл для
того щоб ми зреалізували те що написано
на папері адже в нас в Україні є такий
поганий
Наприклад досвід коли прописані норми не
зреалізовуються з різних причин Мій
колега сьогодні гарно розповів про те що
виділяються субвенції для того щоб те що
прописано могло бути зреалізовано Тепер
треба тільки бажання натхнення
[музика]
і мати ту мету і розуміти до якої цілі
Ми хочемо прийти навіщо ми впроваджує
здорове харчування і чому саме в
школах Я зараз задам вам запитання
підніміть руку будь ласка праву праву
руку хто в цьому залі вважає що він
вживає кількість солі яка дозволена
міністерством охорони здоров'я або
рекомендована міністерством охорони
здоров'я тут значить правдива правдива
аудиторія боді дійсно в нашій країні
середнє споживання солі близько 13 г на
добу при нормі 5 г на добу але
61% дорослого населення вважає що вони
споживають нормальну кількість солі і не
бачать і не розуміють причини виникнення
Після цього в них як приклад
гіпертонічної хвороби а пересолена їжа
веде до того що виникають певні
неінфекційні захворювання і коли ми
зробили перші наші норми і попросили
провідних кухарів зробити по цих нормах
перші
блюда пішле таке якби маленьке але але
уже дискусії щось не
так і ми говоримо що так бо ми зробили
по нормах ці норми імплементовані досить
великій кількості країн які мають досить
велику тривалість життя Що не так е
зібрались і поїхали великим колективом
долучених фахівців з першою леді з
мамами поїхали до школи де
приготовили їжу саме по тих нормах яку
ми Прописали для мене вона була смачна
для більшості е щось крутили відставляли
щось щось не так а дійсно не було солі і
вона не сприймалася в особливо діткам і
ми не є такими що от ми Прописали
написано алюміній то треба і робити Ні
Ми зрозуміли що так також не піде
реформа тому вернулись і подумали що
треба зробити для того щоб пішло
вирішили зменшувати кількість солі в
стравах поступово і вийти на ту норму
через певний період часу оскільки якщо
ти ЗМІ забираєш 1 г людина цього не
відчуває Але якщо ти забираєш вже 2 г
вони начинають відчувати і начинають вже
говорити що несмачна і некорисна і ця
Вся ваша реформа піде не туди куди
потрібно тому реально що ми зараз
просимо ми просимо щоб були відгуки
змість що є не так що треба треба
переглянути Що треба призупиняти для
того щоб ми рухались і рухались тільки
вперед Чому через дітей Ми хочемо
змінювати звички традиційні звички з в
родинах серед розпочинаючи з маленьких
дітей Оскільки сьогодні ми говоримо про
реформу шкільного харчування а
паралельно ми запустили реформу і
дошкільного харчування і сьогодні
Міністерство охорони здоров'я вже
направило на погодження технологічні
картки які для
харчування в дошкільних закладах і коли
в нас будуть діти розуміти що вони
наприклад повинні їхасти Здорово
харчування не солону їжу ця звичка
прийде в кожну з наших родин і ми будемо
змінювати те що повинно змінюватись в
наших родинах для того щоб ми всі з вами
були здорові і що не буде точно в нас і
не повинно бути не повинно
бути сосисок сардельок взагалі
оброблених м'ясних продуктів в шкільному
в шкільному харчуванні оскільки це е ну
не не нездорове харчування не повинно
бути солодких газованих напоїв і ці ці
речі всі прописані в наших нормативах
тому я думаю що ми на панельній дискусії
з вами поговоримо сьогодні є я з вами є
колеги з Міністерства охорони здоров'я
ми можемо надавати поради пояснення щодо
того як впроваджувати ці норми а всім
нам хотілось би бажати гарного форуму е
отримання якомога більшої інформації
розуміння для чого ми це робимо
об'єднатись заради успіху бо як показує
боротьба з ковід що результат ми
досягаємо тільки тоді коли Працюємо як
одне єдине ціле Якщо десь тільки якась
ланка випадає успіху досягнути досить і
досить важко тому я з Надією дивлюсь в
зал і думаю що всі ви вакциновані проти
коронавірусної хвороби хто не
вакцинований будь ласка підніміть руку
Хай вас всі
побачать оце погано ті хто підняв руку
зафіксуйте їх будь ласка журналісти
Зніміть І транслюйте що так не повинно
бути Всім дякую за увагу і клідної нам
праці на
форумі хочу запевнити пана міністра в
тому що принаймні на сцені безпечний А
вакцинований так як наш форум про те
що повинна бути взаємодія між
Центральною владою і місцевою Я з
задоволенням запрошую на цю сцену голову
Одеської Обласної Державної
адміністрації Сергія
[оплески]
гринівецького Доброго дня шановні
колеги шановні пане міністре голова
обласної ради пане міський голова Олега
з Херсона Сергій
вячеславивич враховуючи що є таймінг Я
скористуюсь нотатками з вашого дозволу і
маю честь вітати всіх вас на Одещині яка
завжди відкрита для інноваційних
проектів і нових ініціатив на мій погляд
тема нашого форуму реформування
шкільного харчування - це привід для
розгляду широкого кола питань державного
значення поштовх для вирішення багатьох
нагальних проблем держави і
суспільства проблему організації
шкільного харчування необхідно
розглядати сьогодні в контексті
стратегічних документів які затверджені
в 20му-21му році зокрема це стратегія
людського розвитку це стратегія
економічної безпеки до 25-го року Ви
знаєте це рішення Ради національної
безпеки і оборони які введені в дію
указом
Президента адже безпечність харчових
продуктів загалом особливо тих що
споживають наші діти є одним із
вирішальних факторів економічної безпеки
України і визначається саме спроможністю
держави ефективно контролювати
виробництво та постачання безпечного і
якісного продовольства впевнений ця
сфера діяльності має як гуманітарний і
соціальний аспекти так і економічний
політичний та гарантує продовольчу
безпеку держави вважаю прийшов час
розглянути проблему забезпечення учнів
якісними продуктами зокрема локальними
вітчизняного виробництва і комплексно
усвідомити що це не тільки і не стільки
рядки у шкільному меню це перш за все
сукупність складових які працюють на
результат реформи шкільного харчування
та формування духовного і фізичного
здоров'я нації зупинюся лише на деяких з
них це якість вітчизняного продовольчого
продукту
ефективне тваринництво та
кормовиробництво овочеводство
садівництво виноградарство а заразом і
зрошення ну відверто вам скажу що по
кількості сухих речовин і цукру наш
виноград наші ягоди наші фрукти і овочі
значно кращі ніж ті що ми сьогодні
імпортуємо бо якщо береш там Херсонську
помідору або біляївську помідору То це ж
не та помідора яка йде за кордону якою
можна в теніс грати
це організація процесу постачання та
забезпечення відповідних норм зберігання
це вдосконалення системи державних
санітарних правил і норм влаштування
організації харчування загальноосвітніх
навчальних закладів тощо до того ж Хочу
наголосити на важливості ресурсного
забезпечення процесу реформування
системи шкільного харчування та його
основних складових про які говорили е
панове міністри а саме це кадровий
потенціал це
інформаційно-роз'яснювальна робота та
матеріально-технічний стан До речі е
щодо матеріально-технічного стану Я
гадаю що матеріально-технічну складову
неможливо розглядати сьогодні в відриві
від провадження програми президента
України велике будівництво адже в
результаті її реалізації в Одеській
області маємо сьогодні новозбудовані
садочки та школи з сучасними
харчоблоками модернізовані заклади
освіти е нові спортивні майданчики
стадіони тощо безумовно сьогодні
необхідно і внесення відповідних змін до
низки законодавчих актів України
стосовно організації харчування школярів
проте ніякими законами не примусити
діяти тих хто перш за все має бути
зацікавлений та відповідальний на за
вирішення цієї важливої проблеми я маю
на увазі батьки та медичний персонал
саме їх слово має стати вирішальним дуже
багато залежить і від керівників
навчальних закладів їх рівня
відповідальності і готовності до
рушійних змін у звичних процесах Отже
вирішувати цю проблему треба глобально
та комплексно хочу подякувати пані олені
зеленській з яка виступила ініціаторкою
серії регіональних форумів щодо
реалізації реформи шкільного харчування
в Україні адже це дає нам на місцях
можливість поспілкуватись та попрацювати
безпосередньо з тим хто опікується
реформою важливим кроком якої є
імплементація змін на місцях
підсумовуючи зазначу що правильне
харчування дитини - це одна із найкращих
та потужніх інвестицій яку ми можемо
зробити для її повноцінного розвитку та
майбутньої держави Дякую за
увагу надзвичайно приємно що губернатор
дотримується регламенту друзі завершую
це блок Я запрошую до слова міського
голову міста Одеси Геннадія
[оплески]
труханова Доброго дня нас предупредили
Что На лестнице третья ступенька
опасна Доброго дня шановний Сергію
Миколайовичу Віктора кириловичу
Владислава валерієвна Сергію рафаїловичу
шановні присутні
як міський голова щиро вдячний що для
такого Зібрання було обрано саме сонячну
Одесу мабуть саме у нас і діти і дорослі
звикли їсти дуже
смачно це одна з головних традицій
адесіто тому де ж якщо не тут нам
зустрічатись
реформу шкільного харчування в нашому
місті розпочали рік тому розпочали Як не
дивно з негативу ми чесно і відвер
проаналізували реальний Стан справ
з'ясували що майже 170 млн грвень
щорічно Ми практично викидаємо у
смітник бо наші діти як кажуть У відомій
пісні У нас в Одесі это не
едят ми створили робочу групу з освітян
лікарів дієтологів рестораторів
запросили до Одеси небайдужих людей які
займаються цим питанням у тому числі
Євгена клопатенка розробили сучасни
меню у тому числі для дітей які
потребують безглютенового та
безлактозного харчування
пишаюсь як очільник міста Тим що саме в
Одесі Минулого тижня вперше в Україні
впроваджено безлютенові сніданки для
учнів першого та четвертих
класів ми випробували свої розробки на
базі 10 одеських шкіл і шведські столи і
вендінгові апарати отримались значний
позитивний резонанс і видуки одеситів
Продовжуйте і ми продовжили збільшили в
бюджеті міста видатки на харчування з 10
до 17,5 а потім до 23,5 грн в день на
одного учня розпочали годувати дітей з
особливими харчовими потребами
відремонтували та оснастили новим
обладнанням більш половини харчблоків
закладів освіти
міста Так це значні фінансові витрати
але ми розуміємо що робимо правильну і
корисну
справу адже досить велика кількість
маленьких маленьких оіситів Саме в школі
отримує повноцінний сніданок тому Ще раз
вітаю всіх учасників цієї благородної
справи особиста подяка олені зеленськой
яка очолила цей напрямок і дала новий
такой поштотух для нашої з вами
співраці впевнений що досвід нашого
міста стане корисним і для для інших
гарного і продуктивного дня
Дякую Ну що ж друзі Я запрошую на сцену
технічних працівників для того щоб вони
підготували її для наступної панелі
акцентую увагу на тому що сьогодні ми
зібралися для того щоб відпрацювати
комунікації між Центральною владою і
місцевим самоврядуванням переконаний в
процесі бесіди в процесі того як ви
будете слухати спікерів з'явиться велика
кількість питань
збоку бачите такі столики там акваріуми
туди можна передавати ваші питання
врешті-решт в третьому блоці третій в
третій панелі ми почуємо на них
відповіді сподіваюсь вони будуть Дуже
корисними враховуючи масштабність
реформи враховуючи її важливість Я думаю
що не потрібно соромитися питатися
конкретно практичні задавати конкретні
практичні питання сьогодні ми поговоримо
не тільки про норми харчування з
нове меню А також про закупівлі про те
до якого часу потрібно встигнути це все
зробити а також нагадаю що сьогодні вас
чекає кулінарне шоу де наші кухарі прямо
на Ваших очах приготують за 45
хвилин 700 страв точніше сім страв для
700 чоловік Мені здається це буде цікаво
Ну і врешті-решт Самому цікаво
спробувати чим буде харчуватися Моя
дитина
так добре хочу нагадати також про
пропірці які є в ваших роздаткових
матеріалах там є форми зворотнього
зв'язку Якщо вам не важко також
заповнюйте їх
залишайте там само де і будуть
питання в
принципі в принципі Практично все готово
і Я запрошую на
сцену наших спікерів
і
спочатку як називається ця панель ця
панель називається нові норми харчування
впровадження та контроль спікерами цієї
панелі виступають Міністр охорони
здоров'я України Віктор
Ляшко Міністр освіти і науки України
шкарлет
Сергій державний експерт директорату
громадського здоров'я Скапа
Тетяна
голова державної служби України з питань
безпечності харчових продуктів і захисту
споживачів магалецька
Владислава Ну і модератором цього цієї
панелі цього блоку буде виступати
співзасновник та голова правління
національної асоціації громадського
харчування степаняк Орест оресте передаю
вам керування і з задоволенням Послухай
все
зали
Добрий день колеги я щиро радий бачити
таку велику кількість людей сьогодні в
залі і Е для мене як для представника
профільної організації національної
асоціації громадського харчування є дуже
потішним що питання здоров'я наших дітей
питання організації харчування в школах
є настільки об'єднавче а Ми сьогодні
спробуємо побудувати
дуже таку прагматичну розмову для того
щоби дати вам відповіді на усі існуючі
питання тому що я дуже добре працюючи в
регіонах дуже добре розумію з якою
проблематикою зіштовхуєтесь ви освітяни
представники місцевого самоврядування
які безпосередньо працюють з
організацією харчування на місцях тому
будемо старатися будувати дуже
прагматичну розмову також ще раз
повторюсь у вас є можливість задати
питання на які ми постараємось абсолютно
усі дати відповідь четвертій панелі в
ваших роздаткових матеріалах є записочки
окрім того є форма зворотнього зв'язку
дуже просимо заповнюйте її тому що це
наш не останній форум в Україні і ми
будемо працювати вдосконалюватись в
подальшому а зараз я хочу передати слово
пану Віктору е і пане Вікторе хотів
запитати у вас щодо 305ї постанови щодо
нових норм харчування і нового меню яке
є наслідком е Скажіть будь ласка є
розробле меню Євгеном клопотенком нові
норми ми усі розуміємо їхню важливість
Але чи має це
меню чи тільки меню Євгена клопотенка
може бути чи будь-яка громада будь-яка
Школа може працювати з іншим меню як ви
це
Бачите Ще раз всім міцного здоров'я і
так щодо постанови постанова розроблена
прийнята але з урахуванням того що в нас
є бюджетний рік бюджетний рік з
урахуванням того що багато хто провели
тендери на закупівлю харчових продуктів
ми знову ж таки отримали зворотній
зв'язок і прохання відтермінувати термін
її дії тому ми послухались і
запровадження цієї постанови буде
необов'язковим з 1 вересня а стає
обов'язковим з 1 січня 2022 року
оскільки багато хто закупив продукти для
того щоб не було ніяких судових позовив
там і критичних ситуацій але більш
багато шкіл запроваджують його із 1
вересня у кого було розбито закупівлю і
тендерні процедури на декілька етапів е
і ми будемо підтримувати і я знову ж
таки кажу ті хто буде працювати сьогодні
уже по нових нормах вони побачать певні
плюси мінуси і на мінуси ми готові
відреагувати щоб в січні 22-го року були
вже тільки одні плюси щодо меню так меню
дійсно змінено змінюється в нас раніше
були двотижневі перспективні меню які
переперевіряла колись
санітарно-епідемігічна станція після для
цього
держпроцспоживслужба І сьогодні ми
поговоримо про те що є технологічні
картки ви можете користуватись меню яке
буде запропоновано централізовано А
можете розробляти свої і коли Ви
розробляєте свої вони чотирьохтижневі ви
ее може ви повинні будете їх погодити з
держпродспоживслужбою Якщо ви будете
користуватись централізованим ніякого
додаткового погодження е не потрібно е
головна і ключова Відмінність цього
всього все Це робиться для того щоб було
смачно і корисно і в першу чергу корисно
в другу чергу смачно але як показала
практика все це може об'єднатись і воно
виходить Смачно корисно і не настільки
до дорого як може бути всім
протрансльовано Що це Що ми робимо воно
значно здорожає вартість самого меню як
показала практика не значноздорощує а
воно дійсно там піднімає на незначні
суми а які ми дивимося вперед що ми
хочемо досягнути воно зовсім буде інша
ситуація тому давайте інвестувати в
здоров'я наших дітей і будемо
інвестувати в здорову Україну А це ще
одна програма президента яка запущена і
я думаю що ми досить скоро будемо
показувати вам позитивні речі і будуть
позитивні зміни Чудово дякую Я хочу
підтвердити ваші слова тому що наша
асоціація постійно готує готує в різних
регіонах в різних школах на різних
сценах і і хочу підтвердити те що
сьогодні ми готуємо згідно нових Норм А
ви всі будете дегустувати це меню і ми
не виходимо за межі тих цифр про які
говорив нам пан міський голова Одеси ми
входимо в межі
20-23 грн за вартість харчування для
однієї дитини Тобто це є абсолютно
прийнятні норми і цифри хотів за задати
вам ще таке питання яке нам задають
Завжди коли ми приїжджаємо в різні
області Після наших спічів до нас
підходять і задають питання А чи є це це
меню інструментом переходи переходу на
ці норми як з цим як з цим працювати як
це меню чотирьохтижневе меню чи може
його робити будь-яка школа чи може його
робити будь-який відділ освіти Чи може
його робити будь-яка громада яким чином
використовувати цей інструмент що ви
порадите його може робити Ну але ми
розуміємо що розробити меню
чотирьохтижневе не досить просто тому
так як і ми думали що ось зараз за
місяць раз-два і зробили це меню е
першим хто взявся змінювати підходи взяв
був Євген Клопотенко Він розпочав над
цим працювати і напевно в нього
з'явилась не одна сива волосина поки він
його довів до до ума і також він давав
нам величезну кількість пропозицій
дискутував з нашими науковцями у сфері
громадського здоров'я говорив що це те
що там в нас прописано зреалізувати
неможливо але ми маємо кінцевий продукт
в подальшому розпочали працювати Мої
колеги з Міністерства охорони здоров'я
ро розкажуть і залучили міносвіти
держпроспоживслужбу працівників напевно
і присутніх в залі колег які на місцях
на практиці начали відпрацьовувати знову
ж таки норми і ми дійсно побачили Так це
інструмент коли в нас є чотирьохтижневе
меню і його реально будуть по цих
технологіях робити продукт це той
інструмент для того щоб досягти те що
прописано в нашій постанові в наших
нормах Але є одне ключове но ми повинні
розу міти що ми говоримо про школу в
школі зараз ми всі разом зробимо те щоб
досягнути тієї мети якої ми йшли
запровадити ці норми і забезпечити дітей
здоровим харчуванням але ця традиція
повинна виходити за межі школи оскільки
якщо дитина вийде за межі школи придійде
до кіоску купить газовану солодку воду з
чіпсами то все те що ми зробили воно
піде в Нікуди і ми повинні з цим також
боротись і про пропагандувати про те щоб
ці звички які будуть в школі вони
потихеньку потихеньку переходили в
культуру харчування Повірте е наведу
такий Цікавий приклад е можливо всі Ну
то всі ну ну не знаю хто пробував
е скандинавську
сельотку вона ж відрізняється від
Одеської правда Вона зовсім інша по солі
до того щоб дойти до цієї е е до цих
осолецців вони пройшли 25 років вони
змінили взагалі принцип харчування але
тривалість їхнього життя І зменшення
серцево-судинних хвороб вражають вони
навіть називаються фінляндським
синдромом і пропонують всім вивчати тому
ми повинні зрозуміти що ми сьогодні
робимо фундамент не Очікуйте що завтра
післязавтра у вас уже все буде те що ми
хочемо досягти через пару ее десятків
років але якщо ми сьогодні не зробимо
цей фундамент то я не знаю коли ми його
можемо створити Ми весь час будемо
відкладати відкладати відкладати а наша
з вами мета збудувати здорову Україну і
щоб все що потім буде впроваджуватись
впроваджувалось з урахуванням постулатів
охорони здоров'я погоджуюсь з тим що ви
говорите Дуже дякую вам ви знаєте ми
коли переїжджаємо до прикладу з Мукачева
з Одеси в донецькубо Луганську область
Ми зіштовхується з тим що є різна
культура споживання їжі те що абсолютно
неприйнятно в Закарпаття до прикладу
фршмак так само не дуже правильно
сприймається як паприкаш або банош в
Одесі так тобто є в нас величезна
держава в нас різна культура кожен Шеф
бачить своє меню по-іншому
тому буду рекомендувати вважати меню
Євгена
клопотенка як таким першим кроком де ви
можете брати його вдосконалювати можете
добавляти і створювати своє тобто
рухатись усі до до того щоби створювати
все більше і більше нових якісних страв
які будуть відповідати нормам пані
Тетяно хотів задати питання вам ви як
людина яка стояла біля витоків е реформи
і 305ї постанови хотів би щоб ви нам
розказали про максимально просто і
зрозуміло так Що ж Що ж таке 305
постанова чим вона відрізняється від
попередніх норм Доброго дня шановні
колеги рада всіх вітати е дійсно 305
постанова вона достатньо е має достатньо
багато відмінностей від постанови яка
діяла раніше 1591 якою були затверджені
норми харчування що ж такого нового в
цій 305й постанові ну найперше слід
звернути увагу що в 305-й постанові в
нормах харчування наведено маса харчових
продуктів які
яка зазначена в масі нетто Тобто це та
конкретна кількість певного харчового
продукту яку дитина має отримати для
певного прийому їжі Навіщо це було
зроблено тому що якщо ми проаналізуємо
норми які діяли до цього то вони були
затверджені в масі нет в масі Брутто
Перепрошую і ну дуже такий простий
приклад якщо ми беремо
наприклад страву з м'яса е кожна школа
або кожен засновник школи під час
оголошення тендерів вибирає може
вибирати різну категорію м'яса яку
отримує наприклад хтось
отримує птицю це кури першої категорії А
хтось отримує птицю як філе і якщо ми
порівняємо відходи під час кулінарної
обробки цих двох категорій птиці то ми
отримаємо прифіле - це там здається 0 5%
А якщо це кури першої категорії то це
близько 50%. то тобто якщо ми беремо по
старим нормам масу кур масу птиці умовно
100 г на одну дитину то ви відчуваєте цю
різницю якщо це кури першої категорії
дитина отримує всього-навсього 50 г
птиці А якщо це філе то дитина отримує
всі майже 100 г птиці і різниця дуже
суттєва для того щоб не було таких ссів
нові норми вони зазначені власне в масі
нетто Тобто кожна дитина має отримати ту
порцію яка зазначена незалежно від того
в
якій в якому вигляді замовляється
скажімо
сировина крім того
Е старі норми наприклад містили таку
чудову таблицю як таблиця заміни
харчових продуктів Але ми всі розуміємо
що ну молочну продукцію замінити м'ясом
або яйцями Ну в принципі принципі
неможливо тому що хімічний склад цих
продуктів досить різний він різнитьсяя і
він не покриває всі ті потреби
е фізіологічні дітей які є тому в
постанові Кабінету Міністрів 305 в
нормах харчування нових такої таблиці
немає Дякую Чудово е я розумію е знаючи
нові норми Я розумію що
потрібно змінювати трансформовувати
смакові вподобання наших дітей
Як ви е підкажете як на місцях як
місцевому самоврядуванню як освітянам
працювати з дітками тому що діти мають
сім'ї вони повертаються додому в сім'ях
можливо їх харчують по-іншому як ви
пропонуєте трансформати трансформувати
ці смакові вподовання діток е ну як вже
зазначав наприклад Віктор Кирилович щодо
солі то Е в нормах харчування
встановлено саме по солі перехідний
період терміном до 2023 року і ді є
поетапне зниження кількості солі яку
можна додавати в страви під час їх
приготування тобто з сіллю в принципі
все зрозуміло щодо цукру зважаючи на те
що також встановлено перехідний період
запровадження нових норм е ну не
найпростіше - це поетапно зменшувати
кількість цукру наприклад який додається
в страви при цьому хочу акцентувати
увагу що вже з з 1 січня 2 21-го року
наприклад в шкільному харчуванні
додавати цукор в напої ну заборонено
тобто цього робити все одно не можна
е-е Ну і крім того необхідно працювати
все ж таки ее з дітьми розповідати їм
Навіщо це робиться що від цього вони
будуть мати і намагатись це робити Таким
чином щоби діти були в цьому зацікавлені
були навіть зацікавлені в тому щоб
прийти додому і розповісти батькам що
мама тато або бабуся необхідно це робити
тому що ми будемо здоровіші тому що це
для нас для нашого майбутнього е Дякую
якщо громада активна якщо громада хоче
працювати з новим меню хоче розробляти
своє Які механізми погодження цього меню
і якщо можна змалюйте таку дорожню карту
як працювати
е Так кожна громада кожна школа якщо
вона має власне фінансову автономію або
засновник освіти або навіть той суб'єкт
господарювання який надає послуги з
аутсорсингу або кейтерингу має право
розробити власне меню з урахуванням
вподобань кожної окремої території
кожної там школи кожної територіальної
громади але як зазначалось раніше це
меню підлягає обов'язковому погодженню в
територіальному органі
держпроцспоживслужби як ну крім того
наприклад яким чином найпростіше з цього
вийти да для того Щоб розібратись що ж
там має бути для чого це має бути в
принципі можна буде подивитись те меню
яке буде рекомендоване міністерством
охорони здоров'я для того щоб зрозуміти
що туди входить Ну і якщо поетапно то
якщо ви вирішили розробляти своє меню то
Найперше що необхідно визначитись
скратністю харчування якщо це наприклад
школа і це одноразове харчування ви
вибираєте відповідний додаток до норм
чування це дев'ятий додаток і по ньому
ви складаєте це меню Тобто там прописана
конкретна кількість харчових продуктів в
нетто які є щоб скласти меню ви берете
перелік тих технологічних карт наприклад
які є у вас або які є в збірниках е в в
різних в збірнику Євгена Клопотенко або
будь-яких інших збірниках вибираєте ті
страви які для вас характерні які у вас
наприклад ви думаєте що діти будуть
споживати дуже досить добре і по
технологічних картах набираєте це меню
але
відповідно дивитесь це з урахуванням тих
норм які
передбачені після того як склали меню
меню затверджується або керівником
закладу
або директором департаменту освіти або
керівником суб'єкта господарювання який
надає послуги з харчування Ну і
відповідно погоджується в
держпроцспоживслужбі Чудово дякую за
корис інформації впевнений що вона
корисна в свою чергу хочу підтвердити що
усі
присутні відомства Міністерства і
держпроцспоживслужба максимально лояльно
відноситься до того щоб ви створювали це
меню і його погоджували з нами присутня
пані Владислава яка в подальшому розкаже
про те як працює з цим
держпроцспоживслужба яку абсолютно не
потрібно боятися в цьому випадку А зараз
я хотів би надати слово пану Сергію
шкарлету і запитатись у вас таку річ ее
одним з запитань і одним однією зі
складнощей є
м кадри тобто будь-яке меню окрім
техніки окрім технологічного обладнання
окрім якісних продуктів які маємо
закупити є проблематика кадрів що може
зараз Що можете зараз запропонувати і як
ми Які в нас плани як ми рухаємося з
освітою профтехосвітою в цьому
напрямку Дуже дякую за запитання
ви знаєте сидячи на сцені є принаймні
один такий гарний позитивний такий
привід це є реально бачиш всіх вас такий
цікавий віід на море Дякую Одессі Ще раз
дякую дякую одессси там дуже класна
локація і дякую за
запитання перш за все маю сказати що
дійсно не можна переходити до реформи
шкільного харчування без якості саме
того хто це харчування Хто це буде нести
цей продукт адже якщо не буде
відповідної кваліфікації кухаря то нема
про що говорити такий самий буде і
продукт Ми багато говоримо про Євгена
Клопотенко але коли стало питання
підготовки кадрів то він один з перших
хто зголосився ну переможець майстер-шеф
відомий відома в країні людина
професійний кухар який активно
впроваджує в життя стандарти цієї
професії але зовсім новому було
підписано великий меморандум який
розглядав питання щодо підвищення
кваліфікації оновлення професійних
стандартів розробка ее бордів проведення
інформаційно-роз'яснювальної роботи
стосовно впровадження цього меню дуже
багато було питань до регламенту до
нових санітарних норм стосовно шкільного
харчування але він перший сказав Давайте
я спробую я покажу це меню що це можливо
бо багато було в будь-якої реформи є ті
хто її підтримують але і так само є і ті
ті хто скептично завжди відноситься до
цього Євген показав Він зробив це
чотиритижневе меню зробив рецептурний
справочник але це не є Догма ми в місті
Одеса місяць тому відвідували школу де
абсолютно на но на з дотриманням всіх
стандартів бу було розроблено зовсім
інше меню зовсім інша рецептура
затверджено відповідним чином і і Вона
показала що це меню воно не гірше ніж у
Євгена що ж ми все-таки зробили з ним
підписали меморандум при цьому на
оновлення професійного стандарту для
закладів профтехосвіти кухар дитячого
харчування в двох вищих професійних
училищах міста Києва було цей проект
запроваджено в рамках цього
проекту в нас також запроваджується і
ее за рахунок субвенції державного
бюджету щодо формування
навчально-практичних центрів у сіми
областях вже сформовані такі
навчально-практичні центри щодо під
підготовки осіб за професією кухар і ще
у семи областях до кінця року на суму
більш ніж на 17 млн буде запроваджено
такі самі навчально-практичні центри на
наступний рік ми також плануємо ще 250
млн грвень для
розповсюдження саме професійних
навчально- практичних центрів для
професійної підготовки кухарів на
сьогодні є 22 000 кухарів в закладах
загальної середньої освіти при цьому є
504 вакансії в нас Приблизно 1000
кухарів вже пройшла повноформатно
підвищення кваліфікації і приблизно 3
000 до кінця року ще планується
підвищення кваліфікації в рамках
вебінарів тематичних форумів в рамках
професійних лекційних курсів тому
Міністерство разом з усіма місцевими
органами влади зацікавленими колегами
професійними кухарями активно впроваджує
підвищення професійного стандарту саме
кухаря Дякую вам Чудово дякую вам за
розгорнуту відповідь Також хотів би
запитатись у вас якою ви бачите роль
громади в цій реформі тому що для нас
одне з ключових питань сьогодні
зрозуміти хто за що відповідає за що
відповідає Центральна виконавча влада що
робить громада якщо можна змалюйте нам
будь ласка
її гарне запитання Тим більше що
сьогодні представники і обласної держа
обласних державних адміністрацій
керівники обласних державних
адміністрацій керівники органів
місцевого самоврядування присутні
тут ви знаєте це суспільна робота
взагалі спільна робота всіх щодо
впровадження цієї реформи Я знову ж таки
повернусь до деяких прикладів
перебуваючи в місті Полтава ми
перебували і в інклюзивно-ресурсному
центрі в дошкільному закладі освіти в
закладі загальної середньої освіти там
де запроваджуються всі ці стандарти які
відбуваються в частині реформи шкільного
харчування роль і центрально органу
виконавчої влади і місцевого в тому
щоб
на в спільному використанні тих коштів
які виділяє держава в ТХ тих коштів
органів місцевого самоврядування
запровадити Ну вперш за все ті
ліквідувати ті больові ключові точки які
сьогодні є в частині шкільного
харчування в місті Полтава зроблено
абсолютно в співпраці з міністерством з
держа обласною державною адміністрацією
це і оновлення харчоблоків це
і і птна вода Ти саме те що я говорив в
своїй промові в на прикладі міста Одеса
теж можу сказати що оновлення
харчоброків роздаткових ліній
організація зовсім іншого взагалі іншого
процесу харчування це і той самий
кейтеринг це і так звані фабрики кухні
тобто на сьогодні немає когось окремого
Кому має бути за внесено в зобов'язання
реалізовувати це велика спільна Робота
під патронатом нашої першої леді Олени
зеленської дякую Чудово дякую вам дуже
пані владиславу хотів би передати слово
вам і як
представнику як голові державної служби
України з питань безпечності харчових
продуктів та захисту прав споживачів
дуже хотів поцікавитись у вас Я
пожартував стосовно того що ви дуже
лояльні мабуть ви розкажете в чому ви
лояльні А в чому потрібно контролювати і
як саме забезпечувати цей контроль за
харчуванням дітей в школах Доброго дня
дорогі напевно я попрошу на одну
хвилинку всіх стати і повернутися один
до одного покажу як це зробити будь
ласка вставайте ми сидимо з вами десь
приблизно вже одну годину подивитися я
цей впевнена що біля вас дуже гарні люди
знаходяться хтось може ще помилуватись
якщо побачить море сідайте
дякую Я дуже добре розумію як сидіти на
цих
стільчиках десь приблизно годину
Я маю честь очолювати держпроспж службу
Це дійсно контролюючий орган
і безпосередньо заклади середньої освіти
і всі державні органи місцеві
співпрацюють з нами користуючися нагодою
Дуже дякую пану Сергію
рафаїловичу за нашу співпрацю в Одеській
області хочу з вами говорити не тільки
як Голова служби а в першу чергу як
мати в нашій з чоловіком родині Ми
виховуємо п'ять синів моєму старшому
сину 24
роки нашому меншому сину один ріктри
місяці вот тому я безпосередньо знайома
з кожним етапом шкільного харчування
впродовжже як ви розумієте Да там більше
16 років Я маю на увазі це от період
який стосується шкільного харчування
дітей тому безпосередньо для мене ця
реформа є дуже важливою я хочу
подякувати перші леді за те що робота
ведеться системна тому що не один
державний орган залучений до організації
цього процесу А ви всі бачите от ми
разом знаходимося на не тільки на сцені
а в повсякденному житті ми постійно
співпрацюємо За що дякую міністрам
міністру освіти і міністру здоров'я за
нашу щоденну кроптку працю Я буду
говорити трошки мовою цифр по кожній
області що було Зрозуміло Як з нами
працювати які ми маємо результати
А є стародавня африканська
пословиця яка каже вислів що виховати
дитину потрібна вся
деревня в цьому загложений дуже великий
зміст бо в організації шкільного харчу
ня щоб правильно виховати нові
звички людина завжди дуже негативно
ставиться до будь-яких змін це закладено
в нашу природу але коли у вас
народжується дитина коли ми будемо
говорити про наших дітей
про синів про дочок я певна що кожен з
вас в серці щиро вірить що головне щоб
дитина була здорова а здоров'я
складається з
певних складових перше - це те що ми їмо
друге ще що ми п'ємо і третє чим ми
дихаємо так що ось ця основа закладена В
основу нашого нашої реформи шкільного
харчування бо зменшення кількості і солі
і цукру про які розповідали пани
міністри воно дуже суттєво важливе якщо
Кожен з нас буде притримуватися цих
звичок Повірте і виглядати ми будемо
краще і важити Може трошки менше а це не
так погано Для певних з нас Вот і будемо
набагато здоровіші а здоров'я означає
довгі роки а довгі роки
це насолода бо це єдине що нам дано в
житті
час напевно сама дорога а субстанція яка
існує в цьому світі тепер Якщо говорити
про нас я буду попросити Да дякую
Значить ми працюємо з як я вже говорила
з офісом першої леді ми працюємо з
кожною областю Я дуже дякую за цю
співпрацю обласним всім
органам Зараз одну хвилинку я ага отак
воно робиться значить що ми перевіряємо
як
держпроцспоживслужба як
держпроцспоживслужба ми перевіряємо стан
отримання територій безпечні
умови для того щоб діти могли навчатися
і харчуватися особливу увагу звертаємо
на тих дітей які потребують особливих
освітніх потреб ми перевіряємо стан
забезпечення меблями шкіл створення умов
для учнів початкових класів і стан
проведення лабораторних досліджень
фактори середовища Тобто ми перевіряємо
всі харчові блоки ми пере перевіряємо
якість питної води Я хочу вам сказати що
за рік який
минув ми разом з профільними
міністерствами перевірили більше 22 000
закладів освіти тут і дитячі садочки і
заклади середньої освіти Я маю на увазі
школи школи Ви знаєте це приблизно
трошки ну приблизно 15 000 об'єктів які
ми знаходилися на
перевірках я можу сказати ти що
приблизно в половині
випадків наших перевірок ми
знаходили ті речі які потрібно покращити
ми видавали відповідні приписи і я хочу
на це звернути вашу увагу бо коли ти
говориш мовою цифр це одне а тепер
уявіть там вашу дитину в
школі
ваших найближчих Та може хрщеників чи
як і тоді вам буде намагати легше
осягнути розмір проблематики
А я дуже прошу ретельно за цим
слідкувати бо це безпосередня
відповідальність як я казала да на
виховання дитини потрібна вся деревня
Так що давайте будемо тими хто за це
буде не просто там звітувати галочкою чи
там Ну давайте там закриємо очі і
підпишемо А тих хто буде безпосередньо
дбайливо відноситися до кожного пункту
перевірки які я зазначений в акті ви всі
з ними знайомі які ми
перевіряємо Я хочу звернути вашу увагу
на цифри значить
по Одеській
області Ми провели ми проводимо спочатку
до контролю дуже велику кількість
освітніх і консультаційних заходів задля
того щоб всі були обізнані що ми
перевіряємо і як в Одеській області Ми
провели
150 112 нарад 134 навчання 332
консультації і так по кожній
Кіровоградська 157 нарад відповідна
кількість також навчань консультацій
Миколаївська 99 нарад Полтавська 66
Херсонська
188 187 Я дуже дякую головам
держпроцспоживслужби цих областей Вони
знаходяться зараз у залі ми будемо всі
присутні під час останньої секції там де
буде запити і відповіді ви можете задати
нам впродовж дня Ми будемо тут Так що
будь ласка як якщо є якісь питання які
були не вирішені по вашому загальному
учбовому закладу безпосередньо з
територіальними представниками
держпроспоживслужби ми тут задля того
щоб відповісти на ці питання бо
переходячи від того що ми надаємо як
консультації далі ми присутні у всіх
комісій вірках перевірках які
відбуваються і також коли ми слідкуємо
за ризикорієнтованим підходом
ми
перевіряємо
харчоблоки і в питання харчоблоків У нас
не буде компромісів я буду ретельно
ставитися до кожного
закладу повірте мені голови обласні
держпоспоживслужби знають наскільки я
точно знаю по кожному закладу Що
відбувається і наскільки кожного
губернатора області я інформую яка школа
дещо не виконана і де нам потрібно
допомогти Так що будь ласка на
харчоблокі У нас є особлива увага друга
наша увага - це якість питної води те
саме ми робимо відповідно по кожній
області значить с початку серпня до
комісійних наших обстежень були залучені
Всі працівники держпроспоживслужби які
працюють за цим фахом і ми
перевірили 23 000 заклади освіти з яких
як я вже казала приблизно 15 000 це були
школи перевірки які як результати
давайте пройдемося по кожній з областей
я певна і я бачу що також присутні
губернатори їм буде цікаво це побачити і
почути значить Одеська область у нас
відкрилося 808 закладів середньої освіти
і відповідно до затверджених
розпорядження графіків роботи комісії
всі ми їх обстежили Полтавська область
до початку навчального навчального року
ми перевірили всі 56 500 564 заклади
Миколаївська область спеціалісти наші
взяли участь у перевірці
441й комісійній перевірці Кіровоградська
область
476 закладів і Херсонська 434 це те що
було зрозумів обсяг роботи яка
виконується тепер якщо казати вже за
цифри Одеська область у нас не
підписаний 21 акт готовності шкіл
а через відсутність лабораторного
контролю якості питної води Я дуже прошу
на це зважити бо зрозуміло що там без
води ми вза ну взагалі не можемо тим
більше діти вот
АА також були пропозиції висунути по
харчоблокам і інженерним мережам я
передам вам повний список по кожній
школі щоб цей 21 об'єкт ми змогли
ретельно відстежити в найближчий час
Полтавська область будь ласка в нас не
підписано 159 актів готовності шкіл
через незавершені ремонтні роботи і не
виконання пропозиції по харчоблокам і
інженерним мережам Херсонська область
Дякую не підписано лише 16 актів це
потрібно буде
допрацювати Кіровоградська область не
підписано 46 актів Я просто хочу щоб ви
зрозуміли да Що Що означає 46 акців це
відповідна кількість учбових закладів а
повчальний процес вже він вже почав
відсутність холодної гарячої поточної
води системи водовідведення і інше
Миколаївська область не підписано 138
актів готовності шкіл з яких 59 мають
незадовільний санітарно-технічний стан
будівель 18 незавершено ремонтні роботи
39 не існує проблема забезпечення питною
водою
гарантованої вартості і 22 незабезпечени
харчоблоки необхідним технічним
обладнанням будь ласка пан губернатор
присутній Я дуже прошу на це звернути
увагу бо ми це будемо перевіряти і
напевно давайте перейдемо
до питань також болючих кожен може
відчути це на собі представити свою
дитину в школі значить це питання
фальсифікації тому коли ви погоджуєте
того чи іншого
постачальника який буде надавати це
харчування я можу сказати що ми
перевіряємо ми перевіряємо і виявили за
рік який був навчальний ця частина року
2021го біля 2 тон неякісних м'ясних
продуктів більше 76 кграмі риби і рибних
продуктів які по суті є
фальсифікатам і
дуже не відповідають по якості і
безпечності фальсифікат по молочних і
молокопродуктв 228 кг і рослинного
походження 85 Я не хочу вам
розповідати чи показувати відео Коли ми
приходимо і на
харчоблоках немає
холодильних холодильного устаткування і
все знаходиться знаєте просто так на
шафках лежить
гніє миші мурахі бігають по тих
рослинних продуктах там мука чи макарони
які зберігаються хліб вісь в
цвілі я певна що кожен з вас не допустив
би такої ситуації у власній родині і
тому позиція держпроцпоживслужби Якщо
таке виконується буде безпосередньо дуже
жорстокою до кожної посадової особи яка
буде таке
дозволяти я дякую колегам пані Тетяні
вона дуже ретельно розповідала про
систему як погоджується і формується
меню ми його затверджуємо і я пояснюю
чому якщо ви робите ваше власне меню
співпраця з нами важлива бо ми будемо
слідкувати за тим наскільки насичене
меню відповідно до раціону зберігається
та якість меню з приводу наповнення
всіми необхідними елементами жирами
білками вуглеводовими а також черговість
тобто уявіть просто ваше харчування якщо
не буде цих трьох елементів наприклад У
вас будуть годувати тільки
макаронами не буде черговості замість
білків і жирів будуть пропонувати ще там
якусь
крупу А ми говоримо про здоров'я і
здоров'я нашої нації це є найголовне
найголовніше бо кожна складова цього
меню забезпечує розвиток
а головного мозку
його формування його
визрівання і будь ласка на це також
держпоцпожслужба буде дивитися дуже
ретельно Я також хочу навести тут вже не
буду коментувати по цифрах да яка
кількість меню в нас не була затверджена
але будь ласка кожен з губернаторів і
кожен з керівників по вашій області тут
присутні перевірте Я хочу відзначити До
речі миколаївську область яка Дуже
якісно підійшла шла до системи перевірки
по меню і його затвердження але хочу
звернути увагу Одеську Херсонську
Кіровоградську в Одеській області нам
треба ще погодити 89 меню Херсонська
будь ласка там треба погодити ще 15 меню
не були затверджені
Кіровоградська 72
меню Не погоджена будь ласка зверніть на
це увагу Полтавська область 109
непогоджено
Я вважаю що це взагалі неприйнятна
ситуація і найкраща ситуація у нас в
Миколаївській області Де приблизно всі
меню вже погоджені тобто на цю годину
були вже погоджені всі меню і завершуючи
свій виступ Я дуже хочу ще раз
подякувати пані першій
леді яка опікується цим питанням бо не
можна говорити про будь-яку реформу якщо
ти не дивишся на деталі бо дрібниці і
деталі це є
найважливіше тому я ще раз хочу
подякувати всім хто відповідально до
цього відноситься і попросити ми
відкриті до будь-яких консультацій якщо
у вас виникають питання по хаспу по те
як зробити правильно адаптувати меню Але
я точно вас хочу запевнити до кожного
керівника своєї держпоспоживслужби в
області я буду надзвичайно жорстка якщо
ті норми які закладені в уніфікомому
акті не будуть виконувати
Я дуже дякую за
співпрацю
Дякую що ж я вам дуже дякую особливо за
те що ви підняли питання споживання води
чистої води це надзвичайно важливо і я
би хотів поставити на цьому дуже великий
акцент тому що окрім здорового
харчування нам потрібно виховувати в
дітей культуру споживання води в нас
дуже часто буває таке що діти в
шкільному віці не знають взагалі в
принципі що таке пити чист воду тобто
Вони п'ють або зранку чай або потім
газовані солодкі напої тому забезпечення
чистою водою дітей які будуть вчитися
перед споживанням їжі випивати
склянку води це надзвичайно важливо
дякую вам дуже на мене сьогодні окрім ее
модераторства поклали ще місію
розповісти вам про сучасний
технологічний процес адже реформа
шкільного харчування - Це звісно
продукти з чого ми готуємо це кухарі ті
хто готують а також це певний
технологічний процес про який ми
сьогодні будемо з вами розмовляти е ми
не можемо собі уявити як можна готувати
їжу за 45 хвилин те що нам сьогодні
сказали для отакої великої кількості
людей для 700 людей і приготувати це за
45 хвилин трьом кухарям е насправді
можливо мені подобаються знаєте сучасні
українські будівельники Коли їм задають
Якесь питання Я особисто був присутній
вони кажуть ви знаєте сучасні технології
дозволяють побудувати те що ви хочете
навіть на шелфі Чорного моря так тобто
Можливо в принципі все а одне тільки які
ми будемо застосовувати для того
технології І сьогодні ми будемо з вами
говорити поки що в цій панелі це буде як
аненс анонс нашої нашого нашого
наступного практичної частини де ми
будемо Це демонструвати так ось Що ж
таке Е сучасний технологічний процес для
нас він виливається в дуже дві два
зрозумілих слова це є свіжість і
асортимент це є той маркер якості до
чого ми маємо прийти Звісно що керівники
відділів освіти департаментів освіти
міські голови їхні профільні заступники
не можуть знати і не можуть бути
технологами так В них немає
технологічної освіти вони не знають як
це готувати але якщо ви не будете
розуміти і не будете знати до чого ми
маємо прийти в кінці цієї реформи ми на
жаль не зможемо тоді вимагати від наших
підлеглих від директорів шкіл від
технологів на місцях того як що ми маємо
отримати в кінці тому що ми дуже часто
зіштовхуємось з тим що ми приходимо в
харчоблок абсолютно гарний з новим
ремонтом А задаємо питання А ви можете
дати асортимент їжі для того щоб в
дитинки була не одна котлетка іграча на
кашу А асортимент для того щоб в нас
збільшилось кількість відвідувачів
шкільну їдальню Ні тому для нас дуже
важливо
щоби реально завершенням реформи була
свіжість і асортимент А як з цим
працювати зараз будемо про це говорити
зараз на слайді на екранах ви бачите
класичні звичайні процеси це котел
каструля і шкаф сухожарочний тобто так в
принципі відбувається приготування їжі
Мені дуже подобається що починають люди
кивати головою погоджуються Так
відбувається класично приготування їжі в
принципі в усіх наших школах в більшості
і давайте задамо Питання якщо ми йдемо
до реформи і хочемо нашим дітям сучасним
які всі живуть тепер от в таких гаджетах
які звикли бачити один світ в цих
телефонах а потім ми їх приводимо в
шкільну їдальню і даємо їм один суп дня
е одну котлетку і один гарнір А вони
кажуть Ні вони не звикли вони не жили за
Радянського Союзу вони не звикли що таке
Е що таке все все все у всіх однакове
так вони хочуть вибору хочуть
асортименту відповідно якщо ми на кухні
встановили варочний котел такий один
великий який має 150 200 або 300 л ми на
жаль позбавили е учасників цього процесу
кухарів і директора школи можливості
зробити асортимент їжі в цій школі тому
що він може зварити виключно один суп за
день тому що в цьому котлі 200 л він
закипає 3 години і вони можуть зварити
один цей суп дальше ми стикаємося з
такою великою проблемою як А куди ж цей
суп подіти от ми його зварили 200 л
годуємо дітей на трьох-чотирьох-п'яти
перервах А куди ж нам його діти цих 200
л супа якщо на кожній перерві ви даємо
всього-навсього там по 20-30 л а ми
нікуди його не можемо діти він весь час
Цей зберігається в котлі І тут якраз і
випливає дотримання наших хаспнорм або в
принципі будь-яких санітарних норм ми
е деюре їх виконуємо де-факто Ні тому що
зберігання готової їжі в гарячому
вигляді може бути не більше аніж дві
години Але кухарі на кухні позбавлені
інш ну можливості щось щось інше з цим
зробити тому сьогодні
ми будемо говорити з вами про сучасний
технологічний процес а сучасний - це
коли ми готуємо дуже швидко якщо ми
зможемо
готувати суп варити його не 3 години а
30 хвилин або 45 хвилин Нам не потрібно
його варити 300 л 200 л 150 л ми можемо
його зварити саме ту порцію 30-50 л яка
нам потрібна на одну видачу якщо ми
говоримо про приготування такої важкої
страви як котлетиво тому що треба
зробити фарш треба сфор ти їх в котлетки
А після того їх треба посмажити А в нас
в школі навчається
тися дітей для Одеси Напевно це
нормально тисяча дітей от Уявіть собі
кухар Я не знаю чи ви можете уявити що
таке посмажити трьом-чотирьом кухарям
1тися котлет на пательнях так як це
відбувається ну це це це справді
пекельна робота і якщо ми готуємо це в
пароконвекційних печах до прикладу нам
ми можемо приготувати котлетки
сформувати їх і помістити їх в безпечне
середовище не про водячи теплову обробку
не готуючи їх і тоді коли в нас
приходить наш урок ми готуємо 100 котлет
50 котлет помістивши їх в пару
конвекційну піч натиснувши кнопочку вони
собі готуються в кінцевому результаті ми
отримуємо а не обсмажений на цих
пательнях АА великій кількості жиру
продукт тобто приготовлений з великою
кількістю пари а з дуже гарним
золотистим кольором тому що дітки
споживаються також візуально Так вон має
бути гарним і естетичним і в кінцевому
результаті ми маємо безпечно зберігання
холодного холодної заготовки і швидке
його приготування тому швидкість
приготування напряму впливає на нашу
реформу швидкість дає нам можливість
зробити асортимент і дає можливість нам
зробити е якість а і виходячи з цього ми
створили як Національна Асоціація
громадського харчування концепт урок
готуємо перерва видаємо звісно Ми не
говоримо зараз про те що ми за цей урок
маємо встигнути порізати картоплю
сформувати котлетки зро зробити фарш ці
всі процеси ми можемо робити зраночку
але все підготовлене у нас має лежати
готове зберігатися в безпечному
середовищі +3 +5° і в той момент коли
нам потрібно дуже швидко готувати е в
нас регламент мене змушує завершувати Ми
дуже детально про це з вами будемо
говорити під час нашої практичної
частини А зараз я буду дякувати усім
присутнім пане міністрам е Дякую
величезне за те що ми так конструктивно
і гарно поговорили і вам е наступних
гарних гарної інформації дякую
дякую Гарно дякую пане Віктор пане
Сергій пані Тетяно пані Владислава пане
Орест шановні
представники шановні представники
акредитованої журналістики журналісти
прошу перейти до фотозони там зараз у
вас буде можливість попрацювати Ну а ми
з технічною службою яку Я запрошую зараз
на сцену також плавно підводимо
підготовку до наступної панелі ви знаєте
Я досить уважно
послухав цю дискусію і мені дуже приємно
дві речі перша річ - це те що є
достатньо серйозний підхід до контролю
тобто до контролю того як відбуваються
процеси приготування їжі як відбуваються
процеси зберігання їжі лякають звичайно
дуже лякають
цифри стосовно того скільки неякісних
продуктів було знайдено але я сподіваюся
що такі форуми Як сьогодні є основою
того що більше таких проблем ми не
матимемо А якщо матимемо то не в таких
глобальних моментах також дуже приємно
те що Євген молодець Клопотенко те що
він придумав своє меню на сво на своєму
прикладі показав те що їжа в школі може
бути смачною корисною і
різноманітною але воно не є догмою воно
не є догмою і кожен шеф-кухар який
працює в вашій школі мо може скласти
своє меню Ну що ж Ідемо далі і наступна
тема теж досить важлива тому що вона про
Гроші про закупівлі і Я запрошую вона
називається публічні закупівлі якісний і
проектний підхід Я запрошую на сцену
наших спікерів начальник управління
конкурентної політики Міністерства
економіки України білянський
Олександр
державний уповноважений антимонопольного
комітету України Нечитайло
Ольга заступник директора з розвитку
професійній закупівлі Кузьменко
Андрій а також заступник голови
Полтавської обласної державної
адміністрації лунін
Дмитро Ну і також запрошую на сцену
модератору з цієї панелі Лесю
марталішвілі перед тим як ми почнемо
друзі Буквально за годину вас чекає
кавабрейк і можливість встати трошки
походити тому наберіться сил Терпіння і
уважно слухайти спікерів нагадую про те
що кожен З вас може задати своє
запитання і покласти його ось в тот той
акваріум Гарно дякую доброго дня всім
приємно вітати вас гарна компанія гарна
атмосфера гарне місто і сподівання від
сьогоднішньої зустрічі найкраще Але у
нас дуже серйозна сьогодні панель ми з
вами будемо говорити Під час цієї другої
панелі про закупівлі про те як придбати
якість продукти послуги обладнання про
те як це зробити вчасно коректно як
забезпечити виконання норм при
проведенні закупівель і головне де на
все це взяти гроші
тому що це ми розуміємо основне від чого
ми
відштовхуємось я хочу сказати що
сьогодні на цій сцені ви бачили тих
людей які фактично розробляють реформу
уже протягом року навіть більше і ми всі
команда розробників працюючи над
реформою системи шкільного харчування
очікували що на 1
вересня кожна територіальна громада
кожен автономно автономний в фінансовому
плані заклад кожен управлінець Тобто
кожна структура яка відповідає за
організацію харчування зможуть опанувати
нові норми скласти нові меню придбати
нове обладнання і
відповідно для для всього цього провести
якісні закупівлі але на жаль ми бачимо
ситуація дещо відрізняється від
очікуваної тому і саме тому було
впроваджено перехідний період до
закінчення фінансового року і наша з
вами задача використати оці 3 по місяці
які залишились до кінця перехідного
періоду максимально раціонально і
продуктивно тому що від того як ми зараз
з вами спрацюємо залежить чи в
наступному 22-му році наші діти будуть
харчуватися якісно безпечно корисно і
раціонально для більшості територіальних
громад як я вже говорила
задача старт дати старт реформі 1
вересня виявилася
непосильною Але ми всі розуміємо що
проблема не стільки в закупівлях саме в
сфері організації харчування скільки в
принципі проблема в проведенні
закупівель в галузі освіти це наша з
вами класична проблема коли закупівлями
займаються не ті люди які мають ними
займатися За
освітою коли до проведення закупівель не
залучені відповідні фахівці і технологи
і економісти і кухарі які мають якісно
підготувати технічне
завдання для проведення закупівлі послуг
або е продуктів харчування коли ми
покладаємось лише на думку директора
школи коли проводимо закупівлі
технологічного обладнання а він не
завжди освідчений і свідомий того які
сучасні тенденції використанні
професійного кухарського обладнання на
шкільному
харчоблоці чому так відбувається і якщо
насправді проблема є то як ми на неї
повинні відреагувати Я хочу щоб на ці
аспекти звернув увагу наш перший спікер
Олександр білянський начальник
управління конкурентної політики
Міністерства економіки бо це саме та
структура яка фактично формує державну
політику у сфері публічних закупівель
будь ласка прошу до слова пане
Олександре Дуже дякую Всім доброго
дня дійсно питання харчування дітей у
школах є надважливим для всіх нас хто
зараз знаходиться у залі і Дякую що
завантажили вже мою презентацію Я одразу
перейду до справ перше що хочу вам
повідомити це по суті мінекономіки у
серпні місяці створило робочу групою в
яку входять всі центральні органи
виконавчої ра органів виконавчої влади і
ми по суті працювали над тими питаннями
і проблемами які зібрали по суті від вас
а оскільки до цього ми надсилали
відповідні листи до всіх
облдержадміністрацій та міських рад з
метою отримання інформації від вас які
проблеми у вас виникають під час
проведення відповідних публічних
закупівель а також ми проаналізували
систему prozoro тобто що ми зробили ми
подивилися за якими кодами
ДК відбувається найбільша кількість
процедур закупівель і за результатами ми
дійшли до наступних результатів по суті
ми зараз виділяємо три глобальні коди ДК
за якими відбуваються процедури
закупівлі у prozoro перше - це послуги і
далень друге - це
кекей послуги і Третє - це послуги
харчування різні звичайно в системі
prozoro є і інші коди за якими закупаєте
можливо і ви як я впевнений що в залі є
голови та члени тендерних комітетів які
безпосередньо працюють з такими
документами як документація конкурсних
торгів та з системою prozoro в цілому а
Звичайно є і інші коди ДК але ми
виділяємо найбільшу кількість це саме за
цими кода
А в чому ж ми сфокусували по суті групу
проблем які виникають і групу викликів
які виникають у
замовників під час проведення
відповідних процедур закопівль перше це
недостатній дозвід в організації
тендерів А що це означає це не означає
що тендерний комітет він не спрацював
швидко або неефективно недостатньо
досвіду саме в частині як прописати в
тендерній документації всі вимоги і
правила за якими в подальшому суб'єкт
господарювання буде надавати або послугу
або надавати товар друге питання одразу
яке виникає це по суті як
проконтролювати тому що ми всі з вами
прекрасно
знаємо що в документації конкурсних
торгів і пропозиціях які потім подаються
учасниками ми говоримо не про товар який
буде поставлений або послуга яка буде
поставлена Зазвичай це документи які
фіксують факт того що учасник вже це
комусь надавав і звичайно там є певні
критерії до майбутніх поставок продукції
або послуги але про як це
проконтролювати фізично що дійсно якщо
ми замовляємо наприклад масло
солодковершкове що воно дійсно потрапить
в школу як масло солодковершкове а не
якісь або щось інше І які саме документи
дадуть можливість зафіксувати факт того
що це неякісна продукція можна її
забракувати не прийняти і відповідно
виставити якісь штрафні санкції або
зобов'язання на добросовісному
постачальнику і найголовніше що робити
далі тому що масло необхідно навчальний
процес безперервний і годувати дітей
необхідно кожен день друга категорія
проблем і викликів це по суті те що
писав неналежне виконання умов договорів
і відповідно низька низько прописана
відповідальність за невиконання умов
договорів поставки Третє - це
довготривалість про процедур закупівель
всі Я впевнений знають що провести
відкриті торги - це питання не двох і не
трьох днів Це питання декількох тижнів
якщо тендерний комітет працює надто
швидко і ефективно і немає запитань до
АА тендерної документації від учасників
і ще одним блоком викликів це дедостатня
кі кількість постачальників продуктів
харчування та послуг з організації
гарячого харчування у регіонах це
особливо стосується регіонів і невеликих
міст сел де немає великої кількості
суб'єктів господарювання які можуть
надавати послуги або предоставляти
відповідні товари
А ми згрупували по суті
цю ці питання і для вас і для всіх
колег підготували наступну інформацію
яку я вважаю з якою я вважаю повинен
ознайомитися Кожен член тендерного
комітету якою повинен керуватися в
обов'язковому порядку голова тендерного
комітету оскільки на ньому
знаходиться відповіда щодо відбору
дійсно ефективного
і якісного
учасника переможця вірніше який буде
надавати відповідну послугу або
предоставляти товар тому ми для вас по
суті розробили ще в 2020 році розроблено
методичні рекомендації щодо здійснення
закупівель у сфері організації
харчування це універсальна рамка це не
означає що цей єдиний типовий документ
за яким необхідно працювати Ні це
універсальна рамка за
якою можна виписати певні умови в
документації конкурсних тагів а також ми
для вас в рамках робочої групи А по тим
трьом ДК які я раніше презентував наразі
розробляємо примірну тендерну
документацію яку учасники яку замовники
можуть в подальшому використовувати
під час проведення тендерів Я дуже
багато Чув в процесі розробки від
учасників робочої групи і від а
безпосередньо голів тендерних комітетів
А давайте розробино розробимо типову
одразу тендерну документацію на жаль це
неможливо з двох причин перша причина -
Це закон України про публічні закупівлі
і обмеження щодо розробки типових
тендерних документацій друге - це
специфіка
насправді кожна школа -
це вони різняться між собою кожна школа
відрізняється кількістю учнів
кількістю площею
харчоблоку умовами майбутнього надання
тих чи інших послуг десь школа готує
самостійно повністю все меню десь
відбувається надання послуги з
кейтерингу або послуги Ден тому ми по
суті зробили так званий універсальний
конструктор який ви повинні
використовувати під час розробки власної
документації конкурсних торгів і вчора
ввечері ми вже в робочому порядку
направили до антимонопольного комітету
України України першу документацію - це
послуги їдалень примірно Ми сподіваємося
що оперативно та ефективно відпрацюємо з
колегами з антимонопольного комітету цю
примірну документацію і найближчим часом
ви вже побачите першу примірну докумен
ментацію по послугам єдалень да далі
будуть послуги скейтерингу і далі буде
відповідно продукти
харчування Також ми розіслали на всі Ода
та на всі міські
ради відповідний лист він інформативний
і я сподіваюся що ви його всі отримаєте
і будете використовувати в роботі це по
суті збірник всієї інформації яка
стосується проведення публічних
закупівель там по суті є все там є опис
як наприклад проводити а такі складні
види закупівель як закупівля за
рамковими угодами До речі закупівлі з
рамковими угодами - це дуже рідкісні
процедури закупівлі у системі prozoro а
також там є методичні рекомендації щодо
підготовки документації конкурс торгів
також
розписані
роз'яснення яким чином надавати
відповіді на запитання учасником яким
чином підготувати та завантажити в
систему prozoro відповідні відповідні
файли та документи щоб не було жодних
порушень Також там вже зазначено про те
що якщо у вас виникають технічні або
взагалі будь-які питання щодо проведення
ваших процедур закупівель ви можете
звернутися через відповідний портал до
представників мінекономіки з метою
отримання відповідних роз'яснень але я
хочу тут також закцентувати вашу увагу
що А ви як члени тендерного тендерного
комітету або голови тендерного комітету
Ми не можемо вам директивно ставити
завдання ви дієте в межах закону ви
дієте повністю незалежно ми можемо вас
проконсультувати і сказати що десь є
певні ризики або взагалі можливі
порушення вимог закону України про
публічні закупівлі також мінекономіки
напрацьовано зразки договорів про
закупівлі продуктів харчочування та
послуг ідалень вони розміщені на сайті
Міністерства економіки
і також Ми ще поговоримо Я впевнений в
рамках
наступної четвертої панелі питання
відповіді про proзоро marркет і і яким
чином він може вам допомогти у вирішенні
екстремальних питань коли наприклад
відміняється процедура закупівлі І що
робити необхідно оперативно дозакупити
або закупити хоча б мінімальну
кількість продукції яку з якої буде
виготовлятися порція для
учнів і в результаті ми підготували по
суті для вас
методичні узагальнюючіреко мендації з
конкретними документами які ви можете
використовувати в своїй роботі під час
підготовки вашої тендерної документації
трохи забігу наперед щодо послуг і
далень а по суті що це за примір на ДКТ
Я вейду зараз не в кожен пункт цієї
документації конкурсних торгів а
поблоково по суті це перший блок А
[музика]
це технічні вимоги до тієї послуги яка
надається в цьому блоці Ми описали
намагалися описати максимально все що
стосується якості надання послуги а та
стосується термінів надання відповідної
послуги а також ми окремо
а описали всі випадки а кваліфікаційних
критеріїв учасника Тобто ви можете
навіть поблоково вибирати з цієї
примірної документації те що вам
необхідно застосовувати в своїй
документації конкурсни і що ми в
результаті очікуємо ми очікуємо те що
кінцеву мету Ми таки реалізуємо і ми
отримуємо в кожній школі України якісне
харчування за найвищими європейськими
стандартами і результатом всієї реформи
і результатом розробленої документації
конкурсних торгів примірної і всіх наших
з вами зусиль стане то що в кожній школі
буде якісне харчування для цього по суті
ми
розробили і зараз будемо розсилати чіткі
рекомендації у віди примірної
документації конкурсних торгів
АА від вас ми очікуємо ефективного
проведення публічних закупівель без
жодних перешкод і без скарг до органів
антимонопольного комітету України
оскільки всі вимоги які ви пропишете
будуть максимально конкурентними і
будуть залучати максимальне коло
учасників на процедури закупівлі
а також ми очікуємо контроль ефективний
контроль за якістю надання послуг або
товарів які поставляється у школу
і також ми очікуємо те що кожен
постачальник який надає вам послугу буде
усвідомлювати відповідальність за
неякісне надання послуги або неякісне А
на якісну поставку товару Я вам дуже
дякую Сподіваюся на четвертій панелі ми
досить детально переговоримо з вами по
питаннях Які у вас виникають Дякую пане
Олександре Дозвольте будь ласка запитати
Чи плануєте ви розробку примірних ДКТ і
по рамковим угодам також тому що це
достатньо такий скажемо специфічний тип
закупівель не освоєний освітою дивіться
щодо рамкових угод це
насправді що це дає якщо дуже-дуже
простими словами по суті за результатами
проведеної процедури закупівлі по
рамковій угоді ви на певний період часу
вам не немає необхідності кожного року
проводити публічну закупівлю по суті ви
будете далі працювати там певний період
часу 2-т роки
а за спрощеною системою Тобто ви вам не
немає необхідності виписувати знову ж
таки всю документацію конкурсних торгів
якщо в цьому дійсно є потреба і давайте
переходити Ну тоді в дуже конкретні речі
що саме які проблеми є з рамковими
угодами тому що дуже багато інформації
і про що таке рамкова угода Як це
зробити як це провести є вже в
системі на порталі мінекономіки та дуже
багато роз'яснень є у відкритих джерелах
Давайте тоді просто згенеру мо конкретні
запитання і по них вже адресно проведемо
відповідну відповідний тренінг або
семінар Дуже дякую за вашу відповідь Маю
надію що ті хто зацікавлені в таких
типових
документах зможуть нам комунікувати ці
питання на четверту панель будь ласка
залишайте ваші запитання ми будемо
готувати відповіді на них А ми йдемо
далі Ну і скарги це та скажемо так
багаторічна і найбалючіша проблема
закупівель продуктів та послуг
харчування з яким стикалися більшість
замовників оскільки розгляд скарг дуже
видовжує саму процедуру і ми розуміємо
що під час видовження самої процедури
також якось потрібно харчувати дітей і
бажано харчувати якісно і повноцінно
тому скарги - це те фактично від чого ми
виштовхуємося плануючи кожні закупі лю
як потенційні ризики наших
закупівель можливість оскаржувати
рішення замовників є важливим елементом
державної політики в системі закупівель
і вона фактично формувалась для
підвищення якості закупівель але як саме
замовнику досягти оієї точки рівноваги
між очікуваними вимогами до потенційних
постачальників і тим як постачальник
бачить ці вимоги скоріше за всього може
розповісти нам тільки відповідний орган
який розглядає скарги це Антимонопольний
комітет України сьогодні у нас
представник антимонопольного Ольга
нечитаєва державний
уповноважений цієї структури ну хотілося
б почути практичні кейси пані Ольга
Дякуємо Дуже дякую пані Лесю Вітаю
учасникі панелі Вітаю шановні гості
форуму що ж хочу сказати що дійсно
навіть така соціально-чутлива сфера як
шкільне харчування не захищена від
зловживань та системних змов
Антимонопольний комітет в цьому
контексті виконує дві ролі по-перше ми
як конкурентне відомство розслідуємо
змови на торгах виявляємо факти
недобросовісної конкуренції накладаємо
штрафи і ведемо чорний список по-друге
дійсно Лесю Ви праві як орган оскарження
ми розглядаємо скарги а отже виступаємо
арбітром між учасниками та замовниками і
допомагаємо сформувати недискримінаційне
конкурентне середовище на кожній
закупівлі з
часом з року в рік кількість скарг яка
до нас надходить зростає колосально і
закупівлю у сфері шкільного харчування
не є
виключенням якщо розглядати саме
південні регіони то статистика свідчить
що кількість скарг яку ми
отримали щодо закупівель цих замовників
сягає близько 200 одиниць за останні два
роки в топі Полтавська область зокрема
закупівлі Полтавської міської ради Це
майже 98 скарг як далі іде Херсонська
обла сть Каховський і Новокаховський
район далі Одеса 31 скарга при цьому
половина з них стосується відділу освіти
озмеїлівської міської
ради примітно що в 50%ках випадків ми
встановлюємо факт порушення замовником
закону про публічні закупівлі тому якщо
у вас є системні проблеми з оскарженням
системні проблеми з організацією
процедури закупівлі будь ласка
звертайтесь до антимонопольного комітету
ми готові вам допомогти ми готові
провести спеціальні навчання для
замовників з цього питання Олександре
Дайте мені будь ласка
клікер
Дякую і все-таки для того щоб ваша
закупівля відбувалась успішно потрібно
пам'ятати два чіткі правила перше це
вимоги вашої документації мають бути
чіткими однозначними та мінімально
достатніми для того щоб підтвердити
безпечність продукції а також її якість
і спроможність учасника виконати договір
і друге - це рівне ставлення до всіх
учасників пам'ятайте що кожна вимога
вашої документації якщо вона не виконана
учасником В кінцевому випадку може
призвести до відхилення його пропозиції
і відповідно так до відхилення всіх
пропозицій на вашій
закупівлі відповідно відміни тендеру
тому будьте уважні при формуванні
тендерної
документації оскільки саме вона формує
фундамент для проведення конкурентної
процедури закупівлі Якщо ж скарга
все-таки надійшла що робити Ну звичайно
не варто панікувати це звичай це рутинна
справа потрібно її уважно вивчити Якщо є
можливість і ви з нею погоджуєтесь зі
скаргою необхідно усунути порушення і
повідомити проценти монопольний комітет
це суттєво скорочує строки розгляду
скарги якщо ви не погоджуєтесь необхідно
надавати максимально Розгорнуті письмові
пояснення підтверджувати їх
документально приїжджати в Київ на
засідання не
потрібно вся інформація я яку ми беремо
До уваги має бути викладена в системі
prozoro якщо ви ж все-таки хочете взяти
участь у засіданні це можна зробити з
приміщення південного міжобласного
відділення антимонопольного комітету
будь ласка звертайтесь до них далі хочу
трошки розповісти і про поведінку
учасників оскільки там теж є системні
зловживання так до нового навчального
року Антимонопольний комітет підходить з
шістьма справами про антиконкурентні
узгоджені дії щодо спотворення
результатів торгів у сфері шкільного
харчування за останні три роки ми
розглянули більше ніж 50 таких справ і
наклали 11 млн
штрафів як хто є типовим порушником Як
правило це фізична
особа-підприємець в
70% випадків Саме ці суб'єкти закривають
собою нішу закупівель з низкою очіку ною
вартістю і відповідно на таких торгах
Конкуренція є вкрай низькою
а другий учасник який заходить на
закупівлю відіграє сутотехнічну роль
тому роль замовника є визначальною
оскільки саме замовник може знайти
первинні ознаки змови і повідомити про
це Антимонопольний комітет України Якщо
ви не знаєте як сформувати заяву про
порушення будь ласка звертайтесь до
південного відділення антимонопольного
комітету там Вам
допоможуть але навіть якщо закупівля
відбулась і тендер пройшов успішно це
зновутаки не означає якісну поставку так
за
останній рік ми наклали 141 мльн штрафів
на недобросовісних виробників молочної
продукції 11 суб'єктів
господарювання продукція цих виробників
постачалась в лікарні дитячі садочки
школи
інтернати проте вміст немолочних речовин
в цій продукції досягав
901% тобто Фактично це був фальсифікат я
хочу відзначити одразу що ключовими
доказами у цих справах були саме
висновки
держпроцспожівслужби і хочу звернутися
до пані владислави якщо ви знаєте про
інші факти фальсифікації продукції будь
ласка інформуйте нас оскільки така
практика надає ще й недобросовісні
переваги в
конкуренції одночасно замовнику
необхідно жорстко контролювати стан
виконання контракту передбачати
відповідні умови в
договорах за необхідності залучати
спеціалізовані лабораторії фіксувати
документально кожен факт порушення і
такі документи можна передавати
компетентним органам у тому числі
антимонопольному комітету оскільки
інакше порушники знову і знову будуть
брати участь у тендерах і постачати
неякісні продукти нашим
дітям Ну і на останок Я хочу завершити
тим що є кілька простих правил які
допоможуть нам зробити закупівлі
успішними і більш конкурентними найперше
це недискримінаційна Тен
документація друге добросовісна по
поведінка учасників та замовників
третє контроль жорсткий контроль з боку
замовників фіксуйте документами
порушення накладайте санкції Передавайте
відповідну інформацію до компетентних
органів і тільки так ми зможемо зробити
наші закупівлі більш якісними і
успішними а харчування безпечним та
смачним Дякую за увагу і чекаю ваших
запитань Дякуємо пані
Ольга я скоріше за все скажу Так
коментуючи ваш виступ що зараз перед
вами люди для яких в пріоритеті
накормити дітей а не шукати змови в
тендерах і якісь інші нюанси да тому
Дякую Тому скажіть будь ласка А от як
правильно організувати все-таки
претензійну роботу для постачальників
для того щоб потім у замовника була
реальна підстава для відхилення таких
потенційних учасників в наступних
тендерах це має бути тільки акт Чи це
рішення суду от що буде реально законною
підставою для того щоб такі
постачальники більше не заходили на наші
закупівлі Підкажіть Дякую Ну дійсно
частина друга статті 17 закону про
публічні закупівлі дає замовнику
можливість відхиляти е постачальників
які були визнані недобросовісними і з
якими контракт було достроково розірвано
для того щоб це зробити вам необхідно
організувати претензійну роботу в
порядку передбаченому господарським
кодексом тобто направити претензію в
претензії обов'язково мають міститись
докази встановленого порушення той самий
акт або висновок держпроти
процспоживслужби і тоді якщо
постачальник не відшкодує вам збитки не
сплатить пеній
і в результаті судо судового розгляду
судової справи Ви виграєте справу і
рішення набуде законної сили Ви матимете
законні підстави більш відхиляти
пропозиції таких недобросовісних
учасників тому дуже важливо щоб Ви
думали і прозмови і Про недобросовісну
конкуренцію і про фальсифікат
заздалегідь оскільки інакше наступного
року ку можливо вам знову доведеться
працювати з цим недобросовісним
суб'єктом ну це в тому випадку якщо він
не перереєструється під іншим прізвищем
дуже
дякую Так дійсно ми розуміємо що проблем
в закупівлях
вистачає і як
правило ті хто професійно займається
цією справою чітко усвідомлюють що
проблема неякісних постачальників
фактично є наслідком неякісної тендерної
документації замкнене коло да тобто в
принципі начебто і хочемо але якось не
дуже виходить Я хочу сказати що наша з
вами я маю на увазі замовників мрія
фактично уже здійснюється тому що ми
маємо масу інструментів які допомагають
нам уникати проблем з
підготовкою тендерної документації і є
уже інструменти які допомагають обирати
тільки серед тих постачальників які
пройшли перевірку і їм можна довіряти
про цей інструмент і про інші можливості
сучасні які у нас є з вами в доступі я
Прошу розповісти пана Андрія Кузьменка
заступника директора з розвитку
централізованої закупівельної
організації професійні закупівлі Пане
Андрію будь ласка дякую доброго дня
шановна громада
дійсно вім сьогодні про те як можна
простіше проводити закупівлі закупівлі
продуктів харчування через систему
prozoro ми є да державна установа
професійні закупівлі ми є першою
централізованою закупівельною
організацією і маємо статус
адміністратора електронного каталогу
prozoro Market а також проводимо
закупівлі для центральних органів
виконовчої влади та інших державних
замовників що ж таке прозоромар prozoro
Market - це частина системи prozoro
побудована у вигляді
онлайнмагазину і там до 50 000 вон
працює прям так само як будь-який
онлайнмагазин з яким ви певно мали будь
якийсь досвід як на Розетці чи на
хотлайні коли ви знайшли товар поклали
його у кошик натиснули замовити і потім
укладаєте угоду з постачальникам від 50
000 до 200 000 грн працює схоже ви
знайшли товар який Вам підходить І ви
робите запит ціни для пошуку найкращої
пропозиції серед усіх постачальників
яких ми вже перевірили і кваліфікували в
prozoro marкеet Тобто Це ось виглядає на
прикладі категорії овочі і фрукти ви
Заходите в категорію овочі і фрукти
бачите всі продукти які там наявні
наприклад вас цікавить морква ви
Заходите в моркву бачите що є декілька
видів моркви коли ви хоче Ну зрозу
розуміли що хочете купити наприклад
морква середньостигла Ви зайшли в моркву
середньостиглу і бачите пропозиції
постачальників які вже кваліфіковані і
можете обрати пропозицію того
постачальника який Вам підходить є
можливість фільтрувати за вашою областю
за вашим
регіоном за іншими
умовами чому ж prozoro marкет чому ж ми
вважаємо що prozoro Market - це зручно
купувати продукти харчування ми провели
аналітику і по дивилися що в 2020 році
87% усіх закупівель продуктів харчування
це були закупівлі до 200 000 грн і
prozoro Market - це власне най
найзручніший інструмент купувати до 200
000 грн
е яким законодавством регулюється
законо електронний каталог проzor
marркет ну
по-перше Закон України Про публічні
закупівлі де вказано що prozoro Market
це законний інструмент як альтернатива
спрощеної закупівлі до 200,000 грн і є
також окрема постанова Кабінету
Міністрів яка регулює правила роботи в
prozoro
Market які ж переваги prozoro Market їх
п'ять Ну перша перевага - це все те що
вам потрібно в одному місті це не тільки
продукти харчування це все те що
закуповують школи інші державні установи
це і меблі для нової української школи і
комп'ютерне обладнання і підручники І
звісно продукти харчування ми додали всі
продукти які наявні в новому шкільному
меню там більше 160 продуктів всі ці
продукти зараз уже додані в prozoro
marкет їхні технічні вимоги вже
сформовані там вже є постачальники в
яких це можна
купувати власне друга перевага що для
того щоб купувати в proзоро marркет Вам
не потрібно виписувати технічні вимоги
технічні вимоги уже Ми створили і то
товари які наявні в прозоромаркет - це
товари які вже відповідають цим
технічним
вимогам третя перевага - це те що
постачальників вам також не треба шукати
вам не треба перевіряти їх за всіми
реєстрами ми перевірили за санкційними
списками за чорним списм амку За всіми
реєстрами який вимагає закон про
публічні закупівлі подивилися на досвід
цих постачальників що в них є досвід
роботи з цими товарами і кваліфікували
Вони мають право е продавати через
proзоро marкет четверта перевага - це
швидко в порівнянні зі спрощеною
процедуру яка в середньому займає 21
день від початку до укладання угоди
prozor marкеet якщо ви купуєте прямим
відбором це в середньому 4отири дні якщо
ви купуєте через запит ціни пропозиції
це в середньому 8 днів Тобто це ну за
тиждень ви вже ма можете мати товари на
своїх складах п'ята перевага - це ще й
вигід
ми постійно моніторимо ціни тут от на
прикладі борщовий набір або запіканковий
набір на по продуктах харчування і ми
постійно бачимо що закупівлі в прозро
marкет дають найкращу ціну в порівнянні
із спрощеними закупівлями чи процедури
звітування в середньому
ціна через запит ціни пропозиції на 2%
краще ніж через спрощені
закупівлі нагадаю що два способи купити
через prozoro Market це якщо більше 50
000 грн це запит ціни пропозиції менше
50 гри 50 000 грн Це прямий
відбір така Ну простенька інструкція є
для запиту ціни пропозиції ви розміщаєте
запит чекаєте два дні постачальника який
запропонував на кращу
ціну потім йомудається ще час
підтвердити Як тільки він підтвердив ви
можете укладати з ним угоду При прямому
відборі все ще простіше ви поклали товар
у кошик на постачальника йде
повідомлення Що ви хочете з ним укла
укласти угоду ви укладаєте угоду
звітуєте її в системі
prozoro Це такий приклад теж на прикладі
категорії овочі і фрукти Що наприклад
вам За рік треба купити на 190 000 грн
там є морква цибуля
помідори якщо якийсь з цих товарів менше
000 грн ви Кожен з них можете купити
напряму у постачальника і укласти угоду
якщо більше 50 000 ви проводите запит
ціни
пропозиції також хочемо звернути що
ми пильнуємо за тим щоб постачальники
вели себе добросовісно в proзоро marркет
якщо якийсь постачальник який вам Ну ви
з ним плануєте укласти угоду Він
пропонує іншу ціну або пропонує інший
товар то ви можете надіслати звернення
на нас на централізовану закупівельну
організацію ми перевіряємо ці факти і
якщо постачальник протягом місяця має
три підтверджених порушення або протягом
трьох місяців п'ять порушень ми такого
постачальника банемо Ну тобто він на
певний час немає можливості проводити
закупівлі через proзоро маркет
взагалі тут трошки цифр це показати як в
Україні зараз замовники в цілому
користуються перевагами prozoromket вже
майже 7% всіх замовників в країні
скористалися prozoromket можна побачити
що в яких регіонах там цифри більше
зеленим кольором я підкреслив саме
регіони які присутні сьогодні на
зустрічі
також показати що з початку року уже
продуктів харчування через prozoro
Market закуплено на 45 млн грн видно що
Полтавська область замовники Полтавської
області більше 50% закупівель які вони
зробили через prozor marкеet це були
продукти харчування Одеська область
35%. ну в середньому по країні це
25%. нагадаю ще раз про переваги через
які ми рекомендуємо користуватися в
закупівлях саме проzoroomarket Ну
по-перше це всі товари які вам потрібні
вже перед вами на екрані проzoro Market
по-друге це вже сформована тендерна
документація по-третє це вже
постачальники яких ми знайшли яких
перевірили які відповідають всім вимогам
в четвер четверте - це швидко і п'яте -
це ще й дає вам додаткову економію в
грошах тому всім рекомендуємо
використовувати prozor marкет для
закупівлі продуктів харчува ще
безкоштовно так Пане Андрію да да звісно
замовників це все безкоштовно Дуже
дякуємо акцентую Шановні колеги на тому
що протягом місяця державної установою
професійні закупівлі які зараз
представляє пан Андрій було
проаналізовано повністю все меню яке
готується мозом до рекомендацій і всі
товари з переліку необхідних для
забезпечення цього меню заведені в
маркет в proзоромаркет тобто повний
перелік будь ласка користуйтесь це дуже
зручно чотири або вісім днів звичайно в
порівнянні з двохмісячними торгами це
зовсім інша річ Шановні колеги У нас
сьогодні під час Першої панелі був
присутній пан Міністр освіти Сергій
Миколайович шкарлет який розповідав нам
про субвенційні можливості Які кошти
находять надходять з державних бюджетів
на місцеві для того щоб у нас була
можливість модернізувати харчоблоки І
розпочати
використовувати сучасне модернізоване
мультифункціональне обладнання в
харчоблоках наших шкіл і їдалень Я так
розумію що у
212 році ті субвенції які заводяться на
регіони вони не є цільовими у вас є
можливість обирати серед переліку тих
напрямків які для вас будуть
пріоритетними при використанні і
мільярда спроможної школи і 209 млн
залишків інших субвенцій в 21му році та
інші Можливо ще будуть якісь
кошти але ці кошти які надходять
субвенційно вони як ми бачимо спасають
ситуацію 1809 закладів в 20-му році
отримали можливість скористатися
субвенційними 110 погоджено лише в цьому
році при загальній кількості
1455сяч шкіл в Україні і більше 20 000
закладів дошкільної освіти Звичайно це
капля в морі Тому кошти де їх взяти як
їх раціонально розподілити як громада
може вплинути на такі рішення
і від кого вони в громаді залежать краще
всього почути від людей які вже цю
практику впроваджують Отже цей скажемо
так регіональний аспект використання
субвенційних коштів а також як місцеві
кошти можна раціонально використати для
того щоб впровадити імплементувати
реформу шкільного харчування і
забезпечити нашу націю на перспективу
бути здоровою і повноцінною нам сьогодні
розповість заступник голови Полтавської
Обласної Державної
адміністрації Ми запрошуємо до слова
пана Дмитра Луніна будь ласка клікер
Доброго дня Всіх вітаю ну будемо
говорити про кошти де їх взяти Ну що
може відповісти заступник головам громад
Ну те що кошти у вас є Ну ми ж не для
чого не для цього зібрались
тут в Одесі щоб це обговорювати так
дійсно У нас є така аналітика що на
початок цього року кошти в громадах на
рахунках було біля 800 млн в Полтавській
області на 1 вересня їх вже 1 300 тобто
кошти не так швидко витрачають громади
тобто вони є і за них можна дійсно
будувати нормальні хорчоблоки але хочу
розказати вам за наш досвід у нас на
сьогодні наступна ситуація як засновник
приймає рішення до для того щоб
ремонтувати харчоблок тобто нормальна
людина як я приходить до
харчоблоко задає себе одне питання хочу
я щоб мої діти наприклад їли ї їли в цій
ядальні або їм готували в цьому
харчоблоті і це перше питання яке у нас
перша думка яка приходить в голову ко ми
коли ми попадаємо до
сучасних або не зовсім сучасних шкільних
закладів ви знаєте що впроваджена
програма президента велике будівництва і
згідно цієї програми дійсно проходять
комплексні проекти йде будівництво саме
в тому числі харчоблоків Ну ви бачите
якщо Полтавська область пять-шість
об'єктів в рік буде будувати то ми так
ну Точно це будуть наші першачки які
пішли до школи
закінчувати ці
зміни тому враховуючи стратегію розвитку
Полтавської області яку прийняли
депутати обласної ради одна із цілей є
це якісне життя якісне життя воно
починається з чуння як ми сьогодні чули
від Сергія Миколайовича то дійсно була
впроваджена один із заходів Це розробка
програми якісне харчування дітям
Полтавщини Яка наша була основна ідея Це
в першу чергу що нам треба
зробити
щоби все нормально Що треба зробити щоб
засновники почали
ремонтувати харчоблоки була розроблена
програма ми побачили що дійсно немає
комплексного підходу Тобто хтось купує
обладнання хтось робить ремонт а хтось
робить вентиляцію ну це не комплексний
підхід і тому була розроблена програма
згідно якої ми
фінансуємо ті
харчоблоки в яких плануємо в яких
зроблений вже ремонти і ми надаємо 70%
коштів на закупівлю обладнання
технологічного і % це співфінансування з
коштів
громад надалі у нас
дійсно було проведено вже біля 60
ремонтів в
закладах загальної середньої освіти і в
минулому році ми закупили на 15 млн 62
заклади в цьому році вже нам подано
заявок на 10 мльні Гринь до програми на
закладів на 57 харчоблоків
щодо надання обладнання далі з чим
стикається у нас наші заклади освіти в
першу чергу це як зробити проект тому що
за звичкою приходять до Будівельників до
проектантів говорять зробить нам
харчоблок но я впевнений що саме головне
тут технологія і все починає починається
саме з технологічного процесу тому що це
не тільки безпека і якість це ще і
економічний ефект
який при правильно
спланованому процесі буде надавати шко
школі економію то що ми говорили
сьогодні що нам покажуть як три кухаря
зроблять 700 блюд за там я не пам'ятаю
за за годину да 45 хвилин та за 45
хвилин сім страв для 700 чоловік Да
дякую тому ми розробили програму основна
мета
була заохочити засновника вкладати гроші
в харчоблоки і з свого боку обласна
адміністрація обласна рада надає також
кошти всім закладам які
хочуть це робити але ми ж розуміємо 500
закладів Ми не можемо зробити за
короткий час і тому ми обрали в першу
чергу опорні заклади тому що ми дійсно
вважаємо що в першу чергу треба вкладати
в опорні заклади тому що так або зараз
або пізніше засновники будуть
об'єднувати ці заклади і всі діти будуть
підвозитись до опорних закладів Ну і це
міські школи де навчається 400 та більше
дітей за чотири роки ми плануємо
повністю оновити всі харчоблоки в
Полтавській
області наступне питання яке
е Мене цікавить Це де знайти гроші то що
ми говорили і я вам зараз розкажу
скільки ВР державі є програм і на
прикладі Полтавської області є і
обласних програм де взяти гроші Ну перше
ми вже почули що місцеві кошти ніхто не
відміняв і дійсно дуже багато
витрачається коштів Полтавській області
Я дуже дякую головам громад засновникам
за те що вони вкладають в заклади освіти
великі кошти друге - це обласна програма
дітям Полтавщини якісне харчування третя
в Полтавській області Та я так розумію в
кожній області є такий така субвенція з
обласного бюджету до місцевих бюджетів
це фонд розвитку територій Тобто це
кошти надаються громаді на ті або інші
проекти тобто вже в Полтавській області
на сьогодні виділили біля 15 мльнів
додатково Крім тих що ви побачили коштів
саме на розвиток харчеблоків крім цього
У нас є державні програми це
і державни фонд регіонального розвитку і
в Полтавській області Вона діє Я знаю
діє в Одеській області це надзвичайна
кредитна програма для відновлення
України
також вкладаються кошти і в харчоблоки і
саме в шкільні заклади це давайте не
забувати за соцеконом депутатів народних
які також можуть вкладати і повинні
вкладати в свої громади які їх обирали
Третє це наступне - це інфраструкту
турна субвенція в цьому році вже
розподілена 5,8 млрд грнь на різні
напрямки в тому числі і на шкільні
заклади тобто коштів або джерел
фінансування дуже багато
одне одна вимога - це якісні комплексні
проекти які дійсно повинні зробити
професіонали треба залучати не буді не
проектантів які вміють будувати робити
класні проекти по будівництву а саме ті
хто знаються на технологіях і ці
технології ми можемо впроваджувати саме
в харчоблоках Дякую за увагу дуже слушне
зауваження Дякуємо пане Дмитре за
скажемо так докладну інформацію про те
де все-таки нам можна взяти кошти
шановні друзі Я так розумію море трошки
вносить якусь таку розслабляючу нотку в
нашу з вами роботу я дуже прошу вас не
забувати про те що ви маєте унікальну
можливість задати будь практичне
запитання яке вас цікавить всім спікерам
Які сьогодні перед вами і на четвертій
панелі ми озвучимо всі ваші запитання і
отримуємо докладні відповіді на них тому
будь ласка у вас в папочках є листочок
спеціально для цього ми його розробили і
заклали щоб ви мали можливість задати
своє питання і покласти його на видному
місці і крім того прошу вас не забути по
закінченню нашого заходу оцінити нашу
роботу тому що нам важливо розуміти чи
було щось корисне сьогодні для вас і для
ваших громад що Чи можете ви взяти якісь
практичні нюанси з нашої
роботи Дякую всім за увагу Дуже дякую
нашим спікерам сьогоднішнім і прошу
залишатися на четверту панель ми вас
також будемо
запрошувати Дякую шановне панство ще раз
ваші облески спікерам було досить
докладно для себе відкрив дуже багато в
плані прозоромаркету виявляється все
значно простіше ніж Це здається на
перший погляд вже все зроблено за нас
просто потрібно скористатися цією
можливістю друзі приємна новина
кавабрейк але ця новина буде після того
як я вам нагадаю погодьтеся
чудова
погода Прекрасна картинка вигляд на
мільйон там море Тут друзі є
багато-багато
спокус але давайте з вами домовимося що
ці спокуси почнуть втілюватися в життя
після
16:00 якраз на той час жара спаде я вам
як людина яка тут живе це можу сказати а
зараз кавабрейк зустрічаємося з вами о
13 годині Будемо дивитися
як три
людини за 45 хвилин приготують сім страв
для 700 людей практично біблейний сюжет
до зустрічі за за
[музика]
півгодини
[оплески]
[музика]
there's only
one forget Trouble and to Shine I Hit
The Dr
Running and all I do is to have Fun no
no no tight I wan Give
[музика]
everything no no no Tonight
[оплески]
[музика]
I
[оплески]
[музика]
on Every GL got
Around to foret and to
Shine All I want Do is
[музика]
Him
I Put on Every CL
[музика]
got
[оплески]
[музика]
Don't
forget
[музика]
дорогі друзі шановне панство буквально
10 хвилин і ми чекаємо вас в залі Я
розумію що краєвид манить до себе але
треба трошки-трошки набратися терпіння
погодься те чого чекаєш і те про що
мрієш воно потім ще цікавіше приємніше
тепліше солоніше як наша чор море 10
хвилин і ми
[музика]
починаємо
Oh
[музика]
yeay
Why do I get so D
[музика]
speechless
L When I Look In
Your
[музика]
exp
spech losing my
mind Love with
[музика]
you
spe
[музика]
ye
spe speechless
[музика]
spech Why I get so
speechless Oh
ye
[музика]
L When I Look In Your
Eyes can expain
[музика]
To
spech
My Love with
[музика]
you spech
spe spe
[музика]
spe
Oh
[музика]
yeay you
like what like of
Do you like The ss
[музика]
of
же же
[музика]
же
Yeah beauic
[музика]
[оплески]
music
[музика]
of
Music
ja
Music Jazz Music
Yeah
[музика]
друзі Нагадую що буквально 5 хвилин і ми
починаємо і тому запрошую вас займати
свої місця в
залі
[музика]
[оплески]
jz music
[музика]
друзі Я ще раз вас за закликає займати
свої місця Наші шеф-кухарі вже практично
готові відпрацювати свій гонорар дайте
їм таку можливість будь
[музика]
ласка
друзі прошу сідати
прошу хочу нагадати вам що ми працюємо в
рамках певного таймінгу і насправді
зараз самі себе
затримуємо нагадаю що зараз на Ваших
очах буде приготовлено за 45 хвилин 700
для 700 людей сім страв
А для цього в нас є Шеф Кухарі
є прилади на яких готувати є все для
відповідно тих стандартів яких про які
говорилося в першій панелі
хочу нагадати
що акцентувати вашу увагу на prozoro
Market тому що як на мене я сидів слухав
і розумів для себе одну річ Дуже зручно
раз дуже просто два і основне
безпечно не мені вам говорити що таке
безпека в нашій країні особливо те що
стосується сфери
закупівель думаю що це зручно думаю що
ви цим будете
користуватися спілкуючись вже особисто
почую таку штуку Коли ти переїжджаєш в
територіальну громаду і говориш про те
що є можливість в школі закуповувати в
один клік або за попереднім
замовленням не потрібно забувати про те
що в ваших громадах є виробники цих
продуктів є фермери є
сільськогосподарські підприємства які
абсолютно спокійно можуть зайти в
перелік тих підприємств які знаходяться
вже
е в prozoro marкет і тим самим ви даєте
можливість заробити своїм тобто кошти
залишаються в громаді як на мене це
досить така цікава Дякую вам дякую Це
досить така цікава штука
і для місцевого самоврядування яке
розуміє що тепер потрібно заробляти
самому Мені здається це дуже потрібна
потрібні знання
а так давайте зробимо невеличку
перекличку і подивимося яка область
найбільш
дисциплінована
почнемо з наших найдальших сусідів
Полтава молодці Полтава ви знаєте 53%і
prozороo Маркеті за рік це досить
потужний результат якщо
середньостатистичний по Україні всього
лиш 25 Ви молодці
Кіровоград молодці але дивіться на
Полтаву
Миколаїв Я так розумію що транспорт
частково вже відправляється туди так
Херсон Херсон знову за голядкою на
Миколаїв Ну і Одеса
звичайно
супер було приємно побачити 35% прозоро
Ми молодці Ми майже як
Полтава Це був комплімент Полтаві в
першу
чергу друзі добре від жартів до більш
серйозного я бачу щоіль частина наших
делегатів форуму вже зійшлися і не бачу
причини продовжити затягувати час 10
хвилин ми вже втратили тому плюс 10
хвилин плюс 100 у вас і Я запрошую на цю
сцену модераторів цієї панелі це Тетяна
скоропляс заступник виконавчого
директора національної асоціації
громадського харчування та голова
управління Національної асоціації
громадського харчування степаняк Орест
під ваші
оплиски
Дякую Валерій Вітаю вас всіх на нашому
форумі на нашій практичній частині
Нарешті ми її дочекалися і я спробую
відразу ввести вас всіх в курс справи Що
власне відбувається за нашими спинами за
нашими спинами змонтована кухня фактично
аналог теплового цеху шкільного
харчоблоку це неповноцінна Кухня Тому що
тут бракує кількох цехів мийно охоло
дильного механічної обробки продуктів
але тут відбувається найголовніше
приготування страв і зараз ми спробуємо
вам продемонструвати фактично таке
показове шоу як на майже 700 осіб Тому
що нас з вами більше ніж 600 майже 700
Ми приготуємо шість основних страв за 45
хвилин тобто за умовний час уроку щоби
потім вам на перерві це все видати
Це набагато більше ніж зазвичай може
осягнути звичайна кухня шкільного
кахарчоблоку ми робимо це для того щоб
показати вам що все можливо можливо
готувати навіть в таких величезних
об'ємах і хочу розказати хто ж ми такі
ми громадська асоціація Національна
Асоціація громадського харчування
це громадська організація яка об'єднала
в собі велике потужне середовище кухарів
технологів лікарів всіх хто певною мірою
дотичний до системи громадського
харчування і ми От вже зараз готові з
вами ділитися своїм досвідом орес Я
пропоную запускати роботу нашої кухні
щоби не гаяти часу і розпочинати нашу
практичну панель Ну що ж тоді ми можемо
подивитися на свої годинники і почати
відлік 45 хвилин а ви хлопці можете
розпочинати вперед
так хлопці з Богом попрошу ведучого
засікти нам точний час щоб ми точно
вклалися в регламент який ми собі
запланували оресте Давайте до суті
відразу
переходити давайте розкриємо хоча б В
загальних рисах яка роль нашої
організації в реформі системи шкільного
харчування я перед тим попросив би щоб
нам вивели суфлер будь ласка екран в нас
не працює суфлер ми не будемо бачити
презентації а роль асоціації Ми впевнені
Враховуючи те що ми кожного дня кожного
тижня є в регіонах дуже багато кого я
знаю тут особисто і мене знають ми
приїжджаємо до вас спілкуємось до того
ми вивчали досвід свій за кордоном ми
вважаємо що ми є носії певних знань
певної технології яку ми можемо
імплементувати і допомогти вам це
зробити наші відвідани тої чи іншої
області тої чи іншої громади допомагають
цим громадам вийти на Крок вперед В
розумінні того якою має бути ця реформа
дуже часто ми буває таке що ми приїхали
з презентації приготували в якійсь
області для керівників відділів освіти
приготували їжу
для до прикладу директорів шкіл і до
мене підходять люди і кажуть ви знаєте
от я тільки щойно зрозумів ось це суть
реформи Чому Тому що в цьому нашому
трикутнику продукти кухарі технологія
дуже часто бракує інформації про техно
хнологію Якраз сьогодні ми будемо
пробувати вам розказувати про
технологічність тому що без цього На
жаль неможлива сучасне приготування їжі
неможливий сучасний технологічний процес
тому рухаємось давайте відразу
переходити до проблематики з неї варто
завжди розпочинати щоби розуміти на що
ми спираємося і в від чого
відштовхуємося і що маємо
змінювати
яку головну проблему ви би могли
виокремити в в шкільному харчуванні
наразі в Україні Ну я думаю що якщо б ми
дали можливість цю проблему
е це запитання задали би аудиторії Ми би
отримали напевно зараз 1000 і одне
питання 1ся О аргумент Які в нас є
проблематики для того щоби в нас
відбулася якісна реформа шкільного
харчування але якщо їх всіх об'єднати в
одне запитання найважливіше це є те що
діти в школі відмовляються їсти дуже
часто діти оминають шкільну їдальню з
цього в нас випливає наступне якщо
дитина не приходить їсти в школу вона не
залишається голодною Вона дійсно
споживає їжу але яку тоді головним
конкурентом нашої шкільної їдальні з
гарячою здоровою їжею виступає магазин
МАФ мама яка спакувала з собою ланчбокс
відповідно з якоюсь канапочкою і це є
дуже небезпечно тому що ми сьогодні
спілкувалися з паном Віктором на панелі
Я забув за дати це питання але анонсую
вам для нього Замість замість пана
міністра що в нас понад 12% дитячого
ожиріння в шкільному віці Тобто Це є
дуже погано через що це відбувається це
відбувається через те що
е діти часто споживають газовані напої
діти часто споживають снеки і ми не
можемо їх в тому обмежити тому що ми
можемо обмежити його в школі ми можемо
обмежити його на підходах до школи але
ми не можемо його обмежити по дорозі
коли дитина йде виходить з свого дому і
купує з собою плящину ее кока-коли
pпеepsі чи ще якогось це не антиреклама
якихось певних брендів Але ми всі
розуміємо яка кількість вмісту цукру і і
всього всього там тому наше завдання
зробити так щоби дитина захотіла
приходити ее в шкільну їдальню і
величезні кроки на шляху до цього
відбуваються тому що ми змінюємо ми
змінюємо технологію ми змінюємо Таня
зверну увагу на суплер ми змінюємо
технологію Ми змінюємо а
ми маємо нові норми ми обмежуємо
некорисні продукти і зараз нам
залишається ще декілька правильних
кроків для того щоб ми рухались в
правильному
напрямку попрошу технічну службу підійти
до нас в нас не працює клікер Орест з
того всього що ви сказали я не розумію
От чого власне діти не їдять їм не
смачно Їм не подобається естетика страв
саме в шкільно в шкільній їдальні Чому
вони не їдять от в чому найб більша біда
того
всього я перед тим як буду розказувати
Чому діти не їдять запрацював клікер в
нас все
гаразд супер попередній слайд чому діти
не їдять на наш погляд ми трішки
відходимо від кухні тому що там починає
бути
гаряче наші кухні кухарі активно
працюють діти не їдять в школі По тій
причині що ця їжа не актуальна для них
ми в
мож можливо вже поза сотню шкіл
проводили експеримент де ми зустрічалися
з дітьми заходили в школу просили щоби
нас покинули викладачі і директор школи
і ми з дітьми спілкувалися задавали їм
питання ви в школі їсте частина дітей
казала так переважно це перший четвертий
клас молодша школа Старша школа в
більшості на кухню в шкільну їдальню
заходить рідко ті хто нам казали що вони
в школі не їдять ми їм задавали
запитання А чому ви не їсте в школі
відповідь їхня була дуже проста тому що
там немає вибору і другий аргумент тому
що там не смачно ті хто не їдять Я зараз
Звертаю увагу виключно на ті хто не
їдять але є дуже великий позитив в
Україні тому що в нас уже є сотні шкіл в
яких їдять і це прекрасно де їжа свіжа
де їжа гарна естетична і це І це чудово
так
ось якщо ми говоримо про
неестетичність їжі Ми ніколи не можемо
говорити про те що дитина її захоче
з'їсти тому що дитина її спочатку
споживає очима ми коли з ва ми проходимо
попри магазин попри вітрину якогось кафе
в першу чергу ми звертаємо увагу на їжу
очима якщо їжа виглядає естетично якщо
вона цікава якщо вона гарного кольору ми
тоді захочемо до неї підійти коли ми її
підійшли ми маємо отримати їжу не суху
непересмажену в олії Вона має бути така
за якою ми хочемо повернутися ще раз і
для нас кухарі зараз підготували зварили
декілька
А це щойно при вас буквально там за 5-7
хвилин зварилися деякі продукти так
тобто в нас тут є зелений горошок в нас
є бурячок
морква якщо ми дивимося на такі кольори
вони є дуже яскравими це 100%
подобається дітям якщо такі кольори
овочі будуть в салатах якщо вони будуть
використовуватись в гарнірах ми
однозначно говоримо про те що
привабливість цієї їжі буде давати
можливість дітям до неї приходити і її
споживати що
забезпечує отакий колір варіння виключно
на пару якщо ми варимо на пару ми
залишаємо всі корисні елементи в
продукті і якщо ми варимо на пару ми
добиваємося дуже гарного кольору Звісно
якщо ми візьмемо цю саму морквинку і
помістимо її в воду колір буде уже не
такий і в принципі всі корисні елементи
вона віддасть воді десь приблизно так
оресте але ж якщо ось наприклад навіть
красивий зварений горошок постоїть
більше годинкидвох на повітрі він
обвітриться і буде мати вже не
естетичний вигляд скільки часу за
всіма правилами мають зберігатися страви
в шкільній їдальні і за скільки часу
вони мають видаватися дітям ну чудове
запитання тут навіть не питання в
горошку тут Питання в тому що я
анонсував на попередній панелі з нашими
нашими шановними
спікерами Ви маєте цікавитися давайте
знаєте поговоримо про таке слово хасп
всі його знають всі з ним працюють Але
більшість з вас відноситься до нього так
як відносився до нього Колись я як до
документу який потрібно пройти поставити
в кінці нього печатку підпис і покласти
його на полку я відверто вам кажу я так
само до нього колись відносився до тих
пір поки я не почав їздити вивчати
досвід в Європі А для них хасп - це є
постійне вдосконалення Тобто це є
філософія це є робота з яку ти проводиш
кожного дня тобто якщо ми подивимося на
це Таким чином тоді ми
напевно усі з вас як управлінці заходять
на ваші харчоблоки в ту чи іншу школу
коли ви туди приходите вам звичайно До
того всі готуються в більшості вам
демонструють гарний харчоблок гарних
кухарів і якісь продукти які там готують
так ось Якщо ви звернете на це
увагу велика кількість продуктів у 99%
українських шкіл приготовлена і чекає на
свою видачу це є закономірність усіх
українських шкіл так ось це є перше
порушення норм хасп тому що ми маємо їжу
приготувати і одразу її віддати якщо ми
її не віддаємо Ми її маємо помістити в
безпечне середовище при температурі +3
так ось для нас дуже важливо навчитися
навчити вас а потім щоби ви працювали з
цим з вашими директорами і з вашими
кухарями в ваших школах Чи це
кейтерингова компанія чи Це ваші власні
кухарі Чи це комунальне підприємство яке
надає вам послуги щоб вони працювали з
видачею постійно свіжого продукту
приготували віддали як це забезпечити
для того щоб це забезпечити нам потрібно
ці процеси розбивати на декілька етапів
про що ми
поговоримо трішки трішки згодом Мабуть
так давайте переходити до наступного
нашого слайду і поговоримо трішки про
естетичний вигляд ми вже поговорили
Давайте поговоримо про кухарів от з
якими проблемами кухарі зіштовхуються на
кухнях тому що от зараз впроваджуються
нові меню Я знаю що дуже багато кухарів
з якими спілкуюсь Особисто я як
представник асоціації говорять мені про
те що ми боїмося навіть цих нових назв
мінестроне
равіолі в чому біда як допомагати
кухарям і пояснювати їм що за цими
насправді страшними назвами ховаються
дуже прості страви якщо правильно
підійти до них як пояснювати А ну для
того щоб пояснювати треба дати
можливість кухарям дати їм час на те щоб
вони думали і чогось навчалися я вам
напевно зараз ее не відкрию Великий
секрет коли розкажу про те як
відбувається як організований День
середньостатистичного українського
кухаря в школі переважно це в великій
кількості це люди передпенсійного або
пенсійного віку які 40 30-40 років свого
життя віддали роботі е дуже потрібні
харчувати наших дітей але які
надзвичайно важко працюють Чому Тому що
вони в більшості встають ще тоді коли в
містах не їздить транспорт прокидаються
вони о 4ртій о 5тй ранку приїжджають на
харчоблоки першим ділом біжать включати
котел по тому що він закипає 3 години Да
йому треба час і після того вони
починають займатися підготовкою
різноманітних
ее ну назвемо це правильно кухарською
мовою напівфабрикатів того з чого вони
потім будуть в подальшому готувати вони
чистять картоплю тонами
вони варять яйця потім їх чистять теж
сотнями вони варять і переносять
тилітрові кастрюлі це переважно жінки
люди Їхня робота більше схожа на каторгу
аніж на аніж на роботу як ми можемо
заставити будь-якого кухаря сказати вам
що я готовий приготувати міністрони йому
для того потрібно як мінімум відкрити
мати час відкрити телефон почитати що
таке
міністрони так а потім розібратися що це
самий звичайний овочевий суп от просто
самий-самий який тільки може бути
звичайний але якщо людина приїхала до
нас Якщо людина приїхала на роботу
відпрацювала там 8 10 12 годин як на
катульзі приїхала додому в неї одне
єдине бажання лягти спати щоб проснутись
завтра знов в 4ртій ранку Тому наше
завдання допомогти їм в цьому і зараз ми
до прикладу в нас салати для того щоби в
нас і так тут дуже шумно на кухні
і
Ми не хочемо ще більше шуму створювати
щоб вам не було дискомфортно в нас
салати роблять в холодному цеху за
стінкою але ми зараз попросимо наших
кухарів щоб вони нам продемонстрували що
таке сучасний технологічний процес А я
би попросив якщо можна Олексій можна ї
трішки на підвищення поставити
овочерізко бо звідси нічого не буде
видно Та і таким чином ми фактично
можемо звільнити руки нашого кухаря і
дати йому час думати головою і думати
вже власне про процес приготування
можливо трішки екс ментувати до чого
закликають нас всі кухарі для того щоб
урізноманітнювати дітям раціон зараз
наші шефи наш Олексій із допомогою інших
шефів продемонструє як нарізається
звичайний салат з овочів овочевий салат
це буде в нас огірочок буде капуста що
ще огірочок
капуста Ну власне нарізаються овочі і це
відбувається
трошки швидше ніж руками як люблять
говорити наші шефи але насправді часові
рамки дуже відрізняються тому що руками
один кухар це робив би Ну годину так
точно якщо йому потрібно було накормити
хоча б половину з вас А якщо всіх вас то
це всі дві години на один салат А так ми
за 45 хвилин зможемо приготувати значно
значно більше чим Ми займаємося зараз Ми
займаємося зараз пропагандою обладнання
Ну не якогось певного бренду я жартую В
нас всі бренди заклеєні значками
асоціації ми нікого не рекламуємо але ми
рекламуємо допомогу вашим кухарям якщо
ви не почнете їм допомагати якщо в них
не буде на кухнях тісто місів А
картоплечисток овочірізок це люди
змушені все це робити руками тому я дуже
вас прошу ви як управлінці які маєте в
руках в управлінні Кошти які ви
розподіляєте ви маєте розуміти що вам
потрібно закупляти такі девайси для
ваших кухарів які будуть допомагати їм
готувати їжу і
отримавши фізичну допомогу коли ми їх
розгрузимо їхню працю руками ми зможемо
тоді працювати з ними на рахунок
технологій ми зможемо тоді заставляти їх
працювати з технологічними картами
новими читати нові норми з харчування а
асоціація в тому числі зараз
розробляє деякі нові аспекти деякі нові
страви нові технологічні карти і це
надзвичайно круто Але питання для кого
ми їх розробляємо їм потріб тібно комусь
читати зараз на даний момент ми бачимо
таку картину Я дуже часто зустрічаюся з
таким до мене
телефонують керівник Департаменту однієї
з областей він каже орес ти знаєш от ми
подивилися ці норми ми не перейдемо на
них з Нового року я кажу чому ну В нас
вартість харчування тепер буде коштувати
в три рази
дорожче Я кажу А А чому ви так А чому ви
так гадаєте Ну от я прийшла я
спілкувалася з своїми кухарями
технологами своїми відділами от Вони
мені дали таку інформацію Я кажу Ну
неправда Ну ми працюємо от ми сьогодні
готуємо там вартість футкос цього меню
складає в межах 20 грн а як так що з
цього випливає Люди які працюють важко в
опозиції ставляться до всього в принципі
що їм пропонують нове тому що в них на
це немає часу вони не мають бажання з
цим працювати Тому я дуже вас прошу
Допоможіть і розгрузіть їх фізично тоді
ми зможемо їм допомагати інтелектуально
та і тоді вся їжа яку вони будуть
готувати буде відповідати тим якіс
показникам які ми ставимо собі як за
критерій на який ми маємо орієнтуватися
орестае Я дуже попрошу вас детальніше
розказати про чотири якісні показники
яким би мала відповідати вся їжа на
кухні Ну я думаю що ми бачимо їх зараз
уже на екрані якщо ми доб'ємося з вами
асортименту
їжі ми добавимо як мінімум 20-30% дітей
які прийдуть до нас в їдальні якщо що ми
доб'ємося актуальності їжі тобто коли ми
говоримо про міністрони коли ми говоримо
про гарні гарні модні назви Коли ми
говоримось про гарний колір цієї їжі
коли ми говоримо не про обвітрені сухі
котлети тому що дитина каже дайте мені
сосиску ми всі школи приходимо вони
кажуть чого ви в нас сосиски забрали
вони забрали сосиски тому що е є в
кухарів така мова цікава в них є свій
сленг І коли ти щось пересмажиш
доприклад шматок м'яса стейка або
котлети вони називають якщо це
пересмажене я бачу в залі тут є теж
кухарі зараз напевно мені кивнуть
головою вони це називають підошва Та ну
тобто коли це вже пересмажив так що його
неможливо споживати це називається
підошва так от Давайте ми не будемо
подавати дітям таку пересмажену їжу
Давайте ми будемо їм давати актуальну
коли ця сьогодні ми будемо з вами
дегустувати котлетки вони будуть от вони
всі зараз там готуються в
пароконвекційні печі кухар який їх
смажить от стоїть збоку важко працює Ну
напевно треба потім йому дати тиждень
відпустки тому що він перепрацювався Він
стоїть і дивиться на це як вони
смажаться і відповідно ці котлети
приготовлені на на на пару з великою
кількістю при великій температурі з
великою кількістю вологи тому вони
будуть смачні і ді дитина точно їх
поміняє на сосиску привабливість ми про
це проговорили і свіжість усі Ви маєте
після сьогоднішнього дня приходити до
ваш ваші шкільній їдальні задавати
питання Коли ви приготували суп коли ви
його видаєте коли ви приготували котлету
коли ви її видаєте але запам'ятайте собі
одну річ якщо у вас на кухні застарілий
технологічний процес Сковороди плити
кастрюлі і і все це що що колись
використовувалося
50-70 років тому то ми не можемо
вимагати від кухарів чогось нового але я
знаю і впевнений в тому що велика
кількість шкіл уже має пароконвекційні
печі уже має мультифункціональні прилади
має дуже багато якісного гарного
обладнання і це дуже тішить але біда в
тому що на плечі цих бідних кухарів які
крім того що мусять думати про те як їм
обробити ці всі продукти потім
приготувати з них дійсно смачні і якісні
страви і швидко видати дітям щоб вони
були свіжі і видати їх одразу А не
видавати протягом цілого дня на їхні
плечі поклали ще одну дуже важку роль як
на мене в минулому році під час того як
розподілялися Кошти які виділилися на
е переобладнання харчоблоків безумовно
Це прекрасно що нарешті держава почала
виділяти великі субвенційні кошти але на
нашу думку на куха на кухаря поклали
дуже важливу але місію яку на яку він не
повинен був виконувати це мали робити
управлінці замість кухаря попрошу Ореста
трошки більше розказати і про весь
взагалі ланцюжок того як відбувалися
процес закупівель так технологічного
обладнання на наш погляд асоціації та як
ми проаналізували власне все ж весь
досвід наш роботи з регіонами
е Я б сказав так ми приїхали в одну з
шкіл таких шкіл є десятки можливо і
сотні Ми приїхали в одну з шкіл побачили
Прекрасну школу новозбудовану з нуля
тобто з фундаменту побудували школу в
сільській місцевості
ее чесно я вражений тобто я фотографував
класи я фотографував гарні посадкові
місця комп'ютеризована є маса різних
девайсів е новий підхід до навчання
інклюзія все чудово дальше ми зайшли в
харчоблок харчоблок шикарний саме
головне великий великий такий на
квадратів 250
м я ходжу по цьому харчоблоку Я не можу
зрозуміти
ее де тут Що тобто в нас величезний
гарячий цех такий як в тому харчоблоці
десь такий як дві ці сцени ми
спускаємося в підвал там ще приміщення
ми заходимо е в на на на інший поверх в
двох в двох рівнях Кухня ми нарахували
13 приміщень різноманітних е різні цехи
зберігання одного продукту зберігання
другого продукту В кінцевому результаті
Я загадав питання директ Я розумію по
школі що тут більше ніж там 200 дітей не
вчиться в цій школі невеличка сільська
школа навчається там 80
дітей Оце харчоблок я кажу а напевно
працює у вас аж один кухар він каже да
Ну от тепер собі задайтесь питанням А як
цей кухар в якого за 70 м Хар холодиль
камери має дотриматись норм хасп має
їздити на роликах та йому треба видати
ролики для того щоб він їздив туди назад
туди назад чому так відбувається на наш
погляд через відсутність експертного
середовища цю кухню проектували проектні
організації проектна організація я вам
надзвичайно Дякую кухарі що в нас так
тихо стало проектні організація взяла
типовий проект школи зробила ctrlc ctrl
V скопіювала його і ці проекти ці ну
Вони тепер називаються проекти
повторного використання вони тиражуються
постійно постійно постійно І нічого в
принципі не змінюється і
е немає такого унікального підходу немає
експертного середовища який би якісно
проектував е
технологію я не можу собі уявити жодної
в принципі лікарні Де би не були
залучені лікарі до проектування лікарні
Ну от не можу уявити собі як ми можемо
організувати де в нас буде операційна
кокудой в нас буде ліфт де в нас буде
прийомне відділення якщо ми не маємо
лікаря ми можемо таке зробити це може
зробити будівель будівельна організація
проектно-будівельна організація яка
робить проектно-кошросну документацію Ні
не може а чому ми можемо тоді уявити
якщо ми дома зранку смажимо собі яйце ми
вважаємо що ми знаємо як організувати
харчування для 100-2 ч 15тисячі дітей
нам обов'язково перед тим як щось
починати робити Нам потрібно інформацію
від професійних людей технологів
асоціацій різноманітних комерційних
структур які займаються
технологію приготування їжі і так дальше
тому як ми бачимо ми зараз будемо трішки
критикувати бо асоціація не тільки про
про добре асоціація про реальність в
минулому році безпрецедентна сума
субвенції виділена Ми всім завжди
Дякуємо ськіюклін за такі великі кошти і
за те добре що що ми могли зроби що ви
могли зробити за ці кошти але я попрошу
вивести нам на екран презентацію Але
якщо
ми якщо ми проаналізуємо що ми зробили з
цими коштами відбулося це приблизно
так не у всіх але в багатьох
Міністерство виділяє кошти розподіляє їх
по обласних адміністраціях обласнії
адміністрації розприділяють їх згідно
умов субвенції Між тими отг тими школами
які мають які підпадають по усіх
критеріях і надають ці кошти в різному
обсязі комусь 100 000 комусь 700 комусь
500 комусь мільйон ці кошти повідомляють
директора він надає ну проект що він
хоче зробити тобто перелік якогось
певного обладнання А за інформацією про
це Обладнання дуже дуже і дуже часто
вони зверталися до кухарів це
інформація правдива і всі це знають і
мені кивають люди головами і Всі
розуміють що так це відбулося Чому Тому
що в облдержадміністрації в відділах
освіти департаменті освіти в відділах
освіти на місцях немає жодної людини яка
би володіла інформацію про те як має
бути організований технологічний процес
через те дуже часто закупили но класне
обладнання але воно ніяк не покращило
технологічні
технології не змінило та замінили
кастрлю на кастрлю плиту на плиту тому
для того є асоціація для того є зараз ро
в розробці сайт на якому дуже багато
буде інформації і в кожному регіоні в
кожній області Я впевнений що є
шивкухарі і технологи які можуть вам
допомогти звертайтесь до них за
консультаціями усі проекти усі проекти є
такими які маю містять в собі розділ
технології Я тех тобто звертайтесь за
технологією до професіоналів до проекту
кошторисної документації до проектантів
за технологією до технологів та Але для
того щоби дійсно правильно
імплементувати нам ті технології які
мали мають стояти саме у вашій школі і
зрозуміти і зрозуміти який тип
організації Ось цього сучасного
технологічного процесу вам потрібен
треба розібратися взагалі які
типи харчування є в світі
щоби ви мали собі розуміння що це може
бути Кухня просто в школі або ж
Кухня опорна Кухня від якої потім будуть
розвозити харчування орес я попрошу вас
трошки детальніше розказати про цей кейс
тому що ви більш компетентні в
цьому у всьому світі існує
всього-навсього два типи організації
харчування дітей в школах Це або ми
отримуємо сировину прямо в школу готуємо
з сирої картоп моркви м'яса молока ми
готуємо повністю все з нуля тоді в нас є
заготівальні процеси в нас є процеси
теплової обробки є процеси видачі або
варіант номер два те про що сьогодні
анонсував пан міністр пан шкарлет про те
що Маріуполь інші міста Київ уже працює
над самою сучасною технологію це є
приготування їжі централізовано
охолодження її до стану пс3 тобто
зупинка приготування так звана Коли ми
можемо перемістити гарячий продукт в
апарат шокового охолодження і доставка
цього продукта охолод го до школи тоді в
школі в нас відбувається тільки розігрів
їжі і видача її дітям Ну і звичайно
посудомийний процес який ну з яким
потрібно помити помити за дітьми
розберемо зараз цих два кейса але в
Україні ми тому що ми вивчаємо досвід до
прикладу зараз паралельно з Україною
реформу харчування проводить
Великобританія ми вивчаємо їх досвід їх
кейс але ми робимо і свої кроки в нас
добавиться ще третій тип про який я
зараз розкажу якщо ми готуємо їжу в
школі все зрозуміло класичне
приготування їжі але ми маємо
забезпечити сучасні технологічні процеси
бажано та тобто не купляти кастрюлі і і
там плити А купляти високотехнологічні
речі якщо ми готуємо централізовано в
чому наша основна вимога Вигода Як для
мене в першу чергу це є безпека Чому
Тому що проконтролювати одне виробництво
є набагато простіше вам управлінцям аніж
приготувати до прикладу 10 15 або 20
відрядити кожного наглядача в кожен
такий заклад неможливо коли ми говоримо
про до прикладу Київ і їхній
проект фабрики кухні в Дніпровському
районі ми говоримо про 10 000 порцій
щоденної їжі яка ця фабрика буде
готувати і доставляти її на 13 шкіл
великих 13 шкіл Тобто це є надзвичайно
Передова технологія Чому Тому що ми
контролюємо якість ми економимо в
значній мірі ресурс надзвичайно його
економимо тому що приготувати в одному
місці значно економніше аніж Готувати
їжу в кожному в кожній школі
безпосередньо І звісно в нас є зменшення
витрат е людського ресурсу тому що
кількість кухарів зменшується в рази є
регіони Де це є виключно економія
ресурсу є виключно питання фінансове але
є регіони де е економія людського
ресурсу є питання не фінансове а
безпекове тому що цих кухарів не
вистачає до прикладу такі як міста
Західної України Мабуть або Одеса тому
що коли починається курортній сезон коли
починаються відпу відпускні сезони
кухарів не найдеш ні за які кошти тому
що їх просто немає вони відсутні так
тобто якщо ми говоримо не про сільську
місцевість А про великі міста кухарів
немає тобто до прикладу в Львівських
ресторанах як представник асоціації
громадського харчування я вам розкажу що
в літній сезон приблизна нехватка
кухарів біля 30% є в ресторанах міста
Львова їх немає вони в Одесі в Буковелі
в Польщі Чехії ще десь потім вони
звичайно повертаються але влітку їх
немає то тому питання економії ресурсів
людських це теж дуже дуже і дуже важливо
оресте Я вас переб'ю На хвилинку Поки ви
розповідали Я вже дізналася в хлопців в
нас уже готові перші страви в нас
пройшло фактично 25 хвилин в нас вже
готовий кус-кус готова більшість котлет
і також готові обидва салати і ми зараз
уже їх будемо потихеньку переносити на
зони видачі для того щоби накопичувати
їжу щоб вам потім швидко це все видати
на обід ми показово вам струєм що ми її
готуємо тут і видаємо Але для того щоб
офіціанти не сталось ніякої
непередбаченої обставини на сходах їх з
вашого дозволу будуть видавати через ну
другий вихід для того щоб їх доставити
продукти безпечно але як їх видають ви
можете усі за цим слідкувати а і те що я
анонсував третій тип який в принципі
дуже рідко Ну майже ніде я не зустрічав
щоб його використовували але в Україні
ми з цим працюємо і це вже це вже працює
в деяких об'єднаних громадах Це
приготування їжі
не на фабриці кухні і не приготування
їжі в школі а все ж таки сюдою ви їдете
обережно тільки
прекрасно перші салати вже йдуть на
лінію роздачі будуть на вас чекати ящо
якщо ми говоримо про цей третій тип це є
так званий кущовий тип коли одна Школа
може годувати дві-три сусідні школи і це
є вирішення дуже глобальне питання
вашого ваших обптимізації тому що якщо
ми говоримо про сільську місцевість В
нас дуже часто
школи мають Е 50 70 100 діток 150 діток
і 20 і 15 немає сенсу там тримати
харчоблок але знов ж таки якщо ми не
забезпечимо там гарячого харчування діти
будуть харчуватися нездорово а чому не
може одна школа готувати їжу і в
сусідній в своїй громаді в сусідній
школі доставляти для того нам потрібно
потужності розрахувати і зробити
правильний технологічний проект цієї
кухні врахувати ці потреби що вона має
годувати ще дві-три сусідні
всього-навсього одна машина термобокси
які можуть це доставляти кожну громаду
яка буде бажати працювати в такому
передовому напрямку ми готові
консультувати давати інформацію
допомагати як Таня каже за ручку
проводити по шляху цієї реформи Ну от
власне Ми зараз і будемо переходити до
того що ми хочемо зробити лейтмотивом
власне нашого посилу до вас це проектний
підхід так званий коли ви маєте
підходити до переоснащення ваших
харчоблоків комплексно І починати Це це
все з аудиту технологічного аудиту для
того аби зрозуміти які потужності наразі
є у вашій школі тому що комусь Їх
потрібно тільки трошки підсилити комусь
зробити з нуля і звичайна проектна
організація вам не зможе допомогти
прорахувати яке Вам потрібно обладнання
для цього потрібно пройти певний
опитувальник
від знову ж таки анонсую від наших
менеджерів нашої асоціації які до
поможуть вам потім зробити правильний
технологічний проект Я хочу звернути
вашу увагу що у всіх роздаткових
матеріалах які вам видали є окрема
брошура асоціації громадського
харчування в якій є е такий фактично
чек-лист або ж план дій що потрібно
робити аби пройти від самого початку цей
шлях коли у вас ще нічого немає але дуже
хочеться і є величезне бажання там є 12
кроків і Їх потрібно проходити поступово
на екран ми вивели ці 12 кроків
об'єднали в такі чотири великі блоки
перший блок - це проектування сюди
входить власне аудит і проектування
другий блок - це ремонтні роботи Але для
того щоб провести правильні ремонтні
роботи теж потрібно зробити аудит тому
що дуже часто в школах
проводка
каналізація ще 50-х 60 років і от
сучасне технологічне обладнання
підключити насправді ну майже нереально
і якщо ви наприклад вже зробите проект
закупите обладнання але не врахуєте цей
момент воно потім буде стояти у вас в
коридорах ми з цим насправді дуже часто
зіштовхуємося коли приїздимо з ористом в
школи і бачимо як новесеньке обладнання
стоїть запаковане По півроку в коридорах
довкола нього бігають діти а все Чому
Тому що не прорахували ось ці критичні
Точ які треба прорахувати ще на проекті
на етапі
проектування наступний такий великий
етап - це власне встановлення обладнання
це вже коли всі етапи з тендерами
відбулися школа ваш заклад освітній вже
захистив свій проект на етапі розподілу
фінансування уже відбулися всі тендери і
вам обладнання поступило його потрібно
правильно підключити для цього теж
потрібні правильні підібрати правильну
технічну службу асоціація може
консультувати вас на всіх етапах просто
телефонуйте нам пишіть і ми будемо вам
допомагати і фактично вести за ручку Ну
і власне останній етап про який я
попрошу більше розказати Ореста - це е
заключний етап для того щоби запрацювала
ваша Кухня повноцінно це навчання
персоналу яким чином ми як асоціація
зможемо це забезпечити попрошу розказати
Трішки більше Ореста
раз раз чудово е я би повернувся ще до
питання навіть проектування Я особисто є
прихильник того ви можете розділяти мою
позицію або ні а прихильник того що
краще ми будемо робити менше Але будемо
робити з якісним видимим результатом а
аніж ми будемо робити дуже багато е але
цього результату ми не отримаємо е Мене
щиро тішить Коли я приїжджаю і в нас в
Україні вже є сотні шкіл коли ти заходиш
від входу дитини в харчоблок до входу
продуктів на харчоблок є є європейський
сучасний класний підхід Тобто ми можемо
сказати про те
що три роки тому ми організовували
поїздку
для 20 міських голів різних куточків
України від Закарпаття до Донецької
області в Німеччину і ми захоплено
Їздили по німецьких містах школах і
фотографували знімали на камеру їхні
харчоблоки і
недавно Дуже дякую пані Віті приїжджала
до нас в гості в Києві разом з усіма
представниками Полтавської області і так
само Полтавська область уже захоплено
фотографувала ті харчоблоки і Ці школи
які уже вдалося реалізувати в Києві Це
чудово так Тобто ми маємо зараз от на
камеру виведений один з тих харчоблоків
Тобто це є при приготування їжі
мініатюрна сучасна високотехнологічна
кухня з гарних стандартах в гарній
гарній білій плиточці і
а дуже гарна
естетична зона приймання їжі для того
щоби цього добитися Я вважаю що без
комплексного тере проектного проходу
підходу Ми не можемо цього зробити Ми не
можемо просто купити обладнання і
поставити його чекати коли ми зробимо
ремонт тому що має бути послідовність
цього всього тому якщо повернутися до
попереднього слайду про проектний підхід
і все що йде після нього то першим в
всьому має бути проект цей проект має
складатися з технічного завдання на
проектування в основі якого має лежати
технологія тоді ми цю технологію
описуємо в технічне завдання на
проектування і проектанти для нас
проектують класну гарну кухню отримавши
цю кошторисну документа проектну
кошторисну документацію Вона може бути 3
млн 2 млн 5 млн в залежності від того
яка це школа який це харчоблок ми по
мірі фінансування наповнюємо його
реалізовуємо його ча частинами але ми
йдемо по завіреному плану тому що дійсно
як це
Сльози на очі навертаються коли ти
приїжджаєш в школу і бачиш обладнання
яке закуплене рік тому А яке стоїть яке
стоїть в коробка і його не можуть
підключити через те що там електромережа
не підходить немає виводів Немає
вентиляції ще якісь ще якісь питання
тому проект в першу чергу після проекту
закупівля облад ремонтні роботи після
ремонтних робіт закупівля обладнання і
навчання персонала це є найважливіше
тому що якщо ви будете закуповувати
виключно обладнання без навчання проек
пусконалагоджувальних робіт без навчання
персоналу і адаптації цього персоналу до
нового те логічного обладнання нічого з
того не буде тобто тут є представники Я
надіюся що на панелі питання відповіді
ми зможемо задавати питання про те як
забезпечити в prozoro закупівлю а
якісного
б такого яке нам нададуть не тільки
залізяку яку поставити і і от вона
просто стоїть а для того щоб цей
постачальник цих товарів і послуг
надавав якісне навчання і адаптацію цих
працівників і слава богу в Україні вже є
свідомий бізнес який готовий це робити
який це робить і який підтримує цих ці
ці кухні як комерційні от ми сьогодні
знаходимося в прекрасному комерційному
закладі чим відрізняється кухня в цьому
закладі і сервісне її технічне і
технологічне обслуговування від такої ж
кухні в держави в державному закладі не
має бути ніякої різниці Тобто ми маємо
купляти послугу якісно а не а а не
просто кусок залізяки тому десь
приблизно так оресте ми трошки вже з
вами відійшли в теорію давайте вертатися
до кухні от хлопці зараз мені сказали
буквально хвилинку тому що ми зараз
смажити останню партію котлет так і ми
традиційно хочемо запросити
бажаючих або ж я можу запропонувати
наприклад нашому пану ведучому допомогти
нам с про те що треба відробляти гонорар
якщо не помиляють від вас Тобто ми тоді
я сьогодні працюю на добровільних
засадах то волонтер так я і ми
волонтерських тому з задоволенням
Головне щоб пане Орест щоб після того як
я там посмажу котлети Я не соромився їх
це буде чудово одягайтеся Так
одягаємся слухайте маска маска я
потримаю ва мікрофон Так
дякую Так якщо ви думаєте що я це роблю
кожного дня ви
помиляєтесь А скільки ми котлет будемо
смажувати я про котлети маю на увазіці
скільки котлет 200 200
котлет 240 котлет Тобто ми ускладнюємо
задачу я ящо одна котлета коштує скільки
приблизно собівартість ко 10 гр 8 грнь а
собівартість думаю в межах десь 4 гр 4
гр 240 на 4 це тобто 800 960 грн я б я б
не про це думав я б думав про те
наскільки Ми затримаємося сьогодні Якщо
ви будете смажити 240 котлет Я думаю ми
до до вечора тут будемо ні я думаю що що
ми виконаємо наше зобов'язання і зробимо
це за 8 хвилин прекрасно супер підплиски
всіх присутнік
звичайно знаєте як кажуть в Одесі
Одеський дворик з вікна мама рочить
всёма диі домой Мама я замрз Нет ты
хочешь
кушать даю вам ще рукавички Ми дійсно
показово для вас для чого ми це робимо
для того щоб ви звернули увагу на те що
ваші кухарі можуть працювати в абсолютно
інших умовах і більше скажу для цього не
потрібно чогось надзвичайного нам
виключно потрібні такі девайси які
можуть робити
процеси
Легше Я думаю що багато для кого до
прикладу слово пароконвекційна піч стало
новиною 5 років роки тому назад але я
вам скажу що я був на
одному музе в одному з музеїв де стоїть
параконвекційна піч вона звічно не така
сучасна там з тачскрін екранами Але який
45 років тобто пароконвекційними печами
приготуваннями на пару в світі в Європі
уже користується більше 40 років а ми
тільки ці
технології деколи тільки дізнаємося тому
для для нас дуже важливо передавати цю
інформацію вам і щоб Ви щоб ви з ци
працювали оресте Валерій вже готовий
повністю окіпірований як має бути і вже
підходить до нашого пароконвектомату
давайте Я
відійду Олексій я попрошу мікрофон біля
вас щоби був да
Добрий день всім зараз будемо готувати
приблизно 200 котлет да на нашому
дисплеї ми бачимо
піктограми курка м'ясо і овочі тобто у
нас котлети курячі натискаємо курку
тобто все інтуїтивно курочка намальована
котлетка намальована ми бачимо все що
можемо зробити курки починаючи з курки А
я попрошу камеру виведіть будь ласка на
екранм камебираємо страви в паніромці
крутика на пару смаження на патеня
страви в паніровці натискаємо як в
телефоні просто Да натисну оце як
фактично екран смартфону на якому чисто
інтуїтивно можна обрати
собі ж 78 натискаєм і і робимо 78° ну
80 давайте 80 у нас котлети що ми бачимо
на екрані у нас іде попередній розігрів
да тобто тим самим ми можемо підготувати
наші котлети буде звуковий сигнал ми це
все загружаємо в робочу камеру ставим
цей термощубгу от і йдемо займатися
своїми
справами ці котлети будуть приготовлені
доведені до температури 70 і тим самим
Ми також можемо зняти хаспротокол
що ця партія котлет була дійсно доведена
до
правильно розумію потрібно взяти є якись
має бути якийсь журнал Де за дивіться я
пропоную так щоб ви брали журнал і я
напевно я думаю всі ви знаєте що кожне
приготування нам треба
занотувати кожну кожне наше приготування
занотувати температурні режими для того
щоб дотриматись усіх норм і правил
звісно на наших кухнях таке ніхто не
робить робить тоді коли приїжджає
держпротспоживслужба тобто за місяць або
за два або за півроку швидесенько стають
всі заповнюють але ми жартували і
звичайно записувати Нічого ми не будемо
журнали в принципі в сучасному світі уже
ніхто не користується усе приготування
що відбувається в камері фіксується
через датчики і залишається в
електронних хаспротоколах тобто що таке
хаспротокол це інформація про те що
відбувалося з продуктом окрім того Е це
не дає можливості кухарям помилятися
тому що якщо ми уявимо собі от Ми щойно
посмажили 700 котлет останню партію 240
дозавантажуємо Уявіть собі якщо би
стояло два або три кухаря які смажать їх
на пательнях в когось задзвонив телефон
хтось кудись відволікся перегорнув
котлетку не перегорнув якщо не
перегорнув вона не досмажилась не
досмажилась в нас є ризик отруєння а
приготування в пароконвекційні печі або
якогось такого ро роду обладнання
відбувається через щуб ми виставили
температурку колись ще в цьому програмі
що там нам потрібно 80 до прикладу п
градусі в цій котлеті і ми отримуємо ю
партію завжди при температурі 85°. плюс
ця інформація акумулюється ви її можете
отримувати на свої робочі комп'ютери як
управлінці її може отримувати
держпроцпоживслужба її може отримувати
абсолютно будь-хто навіть офіс
президента якщо це бажає тому сучасні
технології дозволяють навіть такі речі
робити До речі всюди в світі в Європі
електронні хазпротоколи
є абсолютним доказом в суді до прикладу
якщо відбулося отруєння ми знімаємо
хазпротокол з всь всіх одиниць
обладнання і ми бачимо Що ніде не було
помилки в температурних режимах і
приготуванні плюс Ми зняли усі проби з
кухні в нас немає ніде жодних бактерій
вірусів Відповідно ми гарантуємо собі що
отруєння відбулося не у нас Тобто Це є
доказ в суді оресте Валерій вже
справився дивіться я вже тільки що за
допомогою свого
колеги проасистував йому проасистував
йому подачу е всіх котлет в
безпосередньо в шафу тут досить все
просто панелька звичайна є навіть
простіша ніж мобільному телефоні обираєш
курку обираєш е оцим от ричажком курку в
паніровці виставляєш цим же самим
ричажком температурний режим вставляєш
щуб для того щоб бути переконаним що він
котлета буде приготовлена саме до тієї
кондиції яку ми собі поставили там є ее
кілька режимів якому для приготування
м'яса в принципі кругом і є отакий щуб
який буде використаний вже після того як
котлети будуть забрані з безпосередньо з
шафи на цьому щупі якщо я не помиляюсь
буде показано чи вона готова чи не
готова традиційно і відповідно Після
цього я вношу точніше кухар вносить це
знову ж таки в журнал тим самим
відбувається все те що вище вам озвучив
Орест так До речі по часу по часу в нас
залишилося 2 хвилини а Подивіться на на
екрані в вас знате Це останнє
екрані На екрані Нам потрібно ще 14
хвилин воно скориговує він
скориговується від ми тільки завантажили
потім скоригує я думаю що через 7 хвилин
вони будуть готові ви нас пробачите що
ми затрималися на 5 хвилин а ми довго
вдягалися просто Да ми хочемо ще сказати
що в нас є дві страви які тут не
готувалися тобто в нас є приготовлені
тут котлети в нас є приготовлений плов в
нас є приготовлений кус-кус болгур на
гарнір і в нас є дві страви які є не не
готовлені тут на кухні які потребували
приготування зранку для того щоб їх
охолодити Тобто це є шкільна запіканка Я
думаю що ви будете всі тішитись від того
що будете згадувати сьогодні смак
дитинства Ось вона і компот Тобто Це ті
речі які треба було зготувати зраночку
охолодити і тримати в холодильнику я
дуже вам дякую Валерій А тобто я можу
переодягатися без мене вже діста може А
можете залишатися Якщо вам комфортно А
мені тут комфортно ви єте красно
рухаємось дальше до претаі я дуже
попрошу нашу технічну службу вивести нам
на екран презентацію Ми хочемо показати
як виглядає електронний хаз протокол про
який щойно говорив Орест це не журнал це
графік або ж таблиця в якій фіксуються
всі відкриття камери пароконвектомату і
такі хаспротоколи можна брати майже з
будь-яких сучасних технологічних одиниць
обладнання і більшість виробників Це
передбачують ось переходимо далі
давайте трошки поговоримо про економію
орес тому що це те що найбільше хвилює
управлінців напевно як зекономити кошти
І чи взагалі використання такого
обладнання є економічно
доцільним мене дуже радує Коли я
приїжджаю в громади і Спілкуючись з
міськими головами які тут теж присутні
вони мені розповідають яким чином вони
наповнюють свої бюджети ну після реформи
децентралізації ми усі стали трішки
підприємцями трішки бізнесменами Та вони
боряться за пдпо вони боряться за бізнес
який присутній в їхніх громадах і для
мене для мене це такий крок дуже далеко
це такий квантовий просто стрибок в
майбутнє і Але якщо ми настільки
боремося за отримання е ресурсів давайте
також подумаємо про їхню нерозтрату на
марно якщо ми говоримо про економії
ресурсів до прикладу приготування
котлет ми зараз розберемо кейс це
виглядає приблизно так якщо взяти 700
котлет не 700 250 одну партію котлет
якщо їх Посмажити на сковорідках
розставити їх просто по пательнях і 250
котлет смажити на сковорідках на Це при
на це піде приблизно дві години одному
кухарю і він споживе на цих сковорідки
якщо кожна комфорка має по 3,5 кВт або
велика Сковорода має 12 кВт ми приблизно
споживемо там в межах 25 тире 30 кВт
електроенергії для приготування кожен
раз після приготування машина виводить
скільки спожила вона електроенергії
робить вона це в межах 10 хвилин і
споживає електроенергії десь в межах 2,5
кВт тобто 25 тире 2,5 якщо в принципі Ну
що таке кіловатти Ну 20 кВт там
зекономили там чи 22 кВт зекономили Але
якщо ми ці 22 кв помножимо
на 15 000 шкіл в Україні і помножимо це
на 3 грн вартість електроенергії ми
отримуємо 720 000 грн з однієї партії
котлет на всю нашу велику державу якщо
таких партій котлет так як ми сьогодні
готували їх буде три цю суму можна
помножити втричі Та ж сама Та ж сама річ
відбувається до прикладу з водою коли ми
приходимо на застарілі застарілі
харчоблоки які не обладнані посудомийним
обладнанням і ми бачимо коли відкриті
просто крани і витікає
безнеконтрольована водичка да вода Ця
вода підігрівається бойлерами в холодній
воді її ніхто не миє Цю воду
підігрівають а вона просто безконтрольно
витікає з цих кранів Це катастрофа це як
якщо би знаєте ми дуже часто боремося за
вартість
фудкост їжі так званий вартість їжі яку
ми кладемо в тарілку але якщо би ви
порахували скільки коштує приготувати цю
їжу подекоди це більше аніж коштує сама
безпосередньо ця їжа тому Про це
потрібно думати ми усі уже е є
частинками своїх громад ми усі сплачуємо
ПДФО в свої громади і ми усі е можемо
робити наші громади багатшими давайте
зверне бувально кілька кілька слів хочу
сказати Поки ви це все слухали Я ще
більше дізнався про цей апарат
виявляється тут можна не просто
поставити котлети викласти режим і
розуміти що всі 240 котлет будуть
прожарені однаково з мінімальною
кількістю
олії однаково
корисні тут ще можна записати як вони
жарилися внести це в меню і запам'ятати
більше того Якщо ця штука підключена до
інтернету то технолог одразу отримує на
руки все те що відбувалося як на мене це
чудо як на мене це чудо крано Це чудово
Скажіть будь ласка є в залі хтось хто за
10 хвилин готував 240 котлет якщо можна
підніміть руку будь ласка вверх що нема
нікого Я
готував Орест якщо дивитися на таймінг
ми буквально трішечки вийшли за
анонсований час десь плюс-мінус в 55
хвилин ми вклалися в хлопців вже майже
все готово Наскільки я розумію давай
давай ми будемо рухатися тепер в сторону
мультипрофільного харчування я дуже би
хотів про це поговоритимо це найбільш
найбільшим таким протиріччям З ким З чим
я зіштовхаюся коли ми спілкуємося з
керівниками відділів освіти це про
створення в Україні асортименту їжі всі
цього цураються всі кажуть Ой чекайте
Давайте ми розберемося тут просто з їжею
якісною а тоді будемо йти В асортимент
Ми сьогодні нстрували для вас процеси
приготування котлет а друга основна
страва в нас готувалася в іншій машині
там до речі давайте подивимося що
готується тут я наскільки як мені тільки
що підказали тут готується плов ви могли
би відкрити чи чи зараз його не можна
робити зараз кидається тиск дві хвилини
супер так відкриваємо
давайте і Відповідно
ми отримали тут котлети тут ло А давайте
тепер собі просто уявимо що вас тут не
700 людей немає в Україні жодної школи
де би на перерві приходило 700 дітей за
один раз поїсти Так це ми тут займаємося
цирковою виставою так такого не існує
тобто на перерві максимум їсть 150-200
діточок в школі Так але уявимо собі що
нам не потрібно би було готувати 700
котлет в тій самій камері Ми би одне
завантаження за 10 хвилин могли зробили
могли зробити котлетки інше завантаження
могли би зробити шніцеля або риби на
пару або ще чогось нам не СК маючи
нормальні технології на кухні нам не не
складає ніякої проблеми зробити для
дітей асортимент чим більше ви зробите
для них вибору тим лояльніші вони будуть
до вас і до того і до цієї їдальні і до
відповідно с здорового споживання їжі
оресте я думаю що у всіх логічно виникло
питання як можна в одній камері пару
конвектомату готувати і м'ясо і рибу
одночасно е Шкода що немає зараз я не
бачу представників держпроспоживслужби в
нас недавно були про це баталії весь
світ уже так готує і в нас це також
дозволено Тобто ми можемо якщо в нас
невеличка школа І в нас от стоїть
пароконвектомат ми можемо завантажити
рибні котлети і можемо завантажити в цю
саму камеру курячий шніцель до прикладу
і одночасно її готувати Чому Тому що в
камері змінюється пар кожну хвилину
декілька раз запахи не встигають
перемішатися між між продуктами для того
щоб просто нам з одного продукту не
капав жир на інший для того ставиться на
один про ну на один рівень гастроємність
яка не дає можливості просто скапувати
на продукт і тим таким самим чином ми
можемо готувати в одній камері різні
продукти це вже в принципі знаєте ми так
заходимо дуже глибоко в технологічні
процеси які Напевно що вам не потрібні
як управлінцям але розуміння того що
готувати в асортименті в Великих об'ємах
і свіжу їжу Можливо я думаю що ми вам
продемонстрували Я повинен вам сказати
що плов пахне просто і на вигляд і
на аромат фантастичний До речі спробую
обов'язково моїти практично готові
залишилась буквально одна хвилина я вам
повинен сказати що візуально вам там не
видно мені тут краще видно візуально
котлети в
Верхньому деці і на нижній деці Вони
приблизно однакові тобто немає ніяких
різниць Я не знаю чи вам видно звідси
Але якщо ми подивимося на колір цих
котлет вони золотисті так ну тобто вони
такого кольору якого ну їх не страшно
їсти так тому Ну я думаю що ви зараз
будете всі дегустувати ви ще
переконаєтесь в тому що усі страви
залишили всю во вологу в собі тобто ми
цю вологу не втратили через через те що
ми отримали залишили цю вологу вони
відповідно сочні і смачні більше того
овочі які у вас там приготовані вони
приготовані на пару котлети готові друзі
в принципі під оплиски можна їх
діставати Вибачте але це не Оплески це
якісь знущання піддоплески будь
[оплески]
ласка я попрошу наших техніків Вивести
на екран як вивантажують плов крупним
планом якщо можна щоб всі це бачили Оце
мені
подобається та буквально кілька хвилин і
будемо переходити до того чого напевно
всі чекали вже цілу годину саме власне
обіду і де кожен з вас зможе обрати так
само як ми хочемо щоби наші діти мали
змогу обирати собі що вони хочуть їсти а
не їсти те що їм пропонують Тобто ви
зараз зможете прийти і замовити собі
одну з тих основ кі
йно для нас приготували наші кухарі але
я рекомендую Ми готували таким доволі
серйозним запасом якщо дійсно
розібратись на шкільні порції Ми
приготували не 700 порцій не на 700
людей Ми приготували десь приблизно на
100 людей Ви можете набирати собі не
вибирати а брати всього по всього що ви
бачите для того щоб все продегустувати
все попробувати звичайно естетика
говорить про те що їжу викидувати не
можна просіть Нехай вам накидують
потрішечки але всього для того щоб ви
могли спробувати хай хай пробачить мене
Євген Клопотенко але після того як я
готував разом з колегою ці котлети Вони
тепер називаються котлета Одеська
прекрасноплески якщо можна
перед тим як ми будемо іти їсти і буде
найприємніша частина нашого
сьогоднішнього дня Я би дуже хотів щоби
ми поаплодували нашим кухарям окремо
тому що вони працювали
важко звичайно повинен вам сказати там
не так жарко як на будь-якій іншій кухні
але попри те 45 хвилин в такому режимі з
такими на таким напруженням перед вашими
очима Це дійсно заслуговує оплисків але
справжніх оплисків не оплисків людей які
хочуть їсти А тих що вже
поїли Ну і запрошуємо вас до обіду зараз
на ваші екрани ми виведемо qr-коди по
яким ви можете шукати нашу асоціацію в
соцмережах заходити на наш сайт як
мінімум добавляйтесь Підписуйтесь як
тепер модно казати Ставте лайки і
підписуйтесь друзі буквальновертайтеся
до нас за консультаці буквально одну
секундочку я хочу нагадати вам що після
обіду рівно за годину вас чекає
завершальна панель де будуть
розглядатися питання які ви задавали до
спікерів спікери на них будуть
відповідати тому будь ласка не
затримуйтеся без 10 без
10 чотири три точніше три Ми вас чекаємо
тут будь ласка всім
смачного щоб не затягувати пописати цей
меморандум з вами Як це зробити швидше
а а то
ми
Друзі Ну що
ж мені приємно що в залі залишилась
цільова аудиторія яка принаймні більш
ніж переконаний задавала питання у вас
багато відповідно питань багато а часу у
нас час в нас обмежений тому не буду
втрачати його на водичку і перейдемо
безпосередньо до суті завершальна панель
заключається в тому що ви зможете почути
відповіді на свої питання для цього У
нас є експерти наші спікери які зараз
з'являться на сцену під ваші Оплески
а
Дякую відчувається поїли гарний
настрій перед тим як ми почнемо В мене
питання Скажіть будь ласка кому
сподобалась
котлета дякую мені приємно якщо не дай
Бог щось в житті піде не так Я знаю куди
мене направитись а салат з
капустою салат з морквою і яблуками
перше сподобалось не не сподобалось
чому немає ску немає смаку бо немає
солі ми зараз зателефонуємо пану ляшку
він вам пояснить що 5 г максимум а не 13
а Скажіть будь ласка напій без
цукру підійде так як ви вважаєте Діти
відмовляться від солодких газованих
напоїв як не
відмовляться А якщо вести
адміністративні
ресурси
запіканка Супер А мені не дісталося я
вам заздрюв добре друзі наразі Давайте
так як ви оцінюєте меню яке ви
спробували по п'ятибальній от Хто
готовий поставити три
бали раз у нас ведеться відеозйомка я
нагадую але дякую за щирість чотири бали
Ну і пть
хлопці кухарі пть балів вам і вам ці
Оплески Ну що ж Ми продовжуємо Я
запрошую на сцену наших
спікерів заступниця міністра освіти і
науки України
Любомира начальник управління
конкурентної політики Міністерство
Економіки України білянський
Олександр
керівник експертної групи у сфері
безпечності харчових продуктів здоров'я
та благополучя тварин директорату
державної політики у сфері санітарних та
фітосанітарних заходів щирова
Наталія державний уповноважений
антимонопольного комітету Нечитайло
Ольга друзі У нас ще планується один
спікер це голова державної служби
України з питань безпечності харчових
продуктів захисту споживачів магалецька
Владислава але на жаль вона трошки
затримується тож ми будемо її чекати і в
процесі вона до нас доєднається
друзі продовжуємо заступник голови
Полтавської обласної державної
адміністрації лунін
Дмитро як мені в перерві зробили
зауваження Я абсолютно нерівнодушно
ставлюся до Полтавської області Ну
подобається мені там
Ну але в Одесі подобається більше
державний експерт директорату
громадського здоров'я Скапа
Тетяна виконуючий обов'язків директора
професійнії закупівлі адаманов
Едем а також Я запрошую на сцену
модераторів
це Орест степаняк та Леся марталішвілі
під Ваші опласкі
[оплески]
друзі
Дуже дякуємо уім хто знайшов собі сили
після обіду повернутися до роботи тому
що в принципі це консистенція всього
сьогоднішнього заходу Ми хотіли б щоб ви
поїхали додому з повним розумінням того
що у вас є потрібний багаж знань і що ви
можете працювати спокійно
знаючи що ви все робите правильно тому
ми зористом беремо на себе скажемо так
організаційну частину цього цієї панелі
будемо задавати запитання за
належністю кому вони адресуються але я
одразу хочу сказати що більшість
запитань які сьогодні прозвучать
насправді повинні озвучуватися на
місцевому рівні Ну будемо пробувати
знайти відповіді на такі складні
запитання колегіально Тому що перед вами
люди з досвідом з розумінням своєї
справи
оресте можете розпочати першим давайте
щоб чоловік розпочав тішимося з того що
ви залишилися І що вам цікаво отримати
відповіді на всі питання ви бачите яку
яку
прошу Так так за одну хвильку ми
тішимося що така велика кількість вас
залишилась і ми стільки поважних
спікерів для вас залишили до самого
кінця для того щоб зробити тепер новий
формат для нас як для асоціації дуже
важливо щоб в нас була комунікація для
того щоб ми ви дійсно їхали з відповід з
отримавши відповіді на всі запитання
тому пані Любомира манзі хотіла би
запросити усіх остальних хто ще
залишився ми бачимо їх на столиках щоб
вони
повернулись пробуйте пробувати Шановні
колеги Доброго дня Я сподіваюся що ви
збачно поїли але я звертаюся до
керівників областей делегацій з областей
поверніть будь ласка або Попросіть
повернутися до залу тих осіб які з вами
приїхали Я думаю що зараз ще не було
жодного автобуса або жодної машини яка
би поїхала з відсілля тому будьте такі
ласкаві вони в межах Я розумію що люди
хочуть подивитися і На море Але будьте
такі ласкаві Давайте ми відпрацюємо і
тоді будемо вже з почуттям виконаного
обов'язку відпочивати Дякую дкую Дякую
ми всіх чекаємо в
залі ну що ж я тоді задам перше
запитання пані Тетяно вам
питання до мос коли заклади я об'єднав
декілька запитань в одне коли заклади
загальної загальної середньої освіти
отримають нові рецептурники для
складання чотирьохтижневого меню а також
де можна ознайомитися з чотирьохтижневим
меню від Євгена клопотенка Я думаю що
зможете разом відповісти так так так так
колеги
дивіться щодо
рецептурників Міністерство охорони
Здоров України на адресу обласних
державних адміністрацій надсилало
лист із зазначенням нормативно-правового
акту
Міністерства
економіки в якому зазначено якими
рецептурними збірниками можна
користуватись які внесені до цього
відповідного наказу Крім того в цьому
листі роз'ясненні було зазначено яким
чином ви маєте право змінювати ті
рецептури Які наприклад є в Старих
рецептурних збірниках адже вони не
відповідають наприклад по кількості солі
або по кількості цукру або Можливо
навіть там по кількості жирів тобто цей
лист роз'яснення був Я сподіваюсь що
якщо обласні державній адміністрації
його ще не направили до кожної громади
да то будь ласка зробіть це якщо
потрібно то ми можемо його
продублювати щоб люди могли
користуватись щодо
меню примірного чотиритижневого який ми
розробляли спільно з Євгеном Клопотенко
ситуація наступна ті технологічні карти
на страви і вироби які запропонував
Євген Наразі ще проходять державно Сане
підексперртизу в
держпроцспоживслужбі для чого це
робиться тому що ці технологічні карти
мають набути якогось юридичного значення
відповідно Вони знаходяться на
санепдекспертизі в процесі після після
того як отримають Євген отримає цей
висновок сани пдекспертизи на ці
технологічні
карти він його команда передадуть їх
офіційно вже до Міністерства охорони
здоров'я Міністерство охорони здоров'я
надійшли на погодження примірно
рекомендоване меню до тих центральних
органів виконавчої влади які задіяні до
реформи А це саме мо змін економіки і
держпроцспоживслужби і після цього буде
воно опубліковано на офіційному сайті
Міністерства охорони здоров'я і
надіслано листом до всіх зацікавлених
органів і до обласних державних
адміністрацій з проханням довести до
відома всіх зацікавлених хто його очікує
чудово ви випередили Дякую за розгорнуту
відповідь ви випередили ще два запитання
які стосувалися колеги не ображайтесь я
їх не зачитую які стосувалися коли ми
отримаємо технологічні карти
тому якщо дозвоните дуже коротко просто
хочу сказати що до нас приєдналася пані
Владислава
поаплодуємо
що примірне чотиритижневе меню для
осіннього періоду для дітей віком від
одного до 6сти років ну тобто для
закладів дошкільної освіти вже було
фіналізовано і вчора надіслано на
погодження до зацікавлених органів разом
з технологічними картами під це меню і
Ми сподіваємось що найближчим часом Ми
отримаємо відповідь і надішлемо його вам
для використання Дякую Ну це супер
новина дякую пані
Тетяно заклади дошкільної освіти давно
чекають такого документа тому маємо
надію що все пройде гладко у мене
запитання яке стосується саме
закупівель запитання таке тестування
уповноважених осіб коли як чи не буде
відтерміновано прокоментую хвилиночку що
ми знаємо що до кінця фінансового
року у нас мають припинити своє
існування тендерні комітети ми повністю
переходимо до позиції уповноважена особа
при здійсненні закупівель положення про
уповноважену вже розроблене наскільки я
пам'ятаю пане Олександру правильно
питання про тестування воно обов'язкове
буде не буде що в планах знаєте не
знаєте будь ласка Прокоментуйте Дякую за
запитання так дивіться дійсно з
наступного року у нас відбуваються певні
зміни в законодавстві про а в законі
України про блічні закупівлі і з
наступного року у нас з'являються
уповноважені особи що зараз
зараз положення знаходиться на
погодженні міністерстві юстиції України
і сподіваємося що досить скоро воно вже
буде погоджене і з'явиться у нас на
сайті щодо
питань взагалі яким чином буде
організований
процес процес буде відбуватися через
майданчик відповідна особа яка хоче
стати уповноважено особи проходить
тестування за результатами тестування
вона отримує доступ систему і може
користуватися ну здійснювати відповідні
проводити відповідні закупівлі Якщо
особа не здає тестування У неї є
можливість перездати цей іспит протягом
чотирьох днів буде можливість
АА наступне щодо питань підготовка да
які це будуть запитання і так далі після
того як буде погодження відповідне
положення одразу з'явиться інформація на
сайті з переліком відпо в тестових
питань Тобто їх може можна бути
опрацювати підготуватися і далі
авторизуватися у системі Пройти
тестування і стати повноцінно
сертифікованою уповноваженою особою дуже
дякуємо за
відповідь оресте будь ласка можемо
можемо запитання адресую до
дпсс чому за якість питної води в школі
має відповідати школа якщо її чають
комунальні
підприємства
[оплески]
Геніально добре що звернулася до
держпоспоживслужби ми не є органом який
формує політику ми є органом який
виконує політику Ми так само отримуємо
такі ж настанови як і
ви я певна що от коли виступали папена
міністри от треба було задати цей вопрос
до них з іншої сторони зараз немає змін
будемо діяти як є згідно чинного
законодавства А можна враховувати такі
побажання на перспективу А як же дуже
будемо вам вдячні Владислава Валеріївна
у мене питання до антимонопольного а
прокоментувати Да будь ласка Тетяна
Скапа МОЗ може прокоментувати я ну хочу
трошки трішечки доповнити прокоментувати
Дивіться якщо наприклад
виявляється
що за результатами дослідження питної
води яка відібрана в закладі освіти
виявлено
невідповідність для того щоби довести що
ця невідповідність не є проблемою
закладу освіти А є проблемою
постачальника питної води виробника
скажімо да питної води яку яка
постачається в заклад для цього доцільно
відібрати зразки до вводу в заклад
освіти і вже безпосередньо в самому за
закладі освіти ця ситуація ці два
аналізи і їх результати дозволять
отримати відповідь на запитання так вода
надходить невідповідна
від постачальника цієї води Чи можливо в
закладі освіти не відповідні
системи водопостачання і потребує заміни
наприклад вже внутрішня мережа
відповідно від цього вже і будуть
результати яким чином і хто має нести
відповідальність ДКУ дякую пані Тетяно я
б Навіть хотів добавити тому що ми
завжди рекомендуємо працювати з Так
званою водопідготовкою ми живемо в XX
столітті фільтрація води - це вже є Ну
обов'язковість тому якою би не була вода
яку постачає нам комунальне підприємство
ми в своїй школі кожна с школа вправі
поставити фільтрацію це не так дорого
коштує до прикладу А то що точно знаю
Майже у всіх школах Києва вже стоїть
водопідготовка і воду можна споживати в
принципі в принципі просто скрану але це
є на вході Ми отримали неякісну воду
Зато в школі в нас вода ідеальна дуже
добре якщо так питання до пані Ольги
Читайло державної уповноваженої мку як
можна пройти навчання за участю
представників антимонопольного комітету
не дуже зрозуміло чому хотілося б
навчитися Але я думаю що консультативні
якісь навчання все-таки ви ж могли б
щось прокоментувати будь ласка Ні я
розумію чому колеги хочуть навчитися
вони хочуть покращити свою закупівельну
діяльність і це ця ініціатива звичайно
нами вітається Оскільки ми дуже багато
скарг отримуємо фактично щодня І чим
краще працюватимете Ви тим менше роботи
буде у нас для того щоб організувати
навчання потрібно звернутись в
центральний апарат антимонопольного
комітету з відповідним запитом але
колеги будь ласка Я вас дуже прошу це не
буде навчання для якогось конкретного
окремого замовника ви збираєте всіх
замовників в регіоні і для них
комплексно ми проводимо
навчання дистанційно це будемо вже
варіювати в залежно від карантинного
режиму платно ні звичайно Ну ми як
державний орган для вас безкоштовно
можемо організувати навчання з питань
оскарження публічних закупівель які
тимпові помилки як колегія підходить до
розгляду скарги як аргументувати свою
позицію колегії приємно дуже хороша
новина Дякуємо пані Ольга Дякую Чи
планується пані любомиро запитання до
вас міністерству освіти Чи планується
переглянути формування штатних розписів
шкіл в частині кількості посад кухарів
адже нині розрахунки понад 50 дітей один
кухар відповідно складно люди пишуть про
те якщо ми говоримо про асортимент страв
і про нові норми і про новий підхід
складно з одним кухарем я Вла не
переглядала зміни які ми Міністерство
освіти і науки пере надіслало на
погодження до центральних органів
виконавчої влади про що йдеться ідеться
про зміни штатних розписів закладів
загальної середньої освіти в тому числі
введення посад фахівець з закупівель
тому що на сьогоднішній день без такої
особи практично нереально організувати
е роботу закладу який особливо веде
самостійну фінансову господарську ро
діяльність безперечно ви в громадах
маєте можливість по-різному організувати
цю
роботу
управління центр супроводу роботи шкіл
до
прикладу або фінансова автономія школи
тут за залежить від можливості і я
розумію що в місті і в селі ситуація
може бути різною Чому Тому що в місті
напевно легше спокійніше знайти фахівця
з того са з тої ті з закупівель але в
сільській території буде складніше тут
треба навпаки об'єднання зусиль для того
щоб організувати ці процеси тут можуть
Ну тут нема єдиного підходу тут Можуть
бути різні підходи і тому просто треба
пробувати
то ми чекаємо погодження
мерту і буквально Я думаю що наступний
тиждень Ну до двох тижнів цей документ
вийде це наказ МОНУ але юстований наказ
МОНУ зараз він є на погодженні
центральних органах виконавчої влади в
тому числі введення шеф-кухаря чудово
Дуже дякую гарна новина
супер Скажіть будь ласка якщо можна
прокоментувати 305 Постанову чи
правильно розуміє наш дописувач що
одноразове харчування в закладі
загальної середньої освіти - Це сніданок
навіть якщо його споживають о 13
годині е напевно я прокоментую
дякую в принципі Ніде в законодавстві не
передбачено що має бути саме сніданок
відповідно в 305-й постанові для того
щоби уникнути цього непорозуміння був
передбачений додаток номер девять для
організації одно одноразового харчування
і відповідно ви організовуєте харчування
в такому закладі освіти за додатком
номер девять немає значення це буде в 11
годині чи о 10тй чи у 13й але за за
нормами сніданку Да правильно ми
розуміємо ні там є окремий додаток для
одноразового харчування і там
повноцінний обід можна зробити
Спираючись на цей додаток пра що так в
принципі можна зробити і обід дуже дякує
а чи передбачає харчування учнів
5тий-11-й клас за рахунок бюджетних
коштів я на основі цього запитання Якщо
можна я сам на нього відповім я бачу
посмішки в залі ну тобто на мій погляд
запитання трішки некоректне тому
що школи у нас є комунальними і це
запитання більше до вас так Чи плануєте
ви в своїй громаді забезпечувати
харчування 5тий-11-й клас за кошт
субвенції Я думаю не таке не потрібно
надавати і А ще хочу від себе сказати
про досвід європейський в Європі Україна
одна з
країна яка найбільше витрачає на
харчування дітей в школі Чому Тому що в
Європі майже ніде не харчують за кошт
громад комунальний державний тільки не
захищені соціальні групи звісно ті хто
не спроможні Їх потрібно харчувати це
досвід єбровайський коли ми до нього
дойдемо це ну це це вже запитання тоді
якщо можна наступне запитання до вас
пані
любомиро чи буде державна субвенція на
придбання паруконвектоматів
гарне ми ми розрекламували
паруконвектомати і тут за тання і друге
запитання значить в цій записці чому на
рівні держави відбувається
дискримінація закладів загально
середньої освіти а саме шкіл кількістю
менше 200
учнів зрозуміла
[оплески]
дивіться
е перше Минулого року коли вводилася
субвенція на реконструкцію і обладна для
харчоблоків треба було знайти якісь
підібрати критерій тому було введено в
нас Ну ми не могли охопити всі школи
зразу тому були був введений критерій
200 і більше учнів безперечно як ми
виконаємо Цю умову будемо переходити до
наступного критерію Це буде вже 100 чи
150 дітей тобто тут буде будуть зміни
Безперечно ми розраховуємо на те що в
бюджеті наступного року буде субвенція
Ну не на
параконвектомати а На
обладнання для харчоблоків
а пам'ятаєте умовою використання цієї
субвенції було обладнання будь ласка і
30%
це реконструкція Ну щоб ця Кухня або
їдальня виглядали
але Мені прикро але я визнаю в окремих
випадках обладнання куплене і воно
стоїть в заходку і чекає на проведення
ремонтних робіт шановні голови
об'єднаних територіальних
громад так щоб воно не виходило з ладу
бо за рік-два ви скажете воно вже нам не
підходить будь ласка
погосподарськи
підійшли
зробили закликали батьків показали
результат Ну так щоб всі зрозуміли що ви
щось робите ви ж господарі Я впевнена що
ви робите тільки ми інколи не вміємо це
показати Дякую друга частина друга
частина цього запитання якщо можна пані
любомиро стосовно дискримінації менше
200 учнів Ну я сказала тобто перше ми
давайте витримаємо Цю умову на наступний
рік як будемо мати субвенцію будемо
понижувати цю до цей критерій вже
кількісно меншою кількістю
кількістно меншою кількістю учнів у
школі ну але мусимо якийсь критерій
задати для того щоб потім не бути Тобто
це те про що ми говорили проекти і
комплексний підхід не може бути закуля
дуже хочу і дуже Хочу наголосити власне
Пане оресте дякую про проектний підхід Я
вже оголосила про те що ми очікуємо таку
субвенцію на наступний рік поверніться в
школи
підіть Подивіться визначиться Можливо
комусь тільки вентиляцію Можливо комусь
параконвектомат тут є у вас є
у вас були різні можливості хтось вже
пішов дальше Хтось ще навіть не ступав
на цей шлях тому тут проектний
підхід проектна заява
обгрунтова знаєте Минулого року я була
членом комісії яка розглядала заявки
спроможна школа для кращих результатів
пам'ятаєте пане оресте телефонний
дзвінок ввечері коли ми не могли
зрозуміти що ж за обладнання треба в
школі одній з південних областей
вирішила подати нам
на проектній заявці обладнання яке
використовують в суші барах та тобто
коли готують при вас Тобто ви бачите як
відбувається приготування їжі і і ми
були дуже здивовані для чого в
школі таке обладнання яке було написано
в цій заявці Супер дякую пане любимире
пам'ятаєте про це Так звісно пам'ятаю у
мене запитання до Міністерства економіки
а точніше до пані Наталії щерової чи
розглядає мінекономіки Або дпсс можливо
можливість створення нових ресурсів для
навчання і впровадження хасп в закладах
освіти зараз система безпечності
сприймається лише як покаральна
чи можливе створення якихось нових
ресурсів для навчання хаспу Давайте я
тоді відповім а потім Міністерство
економіки Так у нас буде дижиталізований
проект ми над цим працюємо щоб у нас
була
освіта яку ви можете отримати Да не
треба там безпосередньо приїжджати до
офісів держпроспоже служби А крім того
ми проводимо онлайнсмінари і я ще можу
доручити в кожній області провести і
очні семінари задля того щоб допомогти я
можу в кожному територіальному органі
попросити виділити відповідальну людину
до якої можна звертатися по консультації
оберіть який найзручніше буде в ваших
областях чи містах формат ми можемо це
зробити загальноукраїнський Ми зробимо
ддижиталізованой Ну якщо можна впродовж
цього ж запитання аналогічне чи можна
розробити єдину програму звітності по
харчоблоку
або програму по складанню меню схожі
питання в принципі про програмне
забезпечення яке забезпечувало б роботу
харчоблоків і меню Чи можемо ми на
перспективу планувати що воно у нас у
нас таки такий софт колись
з'явиться хто може відповісти будь ласка
да разом спільно з моном і з мозом ну
тобто щоб це було єдини формат Ну там не
тільки від держпроспоживслужби дякує Я
коротко прокоментую пане оледре будь
ласка Ми насправді в процесі підготовки
примірної документації конкурсних торгів
яка одна з них знаходиться зараз вже на
фінальному етапі і інш ще в процесі
розробки а в технічних критеріях
прописували рекомендацію що
рекомендується школам під час надання в
отримання відповідних послуг з
харчування передбачити можливість софту
який може здійснювати контроль за тією ж
якістю обсягом тієї чи іншого послуги
або обсягом тієї чи іншої продукції яку
необхідно закупити більш того наскільки
мені відомо по місту Києву вже
реалізуються такі проекти у школах і
навіть є школа в
якій батьки можуть прийти подивитися
повністю весь процес приготування їжі
а-а батьки можуть е-е навіть прийняти
участь у так званому брокеражі тобто що
Е що готується по фіналу з тих продуктів
і що отримують дітки під час обіду
або вечері або сніданку А тобто софт Він
звичайно необхідний тому що за допомогою
програмних рішень можна більш ефективно
планувати
обсяги продукції яку необхідно закупити
та та послуга яка має бути надана нашим
дітям у школах дякую
дякую питання до вас пані Тетяно облік
виконання норм харчування в 305-й
постанові зазначення що
здійснюється в нетто а в меню
викладається в Брутто і тут є серія
таких запитань і нерозумінь що що до
нетто і Брутто точно так само як про 305
Постанову пишуть що сік в нас видається
в літрах а не в грамах відповідно коли
ми його розраховуємо згідно постанови в
мілілітрах а потім переводимо до
прикладу сік 200 мл переводимо в грами в
нас ми отримуємо 204 г відповідно це не
відповідність і дуже складно з цим
працювати Що можете прокоментувати Да я
можу
прокоментувати наступне колеги
відповідно до пункту 11-го я перепрошую
я зачитую просто я не пам'ятаю на на
пам'ять Постанову щодо пунктом 11-м
порядку організації харчування
передбачено що контроль за дотриманням
норм харчування здійснюється на в
журналі обліку виконання норм харчування
який заповнюється щодня на підставі меню
розкладу якщо ми прочитаємо Визначення
що ж таке це меню розклад це визначення
цей термін також наведений в порядку
організації харчуо який затверджений
постановою 305 то меню розклад я не буду
зачитувати повністю цей термін але меню
розклад він містить інформацію про вагу
про масу продукту в нетто і в Брутто
відповідно дякую по меню розкладу і
можна здійснити контроль за виконанням
норм дякукую Дякуємо питання Сергію
Миколайовичу шкарлету адресувалося в
рамках спроможної школи тільки чотири
заклади в чотирьох громадах Полтавщини з
60ти отримали державну підтримку ну
мається на увазі мабуть фінансування як
діяти громадам яким при наявності всього
необхідного пакету документів без
пояснень було відмовлено у фінансуванні
в рамках цієї субвенції підпис голова
громади територіальної Ну ми Мабуть
переадресуємо це запитання пану дмитру
луніну поскільки ваша територія Можливо
ви краще розумієте специфіку чому цим
закладам все-таки не дістались кошти
державної субвенції будь ласка Ну я
нагадаю механізм як
визначаються проекти Тобто всі громади
подають проекти потім згідно критеріїв
які у нас є Ми
визначаємо рейтинги тих проектів які ми
бачимо згідно вимог і критеріїв потім
цей перелік надаємо в мон і далі в моні
створюється комісія яка в яку входять
Мені здається народні депутати які потім
затвер
остаточно цей перелік Ну ми знаємо що
коштів у нас не вистачає будуть
задоволені ті хто Кого обрали і будуть
незадоволені тих кого не обрали я вам
хочу сказати що з всіх проектів які
подаються у нас на державні
субвенції
часто скажемо так перемагають ті які
зроблені якісно та комплексно Якщо ви
хочете вигравати скажемо так субвенції
якщо можна так сказати то робить більш
найкращі проекти а не я якісь заплатки
наприклад там замінити там 10 вікон або
зробити частину Даха Ну звісно коли є
більш якісні проекти ну ніхто не буде
обирати там частину даху або якусь
кількість віку тобто в пріоритеті
комплексний підхід до вирішення проблеми
правильно розуміємо да Дякуємо за це
чудова інформація тому що до нас деколи
звертаються і є такі громади які уже
працюють з технологічною економічною об
обґрунтацією своїх обґрунтовують свої
проекти звертаються це до нас так само
за консультаціями тобто коли зробили
проект також його обґрунтовують і І це
чудово тобто коли ми не не просто як
правильно сказали замінюємо вікна А коли
ми даємо інформацію про те чому ми
хочемо зробити цей харчоблок що він нам
дасть І гарантуємо про те що в нас буде
асортимент їжі їжа буде свіжа ми будемо
дотримуватись норм Це чудово
а пані владиславо до вас запитання Чи
отримали регіональні відділення
держпроцспоживслужби документи щодо
а поступового введення нових
норм Ну так бо там навіть міністри коли
виступали в самому початку да вони
говорили да Що там перше були проведені
тендери і тому там буде поступове
введення новогоменю скоріш за все старт
у нас буде 1 січня територіальні органи
з цим обізнані це загальний документ
який надійшов на
держпоспоживслужбу він автоматично
розсилається на всі обласні відділення
як я вже говорила тут присутні всі
керівники по
областях які у нас сьогодні і Одеська і
Миколаївська і Херсонська і Полтавська і
Кіровоградська ви можете підійти в них
перепитати Дуже дякуємо у мене таке
запитання зараз подумаємо кому його
адресувати чи не виникнуть проблеми при
закупівлі соків йогуртів з низьким
вмістом цукрів як передбачено норма
нормою хліба цільно-зернового з ви
вмістом харчових волокон та обмеженим
вмістом солі адже на сьогодні дуже
обмежена кількість виробників продукції
Які яка б відповідала цим нормам ми
можемо попросити пана едему адаманова
прокоментувати Можливо у вас є приклади
конкретні по прозоромаркету А якщо ні то
тоді і пане Олександр мін економіків
будь ласка доброго всім дня Дякую за
запитання насправді дуже розуміємо цю
проблематику тому що самі кожен день
щось закуповуємо і це дійсно може бути
проблемою як ми з цим працюємо ми
передбачали що може бути Така проблема
там є в меню і безлактозне молоко є
багато нових речей де не так багато
постачальників на даний момент
прозорамаркеті безпосередньо по
продуктам харчування у нас 300 плюс
постачальників це не так багато але ну
кожен день ця кількість збільшується
коли ви маєте дуже складний предмет
закупівлі дійсно вам потрібна
конкуренція але якщо ви можете знайти
хоча би три постачальника Цього вже
достатньо щоб забезпечити нормальний
рівень стаття четверта закону дозволяє
вам робити ринкові консультації
зустрічайтеся з ними Запрошуйте зараз в
ковідний період всі в зумах в Google
мітах Це дуже легко насправді не думайте
що якщо у вас складний предмет закупівлі
ви просто оголосили це в prozоor і всі
чекали поки ви оголосите і прибігли ну
такого не буде по складних предметах
закупівлі треба трошки трошки
попрацювати потрібно зробити аналіз
ринку позапрошувати всіх постачальників
заявити про себе і пропрацювати технічну
частину щоб вона не обмежувала
конкуренцію і ще дуже важлива річ коли
ви виписуєте якусь вимогу по
сертифікатах чи По
документах зважайте що ну норми завжди
оновлюються є технічний регламент є
декларації і напевну групу товарів це
законодавство воно постійно оновлюється
і і вимагаєте лише те що дійсно
і не вимагайте те що взагалі не
прописано в законодавстві щось додатково
Ну наприклад є певні замовники вимагають
сертифікати іo по певних групах там Ну
класифікаторах там по менеджменту
наприклад 9001 на деякі товари Ну де це
взагалі не потрібно ну це теж зважайте
некла Не ускладнюйте життя
постачальникам і собі і антимонопольному
комітету який потім розглядається скарги
Так пані Ольга хоче прокоментувати Так
звичайно хочукоменту Оскільки ми потім
розглядаємо скарги на такі процедури
прозоромаркет до нас не оскаржується
оскаржується звичайні українські сторги
і у нас в цілому в цьому контексті є
такий дуже стандартний уніфікований
підхід він застосовується як до
обладнання до техніки так само якщо
виникне проблема з продуктами харчування
він також буде застосовуватись
дуже важливо щоб ви на етапі попередньої
роботи з ринком зібрали необхідні
документи що я маю на увазі тендерна
документація має бути сформована у
спосіб так в той в такий спосіб щоб всім
в сукупності технічним характеристикам
відповідали принаймні два виробники
навіть не три два і це на це у вас має
бути документальне підтвердження від
виробника
наприклад умови технічні умови за якими
виготовляється продукт цей документ ви
потім надаєте органу оскарження якщо
надхо ходить скарга якщо скарга не
надходить ви себе заздалегідь упередили
від будь-яких ризиків Якщо ж таких
документів не буде ми будемо вас просити
змінювати документацію А все це все
додаткові строки Олександре А у нас є
такі виробники скажіть Бо так я і не
почула відверто кажучи відповіді
Дивіться Ну тут питання досить відкрите
і все залишить в першу чергу від того де
це відбувається в якому регіоні А І от
одем він почав говорити
дійсно в законі України про публічні
закупівлі передбачено що замовник перед
проведенням закупівлі може проводити
вивчення пропозиції конльтаці з нком це
це по суті ну по суті це так званий
аналіз ринку хто є на ринку хто
теоретично і потім фактично зможе
поставити цю продукцію зазвичай у
замовників на це просто фізично немає
часу Чому Тому що процедур закупівель
багато зазвичай деякі люди проводять і
закупівлі не тільки ж продуктів
харчування там іде і питання по
електроенергії і по поточній діяльності
То того чи іншого закладу і по
капітальним ремонтам і так далі І на це
не звертають увагу а це призводить в
подальшому до того що формується
фінальна документація конкурсних торгів
по якій по суті ніхто ну не прийде Не
може зайти так не може зайти а або інша
ситуація інша ситуація - це можливо
навіть в деяких випадках
неумисне включення до до документації
конкурсних торгів дискримінаційних умов
тобто не досить детально Проаналізована
чинна нормативна правова база
висилаються додаткові вимоги до
потенційного учасника якісь ліцензії які
вже скасовані або якісь технічні
регламенти які скасовані і по результату
Ми навіть маємо переможця але він не
відповідає тим вимогам тому що він
просто фізично не може завантажити ті чи
інші документи які вже не існують дуже
вичерпна Дякуємо ще раз чуємо інформацію
про те
що закупівлі - це професія якій потрібно
вчитись постійно і головний напрямок на
21-22 рік який повинні для себе
управлінці поставити так би мовити як
прі
це професіоналізація закупівель Від
цього залежить результат Дякую якщо
можна дуже коротка репліка одна ми
казали на початку питання були різні
товари Да там
йогурти сухофрукти і так далі дивіться
тут дуже обережно дуже необхідно
підходити до визначення предмету
закупівлі тому що певні товари можуть
знаходитися в різних групах ДК держав
класифікатора товарів робіт і послуг і
відповідно якщо вони знаходяться в
різних групах то об'єднувати їх в одну
процедуру не
варто Тобто ми можемо об'єднати в одну
процедуру виключно ті товари які
знаходяться в відповідній групі ДК і
відповідно поділити їх на
лоти і за результатами вже проводити оцю
розширену процедуру але якщо товари
знаходяться в разних групах ДК це може
бути порушенням порядку визначення
предмету Дякую якраз ви відповіли
Вибачте На наступне моє питання Я його
озвучу щоб людина зрозуміла що ця
відповідь прозвучала чи можна здійснити
закупівлю продуктів харчування за кодом
1581406 продукти харчування різні чи
слід розбити на дрібні молоко овочі
картопля і так далі ще раз дуже коротко
якщо в одному в одному ДК знаходяться
всі товари ді діліть процедуру на лоти
будь ласка проводьте єдину процедуру
якщо товари знаходиться в різних ДК будь
ласка окремі процедури пані Ольга щось
хотіла ще додати Вибачте Так я б хотіла
б ще додати що колеги ми бачимо як орган
оскарження що деякі замовники у тому
числі заклади освіти роблять одну
системну помилку держава дає бізнесу
сигнал готуйтесь Так випускайте саме
таку продукцію наприклад хліб має
відповідати таким-то таким-то базовим
характеристикам але замовник формуючи
тендерну доку ментацію додає якісь свої
додаткові вимоги наприклад вимоги до
упаковки яка вона має бути який має бути
цей брусочок хлібу Ми дуже багато бачили
таких
додаткових вимог Які фактично
дискримінували постачальників на
закупівлях зтим лабораторій які
відбувалися минулого і позаминулого року
тому будь ласка держава не просто так
визначає мінімально мінімальні базові
технічні характеристики продукту це для
того щоб ринок міг підготуватись і ви не
мали цієї проблеми з оскарженням двох
виробників продукції Дякую але тоді якщо
можна запитання від асоціації тому що ми
о кожен раз коли ми в регіонах чуємо це
запитання і Тому адресую поки що я його
не не бачу тут але адресую його вам
міністерству економіки антимонопольному
комітету задають питання
нам громади як їм працювати замовникам з
закупівлею обладнання якщо вони не
включають туди навчання тобто в їхнє
питання ми щось закупили приїдьте
Допоможіть нам Навчіть ми задаємо
питання чому вас не навчили
постачальники працювати з цим
обладнанням Як ви бачите розгорнутий
тобто коли ми не закуповуємо просто
одиницю техніки якусь а
комплекс комплекс
цілий я бачу все як прописання в
тендерній документації умова ее
проведення тендеру забезпечення тендеру
є це дуже гарне запитання насправді і це
не тільки ну це не тільки по обладнанню
харчуванню це по кондиціонерам така сама
проблема чи можна зі встановленням їх
купувати чи не можна по обладнанню чи
можна включати навчання чи не можна
відповідно до чинного законодавства
можна єдина умова якщо супутна послуга
не дорожче ніж 50% від вартості цього
обладнання ну умовно якщо обладнання
коштує 100 000 грн і всі супутні послуги
які ви вимагаєте коштують до Ну там 49
000 грн умовно тоді можна якщо вийде так
що послуга супутна дорожче ніж
обладнання хоча б там на 51% або на 100
то то то тоді не можна тоді це різні
коди cpv це різні закупівлі і тоді якщо
вже говорити про якісний показник Ось
цього навчання тобто може вимагати
замовник і описувати саме ту необхідну
якість так тобто якісь критерії якості
цього навчання Бо можна прийти сказати
ми Ми навчили якби приймайте роботу а
потрібно працювати з якісним показником
якщо можна можна можна вимагати щоби ті
люди які будуть інсталювати то навчати
вони були сертифіковані виробником
абсолютно кожен виробник у світі він
сертифікує інженерів а своїх інженерів і
ці інженери вони не належать якійсь
одній компанії тобто вони працюють в
офіційному представництві якогось
виробника Це абсолютно нормально і дуже
класна порада якщо ви зробите просто
чекліст це буде додатком на дого щоб всі
на березі розуміли що саме ви будете
перевіряти і ви хочете і просто і цей
чеклист можна також завантажувати разом
з вимогами да Якщо це додаток до
договору проект договору є складом
тендерної документації це можна ми
виріжемо оцю частинку вашого спічу і
будемо на кожній презентації в регіонах
її демонструвати дуже дякую запитання
потребує вирішення питання щодо
достатності отримання порцій з меню
школярам е
зрозуміло тобто велика кількість дітей в
школі не встигають вони отримати їжу і
відповідно їжа вони не встигають її за
час перерви отримати і
з'їсти Я напевно відповім сам на це
запитання якщо можна тому що в нас є
досвід розкажу вам такий приклад з з
такою проблемою ми зіштовхнулись коли до
нас звернулась Академія сухопутних
військ місто Львів це 5 000 е курсантів
а трьохразове харчування тобто три рази
в день по 5 000 людей нам треба
пропустити через одну столову Звичайно
що Курсанти люди і військові
організовані це не діти в першому класі
але забезпечили ми це різними потоками
тобто різними входами і забезпечили ми
це різними роздато роздатковими лініями
Тобто де ми відвели холодні процеси від
гарячих процесів тому що по-іншому
забезпечити це неможливо приклади такі
яскраві як забе гарно організовані
роздаточні лінії можна в тому в в нашій
столиці в Києві особливо на лівому
березі є величезні школи в які
харчуються по 15ся дітей приїжджати туди
проситись відвідати як референсуб'єкт і
подивитись як організоване харчування
там тобто все все це можливо потрібно
тільки
включати якби це питання директора
забезпечити харчування і і час
відповідно потрібно підвищувати
кваліфікацію директору їздити і
ознайомлюватись з варіантами Дуже
дякуємо морести такі питання які
стосувуються і місцевого аспекту і
проведення закупівель в принципі чи може
засновник через місцеву програму
фінансувати комунальне підприємство з
надання послуг харчування в закладах
освіти без проведення тендерних доку
закупівель Дмитро сергійовичу ви знаєте
цей нюанс Про місцеві програми чи
можливо
е попросимо пана Олександра можна да
дяку дуже коротко е дивіться
дійсно відповідь на це питання вкриється
У правильності розставлених слів в цьому
питаннігу перше Програма вона є існує
вона затверджена місцевим органом в цій
програмі чітко визначене що певне
комунальне підприємство буде надавати
послуги у закладах освіти наскільки мені
відомо такий проект Навіть є живий на
території України в певній області в
певному місті є дійсно комунальне
підприємство яке надає послуги по всім
школам по харчуванню дітей до функції
цього підприємства входить в тому числі
і проведення відповідних закупівель на
закупівлю товарів і і робіт і послуг які
пов'язані з харчуванням дітей у школах і
це по суті централізація Так звана
централізація процедури харчування дітей
через комунальне підприємства я ми
розмовляли про це з колегами в
міністерстві економіки чи дійсно це
ефективний шлях тобто що
відбувається орган місцевого
самоврядування передає кошти та певні
обов'язки свому комунальному
підприємству якщо тут здійснюється
ефективний контроль за комунальним
підприємством і за результатами які ми
повинні побачити у школах у вигляді
посмішок дітей тоді все добре якщо це
іде асигнування через програму в
комунальні підприємства і далі
ми ну я дуже
так кажіть як є тут залишились всі свої
скромно скажу да Якщо ми бачимо посмішки
а повне розчарування тоді необхідно
повністю переглядати підхід щодо такої
програми тут
насправді важливий менеджмент ну
управлінський менеджмент в в частині
реалізації цієї цієї програми і ще один
момент тут є питання щодо конкуренції
Чому Тому що певна сума коштів через
програму виділяється саме комунальному
підприємству А чи ми не не розглядали
оттут і необхідно проводити по суті
Вивчення ринку Чому Тому що можуть бути
приватні суб'єкти господарювання які
дійсно можуть і якісніше і можливо і
дешевше і можливо більш оптимізовано
надавати ці послуги у школах тому тут
дуже велика відповідальність лягає як на
орган місцевого самоврядування так і на
комунальне підприємства на органі лежить
по суті саме вибір що це буде КП А на КП
лежить повна відповідальність за
результати які побачать діти у своїх
тарілках дякую дякую дуже вичерпно ДКУ
а запитання до Міністерства економіки і
Міністерства освіти разом подиви
подивитесь кому на що зручніше
відповісти а як забезпечити підвищення
кваліфікації шкільних кухарів Хто де
коли і Чи планується підвищення
заробітної плати після проходження
курсів якщо такі запровадять це дві
різні людини писали але Ну от воно
продовжується кваліфікація кухаря А якщо
він піде працювати до шкільної їдальні
тобто чи якщо йому піднімлять якщо він
піднімлять кваліфікацію чи не піде він з
шкільної їдальні працювати
деінде відповідь на це питання
спробую дати отже є два варіанти
організації шкільного харчування перше в
штаті школи Ви маєте
кухарів друге кейтерінг ви замовляєте
послугу у випадку якщо ви маєте в штаті
школи
кухарів
пропоную закумулювати зусилля
Департаменту освіти на рівні Обласної
Державної адміністрації і визначити до
прикладу в кожній області одне або два
базових заклади професійної освіти де
готуємо
кухарів і на тих і в тих закладах
організувати підвищення кваліфікації
кухарів ви можете укласти як об'єднана
територіальна громада якщо Це ваші
кухарі укласти угоду з закладом
професійної освіти і організувати
підвищення кваліфікації ба більше
майстри виробничого навчання закладу
професійної освіти з задоволенням
приїдуть до вас і навчать цих кухарів
підвищить їхню професійну майстерність у
випадку це якщо Це ваші праців
тоді ви за них можете Ну організувати та
таку процедуру у випадку якщо ви
замовляєте послугу або
кейтерінг тоді в тендерній документації
прописуйте що кухарі які будуть
здійснювати організацію харчування в
такій-то школі
мають мати досвід мати підвищення
кваліфікації впродовж там до прикладу
року не детирічного віку а впродовж
останнього року але це ви прописуєте
тоді в тендерній документації тоді
безперечно ви не можете за них заплатити
ви можете
мотивувати підприємця який надає вам
послуги але найкраще це правовий шлях це
тендерна документація і кожен відповідає
за своє пані любомире тоді продовження
наступнеступне запитання про підвищення
заробі Чи планується підвищення
заробітної плати так як це напряму я
підтвердження цих слів Це напряму
впливає на ринок тобто дуже складно
найти кухаря в школу з ринку де до
прикладу в ресторані заробітня плата
Више е зараз перше змінюємо штатні
розміси а потім будемо пла працювати
точно обіцяю що будемо працювати над
заробітніми платами Я розумію що ця
заробітна плата яка є зараз в кухаря
важко знайти кухаря на на цю заробітну
плату в школі бо реально треба
наробитися дякую дякую у мене запитання
до антимонопольного комітету чому
бувають випадки коли Антимонопольний
комітет при розгляді однакових скарг дає
різні висновки і різні рішення Якими
можуть бути дієзамовника в цьому випадку
ну конкретизації більше ніякої Ольга
немає вибачте можли
є сенс поспілкуватись з автором пані
Ольга в доступі будь ласка Ну дійсно
якщо потрібно розібрати якісь конкретний
випадок Давайте ви підійдете до мене і
ми подивимось що трапилось але загалом я
хочу сказати наступне ми маємо
Олександра підправте якщо я буду
плутатись в цифрах в Україні 30 000
замовників кожен замовник закуповуючи
моркву під себе самостійно формує
індивіду гально унікальну тендерну
документацію такого немає в жодній
країні ЄС Звідки ми ретранслюємо
законодавство на ці 30 000 замовників ми
маємо 200 000 учасників Можливо навіть
вже більше і виходить що це теж
унікальні тендерні пропозиції
відмінність в одній Комі іноді має дуже
суттєву роль тому Найперше що хоче
Антимонопольний комітет це щоб у нас
була універсальна тендерна документація
яку замовники зможуть
ретранслювати в свою під час оголошення
тендерних закупівель а учасники зможуть
уні сформувати універсальну тендерну
пропозицію Яку пропонуватимуть вам всім
Дякую та смілива жінка бачите за весь
антимонопольний відстояли Орести будь
ласка тут російською я тому перекладу як
система контролю харчування в школі
як буде контролювати система харчування
в
школі продукти молочні продукти сир і
так дальше які не будуть відповідати
якості це до
держпроцспоживслужби ми отбираємо зразки
ми перевіряємо їх в лабораторію ми
видаємо
результат я правильно да зрозуміла про
тобто яким чином будуть контролюватись
неякісні продукти Ну я думаю що це
банальне запитання але це стандарт
процедура ну тобто всі з нею
стискалися так у мене теж непросте
запитання вірніше навіть два чи потрібно
погоджувати графік постачання продуктів
з
держпроцспоживслужбою учаснику відкритих
торгів до проведення аукціону та до
укладання договору тобто на етапі подачі
документів ви знаєте цці ці нюанси пані
Владислава
ні Можливо тоді тендерів ми це такого не
робимо ви не не вимагаєте а можливо
мінкономіки прокоментуєрто кажучи Вперше
це мабуть прописано в документації
конкурсних торгів така вимога була що
необхідно перед завантаженням я так
розуміє система поправляйте мене тут чи
Скоріше так да замовник ви замовник
вимагає
надати документи які вже погоджені з
дпсс нуце ну теоре тично це могло бути
меню Наприклад якщо закуповувалась
послуга з кейтерингу яка передбачала
одразу розробку меню то теоретично і і
замовник просив дати меню то це меню
теоретично могло а все ін конкретний
випадок Може тут є автор цього запитання
бо такли і подібне питання для чого
потрібно погоджувати з дпсс перелік
постачальників адже вони вже є
переможцями
торгів Ну я думаю що відповідь закладена
сама в запитання да прозвучало
якнайменше п'ять запитань да Що робити
якщо визначений постачальник не був
добропередним і там був
недоброякісним Тому задля того щоб був
постійний контроль Так ми це
перевіряємо чудово пані Тетяно запитання
до
вас Шановна пані Тетяно чому 305
постанова додаток номер де вилучено
м'ясо свинини а також впродовження схоже
запитання чотирьохтижнеове меню
рекомендоване робочою групою експертів
не відповідає нормам харчування що
затверджено постановою 305 зокрема в
меню входить свинина та яловичиня а в
нормах цих продуктів Немає чому така
невідповідність тут запитання одне
другому суперечить тому внесіть ясність
бу ласка відповім ми в принципі вже з
автором запитання це
обговорили дивіться деятий додаток е
розраховувався на те що це Ну скажімо
той безкоштовний сніданок який
е звучить завжди і е у всіх на вустах во
одноразове харчування передбачаючи що це
був ну теоретично сніданок але в різних
регіонах це може бути по-різному в
залежності
від режиму роботи закладу освіти і від
режиму організації цього харчування
одноразового але ее коли розроблялось е
розроблялись норми Ми консультувались з
дієтологами залучалась асоціація
дієтологів України її голова і не тільки
і фахівці дієтологи ее наполягали на
тому що червоне м'ясо може пропонуватись
дітям виключно на обід відповідно не на
сніданок не на вечерю червоне м'ясо в
нормах харчування не передбачено тільки
птиця птиця або риба щодо того що
Міністерство охорони здоров'я
опублікувало На своєму сайті примірне
меню
з з ми вже якби розібрались з цього
приводу і це Ну не зовсім відповідає
дійсності тому що потрібно дивитись на
одноразове харчування яке розроблялось
відповідно до дев'ятого додатку Крім
того були ще там опубліковані примірні
меню для обідів там вже червоне м'ясо є
і має бути Дякую Тут наступне запитання
воно звучало так 305 постанова - Це
сніданок чи обід
тобто 305 постанова ее передбачає в
залежності від кратності харчування е
який організований в закладі це може
бути одно дтричотири або п'ятиразове
харчування на 5ть-шість або сім днів
тижня просто необхідно розібратись який
додаток вам потрібен якщо у вас в
закладі наприклад заклад працює пять
днів на тиждень і там організоване
одноразове харчування ви використовуєте
додаток номер дев'ять якщо
це триразове харчування ви
використовуєте додаток Ну я щодо школ кі
шкіл кажу додаток
номер п'ять якщо це наприклад заклад з
семиденним перебуванням дітей які
перебувають там цілодобово то ви
користуєтесь якщо я не помиляюсь
додатком сьомим або додатком восьмим все
чудово Ну все зрозуміло тобто постанова
305 вона уніфікована для всіх додатками
ми регулюємо конкретно той випадок який
потрібно Вам потрібно шукати саме
додаток той який вам потрібен у мене
запитання не скільки по системі
харчування А скільки скажемо так
життєзабезпечуючи для закладів освіти Чи
можливо врегулювати закупівлю
енергоносіїв наприклад закупили газ на
початку року по 7 грн за куп на сьогодні
18,85 необхідно провести нові відкриті
закупівлі до кінця року учасник під час
торгів знижує ціну після підписання
договору через пару днів піднімає
відповідно до закону чи не простіше
дозволити заключити додатко угоди про
збільшення Суми договорів і спокійно
працювати до кінця року Ну тут мене пару
днів смущають як термін для підняття
ціни але якщо хтось може відповісти будь
ласка ціна на газ дуже коротко
прокоментую дивіться чином
законодавством передбачено наступний
алгоритм і механізм якщо ціна змінюється
до 10% можна заключити так зване
додаткову уводу
і відповідно
скоригувати обсяги Енерго Сія ну в
даному випадку це у нас газ якщо я не
помиляюсь а далі все що вище необхідно
проводити відкриті торги чому так а тому
що в деяких випадках відбуваються
маніпуляції
Тобто Ну в принципі тут і повинен бути
спрацьований індикатор на системі
prozoro аномально низька ціна якщо
наприклад під час процедури закупівлі
хтось занижував досить давав пропозицію
дуже низьку яка ну не може бути надана
тоді спрацьовує цей індикатор і тоді
потенційному Переможцю необхідно
повністю деталізовано замовнику
аргументувати Що відбулося і як він це
збирається поставляти а-а стосовно
вирішення цього питання чи можна
відпустити цю ситуацію і
а- додатковими угодами до закінчити рік
да тобто е якщо ціна виросла на 20-30
40-50%
це може призвести до втрат бюджету так
званих тобто необхідно все-таки
проводити повторно відкриті торги
визначатися з переможцем і працювати з
цим переможцем єдине питання а в теорії
можна це прописати в документації
конкурсних торгів що якщо А ну тобто
учаснику необхідно реально
аргументувувати свою ціну яку він
пропонує під час проведення процедури
закупівлі Можна спробувати це виписувати
в документації конкусних торгів єдиної
Пігулки Що от саме давайте відпустимо цю
ситуацію більше ні чим Так чому Тому що
це приз може призвести до просто
ухилення від проведення процедур
закупівель і втрати конкуренції на
відповідному ринку тому що зараз ринок
газу він по суті конкурентний і
постачальників досить багато на
території України питання в виписуванні
до них вимог у документації конкурсних
торгів а саме відповідальності за
несвоєчасне неякісне надання товару чи
послуги
і тай в принципі все якщо це виписано
можна регулювати це через відповідний
договір і договірні відносини Дякую А
який передбачено термін на підняття ціни
90 дні Здається так я тут додам це дуже
класне запитання воно прям воно прям
супер класне тому що ми закуповуємо
електроенергію для всіх міністерств і ми
кожен день розуміємо цю проблему бо
навіть якщо на 10% можна підняти Не
можна Ну не можна змінювати загальну
ціну договору вам грошей не вистачає ви
зменшуєте обсяги і це дуже складно е
єдине що можу порадити е ви можете прямо
зайти в систему prozoro прописати
замовник державно установа професійні
закупівлі знайти наше рги по електричній
енергії наприклад да по енергоносіям є
дві пигулки ми використовуємо формульний
розрахунок Тобто ми прив'язуємося до
формули якщо Ціна за одиницю товару
змінюється там у оператора ринку
постачальники вони змагаються в аукціоні
за маржу Або вона плюсова Або вона
нульова Або вона мінусова і коли
змінюється ціна на ринку Вони мають
право тільки якщо вона змінилася за
одиницю оператора ринку а їх мамержа
вона ніколи не змінюється щоб вони не
закидали вас додатковими уго ми в законі
визначено що раз на 90 днів Але є
виключення для енергоносіїв це вас не
унебезпечує і друга пігулка вона дуже
класно дійсно працює Подивіться на
рамкові угоди як на інструмент який вас
хеджує від зміни ціни Поясніть чому є
два кейси рамкова угода Вона може бути
оголошена на очікувану вартість
приблизно умовно ви оголошуєте на роки і
приблизно розумієте що вам потрібно 100
000 грн на рік це не має бути уже у вас
у видатках в вашому бюджеті ви просто
собі спрогнозували і вказали 300 000 на
роки і кожне три місяці ви робите
відбори всередині рамки і навіть якщо
вам в цьому році не вистачило грошей
просто сесія ради вам додала коштів і ви
всередині ромкової просто докуповуєте це
дійсно працює спробуйте якщо не
розумієте Як це працює просто напишіть
нам на пошту в Гуглі напишіть державну
установу професійні закупівлі у нас там
є пошта напишіть щоб ми мали з вами з
з'язок ми направимо інструкцію як це
працює чудово Дуже дякую
а запитання таке в громаді функціонує
чотири школи в першій 170 в другій 135
15 і 40 учнів відповідно
наразі розпочали будівництво нового
харчоблоку опорного закладу яка доля
малочисельних шкіл в яких мало
навчається учнів як це вплине на
потужність нового харчоблоку та
відповідно Суми необхідної для
будівництва коштів Шановні колеги це
виключно індивідуально тому що ме ну
запитання Я не зрозуміла перспективу до
прикладу малень цих маленьких шкіл ви
хочете будувати новий харчоблок Для чого
Для того щоб зробити там одну одну кухню
яка ні ні вони будують Зараз будується в
громаді опорна школа в якій буде великий
харчоблок Наскільки я розумію порадити
потрібно їм можливість цей харчоблок
який може харчувати і і інші школи
маленькі е так безперечно можна це
врахувати давайте індивідуально ви ми
хочемо з асоціацією власне відпрацювати
в сільський варіант е ну тобто бо ми в
місті розуміємо як зробити фабрику кухню
але в селі інфраструктура дороги те час
довезення ну тобто там є інший комплекс
питань який необхідно вирішити ми
відпрацюємо такий алгоритм дій
оприлюдниємо його але якщо по цьому
конкретному випадку треба розуміти
демографічну ситуацію яка є в цій
громаді не треба тільки жити
сьогоднішнім днем треба розуміти що
завтра є потенційно прирість дітей Чи в
вас іде зменшення тобто тут треба
розуміти комплекс інфраструктура дороги
тобто перспектива Давайте ви підійдете
до мене Я буду після закінчення панелі
ми поговоримо і відпрацюємо вашу до
прикладу ситуацію Чудово дякую оми Ми
мусимо пришвидчуватись ми вже 10 хвилин
вийшли за рамки так у мене залишилось
єдине запитання Я хотіла б ним
фіналізувати якщо у тебе є будласка мене
ще тоді одне іласка зар давай
а шановні спікери до всіх адресується
запитання із 110 страв які надруковані в
збірнику клопотенка держпроцпоживслужба
наполя на можливості використання лише 2
однієї шість салатів одна перша страва 8
други далі чому інші страви Ми не маємо
права готувати в закладах до всіх
спікерів але мабуть до вас пані
Владислав А є автор цього запитання Ну
от
присутній Ага якщо можна А яка це
область яка кіроводсь можливо є сенс
поспілкуватися індивідуально так от пан
Ігор Прокоментуйте будь
ласка Я
думаю ми організуємо вам зустріч після
після і ви поспілкуєтесь дякуюку Я
просто думаю що це буде
ефективніше шановні друзі Я хочу
нагадати що у тих папочках які ви
отримали сьогодні при реєстрації єли
точок очікуваного від вас фідбеку про
сьогоднішній захід ми б дуже хотіли щоб
ви час швиденько проставили там позиції
так як ви оцінюєте роботу нашого форуму
а від себе Поки ви це робите хочу
прочитати вам з Тако інформацію яка
надійшла до нас Як запитання але вона не
зовсім запитання дуже змістовний семінар
але виїзд учасників треба було планувати
напередодні після безсонної ночі
інформація сприймається дуже важко
просимо врахувати побажання в подальшому
ми розуміємо що програму перебування
кожної делегації формували обласні
структури тому саме до вас шановні
колеги бережіть на своїх управлінців
Бережіть своїх керівників і менеджерів
давайте їм можливість насолодитися
чудовою Одесою Наступного разу або
іншими містами України і плануйте
раціонально свій час так щоб була
можливість і поспілкуватися і відпочити
і по працювати дуже вам вдячні за
сьогоднішні запитання маємо надію що ви
отримали відповіді на них і дуже вдячні
нашим спікерам що була скажемо так
конструктивна розмова сьогодні на цій
панелі маємо надію що ви ще потерпити
нас Протягом наступних
форумів які плануються на інші регіони
Дякую я вам хочу сказати кого зможемо
розрадити тим хто важко сюди добирався Я
розумію в нас величезна держава далеко
доїжджати організатори теж декілька
ночей не спали тому якщо це когось
розрадить тому Дякую всім за час
[оплески]
величезне Дякуємо очікуємо фідбек і до
наступних зустрічей шановні друзі хочу
нагадати що сьогоднішній форум
проводиться за підтримки першої леді
Олени зеленської та у співпраці з
міністерствам охорони здоров'я
міністерством економіки державною службо
можна аплодувати державною службою з
питань безпечності харчових продуктів та
захисту споживачів національної
асоціації громадського харчування
Одеської обласною державною
адміністрацію та одеською міською радою
Ну що ж друзі я вас вітаю ми добігли до
завершення як на мене дуже конструктивно
дуже продуктивно дякую ще раз спікерам
дякую модераторам було дуже цікаво для
себе почув дуже багато відповідей як
депутат обласної ради обов'язково буду
втілювати в себе на регіоні чого і вам
бажаю друзі додому і працювати гарного
настрою море там приїжджайте частіше до
оде і до
роботи і до зустрічі в Дніпрі напевно з
кимось гарного настрою всім до побачення
я від імені Міністерства освіти і науки
України хочу подякувати вам за
участь і хочу подякувати окремо Одеській
обласній державній адміністрації
за
неймовірно теплий прийом всіх учасників
з півдня
України вас бачити тільки спільно разом
ми
зможемо здійснити реформу коли ми будемо
про неї а говорити пояснювати і до цього
долучати не тільки управлінців
директорів шкіл і керівників органів
об'єднаних територіальних громад нашими
партнерами в цій реформі мають бути
батьки тому найважливіше закликаю вас
кому
нікувати з вашими громадами з батьками
зі школами пояснювати Суть не в
кількості зменшення цукру і солі реформа
а в зміні підході і формування здорових
здорової культури
харчування успіху нам в нашій
непростій
але потрібні реформи потрібній справі
Дякую за партнерство офісу першої леді
Дякую до зустрічі якщо у вас будуть
питання Міністерство освіти і науки
України готове
відповісти підготувати вам чеклисти якщо
є необхідність будь ласка ви знаєте що
ми готові до співпраці Дякую до зустрічі
Дякую Не забувайте залишати фідбеки на
двох білих столиках які знаходяться біля
сцени Дякую
всім